hey there future cyber Defenders welcome
back to our Channel today we have got an
exciting topic That's essential in our
ever evolving Digital World cyber
security engineer course whether you are
an aspiring IT professional or someone
looking to level up your skills this
video is your ultimate guide to become a
rock solid cyber security engineer we
will cover everything from the basics to
Advanced Techniques so make sure you hit
that subscribe button and ring the
notification Bell so you never miss our
latest tech insights and now let's di in
and before that if you are someone who
is interested in building a career in
cyber security by graduating from the
best universities or a professional who
alits to switch careers with cyber
security by learning from the experts
then try giving a short to Simply learns
postgraduate program in cyber security
with modules from MIT schwas man College
of Engineering the course link is
mentioned in the description box that
will navigate you to the course page
where you can you can find a complete
overview of the program being offered
and if you want to Kickstart your career
as a cyber security professional in 6
months then try giving a short to Simply
lar skeletic cyber security boot camp
the course link is mentioned in the
description box below that will navigate
you to the course page where you can
find a complete overview of the program
or the boot camp being offered and now
let's take a minute to hear from our
Learners who have experienced massive
success in their careers hi I'm Philip
I'm 61 years old and last year I upskill
with simply learns postgraduate program
at Cyber security after working 30 years
in the it sector and various different
profiles I'm happy to tell you that I
was able to clear and pass my cissp and
ccsp certification exams on the first
attempt after taking the course course I
must say was packed with practical
examples it was led by highly skilled
certified instructors with many
companies before security analyst and
architect on a contract basis but I
needed some stability which I got with
the job I just started with infosis as a
cyber security consultant happened on
the
first welcome to Simply learn if you
haven't subscribed yet hit the Subscribe
button below and let's start learning
about cyber security in one
minute with 4.9 billion people using the
internet in 2022 cyber security now has
to protect users against dangers like
viruses malware adwar and other
ransomware
attacks it involves techniques that help
secure various digital components like
networks data and and computer systems
from unauthorized access the financial
impact of these security breaches is
massive be it for an Enterprise
environments or for personal computers
deploying firewalls using web protection
suits and stronger encryption are just a
few ways to bolster your network
security even job roles in cyber
security Now range from ethnical hacking
to security analyst in big forms
providing ample growth opportunities to
anyone starting out in the cyber
security domain data is the new goal
imagine how much data is is generated by
just your smartphone every single day be
the pictures you click or the messages
you send nearly 41 million messages are
sent worldwide via WhatsApp every single
minute so safeguarding your personal
data against hackers has now become a
top priority did you know that India
leads the world when it comes to ethical
hackers with 23% of the worldwide
hacking population from India the top
ethical hackers earn more than twice of
what software engineers in India do but
what makes ethical hacking such a
demanding industry IAL hacking is the
process of taking security measures to
safeguard data and networks from
malicious cyber attacks the hackers use
every tool at their disposal to try and
breach the security barrier and find any
potential vulnerabilities the ethical in
ethical hacking denotes the lack of
malicious intent since these sessions
are often permitted by the system owner
or the network that is being hacked into
to fix any compromised entry points
before black hat hackers discover and
exploit them so what is a black hat
hacker you may ask a hacker who exploits
security vulnerability for monetary
gains like stealing or destroying
private data altering disrupting or
shutting down websites and networks is
known as a blackhead hacker on the other
end of the spectrum we have white hat
hackers who help people secure the
networks by stress testing the platform
against the most dangerous of cyber
attacks that is with their consent of
course but the most neutral of the bunch
are grayhead hackers who may not ask for
consent before snooping on a foreign
system but they do inform the owner if
they find any vulnerabilities sometimes
in exchange for a small
the security breaches have become less
and less prevalent thanks to rigorous
ethical hacking campaigns and corporate
awareness programs the ability to fix
critical security issues before blackout
hackers leverage them has saved
organizations billions of dollars Google
IBM Microsoft and virtually every major
corporation are looking to protect the
data so it shouldn't come as a surprise
that ethical hacking and information
security job market is set to rise by
nearly 28% by 2026 with salaries going
as high as as
$225,000 perom so that's ethical hacking
wrapped up in 2 minutes to catch more
bite size and detail videos on different
Technologies subscribe to Simply learn
and stay updated in today's digital age
where cyber threats Loom large
understanding ethical hacking is crucial
by dwelling into the world of ethical
hacking you gain a deep comprehension of
hacker techniques and vulnerabilities
which will enable you to strengthen your
security measures with a demand for
cyber Security Professionals soaring
learning ethical hacking opens doors to
wide range of exciting career
opportunities moreover it empowers you
to protect your personal data and
privacy while staying one step ahead of
evolving cyber threats by embracing
ethical hacking responsibility you
contribute to a safer digital
environment enhanced problem solving
skills and Foster continuous growth get
ready to embark on an exciting journey
into the realm of ethical hacking and
discover its immense value in today's
interconnected world and if you are
someone who's interested in building a
career in cyber security by graduating
from the best universities or a
professional who elects to switch
careers with cyber security by learning
from the experts then try giving a shot
to Simply learn's postgraduate program
in cyber security from Schwan's College
of computing in collaboration with EC
Council the link in the description box
page where you can find a complete
overview of the program being offered
take action upskill and get ahead but
before we begin if these are the type of
videos you would like subscribe button
and click on the Bell to never miss an
update from Simply learn without further
Ado let's get started with understanding
why you must learn ethical hacking there
are a wide variety of reasons of why to
learn ethical hacking let's discuss the
important ones firstly cyber security
awareness next strengthen security
measures career opportunities protection
of personal data awareness of cyber
threats ethical use of skills problem
solving and continuous learning now that
we have few important reasons let's
discuss each one of these important
reasons in a bit more detail firstly
cyber security awareness learning about
ethical hacking provides you with a deep
understanding of the techniques and
methods used by hackers this knowledge
helps you identify vulnerabilities in
your computer systems networks and
applications enabling you to better
protect them the next one is
strengthening security measures by
learning ethical hacking you can
actively contribute to improving the
security of computer systems ethical
hackers often identify weaknesses in
organizations networks and provide
recommendations for enhancing security
measures
followed by that we have career
opportunities the field of cyber saing
and there is a high demand for skilled
professionals by acquiring knowledge of
ethical hacking you can open up various
career opportunities in Industries such
as it security Consulting penetration
testing and incidence response next
ahead we have protection of personal
data understanding ethical hacking
techniques empowers you to safeguard
your personal data with privacy you can
Implement security measures to protect
your devices online accounts and
sensitive information from potential
attacks awareness of cyber threats is
the next one on the list the digital
landscape is constantly evolving and new
threats emerge regularly learning
ethical hacking helps you stay up toate
with the latest cyber threats attack
vectors and vulnerabilities enabling you
to proactive your measures to mitigate
the risks followed by that we have
ethical use of skills ethical hacking
emphasizes the responsible and legal use
of hacking techniques by learning
ethical hacking you gain the knowledge
of the ethical guidelines and legal
boundaries associated with cyber
security this ensures that your skills
are utilized for positive purposes
protecting individuals and organizations
from malicious attacks next on the list
is problem solving skills ethical
hacking requires critical thinking
problem solving and analytical skills
through learning ethical hacking you
develop a systematic approach to
identifying and solving complex security
issues which can be valuable in various
aspects of life and other technical
domains next and the list is continuous
learning and growth cyber security is a
dynamic field that demands continuous
learning to keep up with evolving cyber
threats learning ethical hacking ensures
that you remain engaged on ongoing
education and skill development
fostering personal and professional grow
growth now let's get into the important
aspect of today's tutorial that is
salary details for a certified ethical
hacker in the United States of America
the salary of an ethical hacker can be
based on various factors such as
experience skill level location industry
and the organization they work for
generally ethical hackers in USA tend to
earn higher salaries than other
countries due to the demand for Cy
Security Professionals entry-level
positions may start around $60 to
$80,000 perom while experienced
professionals with Advanced
certifications and specialized skills
can earn salaries exceeding
$150,000 per anom the salary of ethical
hacker in India can vary depending on
factors such as experience skill set
location and organization they work for
on an average a beginner level ethical
hacker in ending from 3 lakhs to 6 lakhs
perom as the gain gain more experience
and
expertise their salary can increase
significantly experienced ethical
hackers with several years of experience
and advanced certifications can earn
salaries ranging from 8 to 20 lakhs or
more annually now proceeding with the
companies hiring ethical hackers several
companies hire ethical hackers to
enhance their cyber security defenses
and protect their systems here are some
prominent companies known for hiring
ethical hackers
Google Facebook Microsoft Apple Amazon
IBM Cisco Intel deoe and evi are the
most prominent ones hey have you heard
about Twitter's data breach employees
data getting leaked have you heard about
last fast data getting breached have you
heard about Facebook getting hacked
there are so many news that we hear day
in and day out in this world and they
are so common in recent times we all
know how big is the scope of cyber
security and it's increasing day by day
statistics show that that over 1 million
job openings will be there by the end of
2023 and the fact is less than 50% of
individuals are actually skilled to do
the job less than 50% and even after the
Advent of AI it's the same as
digitization increases more and more
people are coming online more and more
businesses are doing their business
online coming up with their assets
online after Co there is 600% increase
in cyber attacks and I'm not kidding and
there is a big fact check that every 38
seconds there is a targeted Cyber attack
happening somewhere in the world so what
is cyber security cyber security is an
industry where we apply techniques and
tools used to protect a computer related
system namely software Hardware or a
network from cyber criminals or hackers
and honestly cyber security as a whole
is a very huge field when people say
about I'm getting a job in cyber
security how to get a job in cyber
security there is no job in cyber
security as such even won't get it there
are many fields there are many
disciplines many domains inside that so
you need to get a job inside that
because there are so many systems
diverse systems that have their own life
cycle to secure for example you might
have heard about different types of
softwares namely web applications mobile
applications maybe Android or iOS
desktop applications iot applications
and many more for a job in cyber
security you can be a destroyer or a
protector you can join both the sides of
the coin for an offensive job you hack
and find bucks for a defensive job you
identify attacks and stop them and this
is a very high level simplification of a
cyber security job even if you go inside
red team and blue team there are so many
different domains like namely appc Cloud
secc forensic investigator s iot malare
analyst incident responder and so on and
the most common jobs you might have
heard about in cyber security are pain
tester for offensive jobs VAP or red
team and for defensive job it's s so s
so analyst or a DFI analyst or a blue
deer and if I go in deep on all the
domains will be out of scope for this
video I'm here to give you a general
overview of every domain and how to
create a career potentially out of that
and I'll give you a road map for the
exact things that you will do and you
should do I cannot tell you exactly what
to do because there is no perfect road
map for anything but I'll just give you
the bare minimums and my recommendations
what I would suggest you to do so let's
get started but one problem I want to
tell you but I can tell you what to
learn and how to learn it but you'll
need to find the resources to learn
because they're very scattered there is
no single course that can teach you
everything so the problem with people is
that they'll go there they'll find
resources on Google they'll learn from
scattered resources and the problem will
be that they will not have complete
knowledge of the same domain in deep
they'll pick up voids between their
knowledge so it will affect their career
but what if someone shows you the exact
things to learn and make your industry
ready for a domain I'm going to talk
about simply learns industry ready cyber
security program that will teach you in
demand skills in just 6 months and your
career can be started right away this
program is Advanced executive program in
cyber security by simply learn in
collaboration with TripIt Bangalore
where you will learn this in demand
skills from their top faculty with real
world scenarios and here you will learn
practical knowledge by solving practical
Labs with popular tools including nessus
and BB Suite after the completion of
your course you will get a completion
certificate from triple it Bangalore and
a transcript to validate your learning
apart from that you will get a virtual
internship from npci National payments
Corporation of India in which you'll get
four projects where you'll have to solve
cyber security problems by identifying
issues or vulnerabilities in a system
and tell how to secure them sounds
exciting right so if you want to be
eligible for this program you need to
have a bachelor's degree at least and
one year work experience in any relevant
security field and some basic knowledge
of programming so if you are interested
the link is in the description go to the
link read all the description and all
the details click on apply now fill all
your details and just enroll right away
in order to learn cyber security you
need to First learn some prerequisites
it's not that easy to jump directly into
that so first of all you need to love
computers you need to fall in love with
them I am serious so first of all the
very basic skill you need to learn is
computer fundamentals so IO input output
software Hardware how memory management
is done Disk Management memory uh
Process Management Windows and Linux in
both the OS and I'm not kidding you need
to learn system administration level of
courses you can do A+ and then you need
to learn virtualization too how to run
an OS over OS and multiple OS and you
can find all those courses on YouTube
you don't have to wender around anywhere
and waste your time everything you can
get free so the next thing that you need
to learn is the most important thing
they want to talk about is computer
networking the that's the most important
thing no single computer can be hacked
if it's not connected to anything else
so there is no isolated system in cyber
security so you need to learn how
computers are connected the basic PCP IP
and OSI models and all the layers inside
that the most important layers are data
link layer till the application layer so
the application layer is most important
here all the protocols that you will
learn HTTP SMTP FTP SSH and everything
the most common in web is HTTP so you
need to be thorough in IDE that that is
indirectly related to internet internet
runs on IP addresses and port numbers so
the third and fourth layer are very
important for you to understand how
network works if you want to be a
network pestor then IP IP layers and IP
protocols and IP types the header
formats TCP UDP quot numbers and all the
details inside that and I'll repeat
again 90% of hacking is based on network
so you need to learn them you can learn
from books there is some good book I can
recommend data communication and
networking from foren that I personally
used but you can watch YouTube videos
you can watch courses and I'll repeat
again 90% of hacking is based on network
so internet is networking the third
thing is Linux and shell programming if
you don't know majority of world's
servers are based out of Linux because
it's robust some examples for robust
Linux servers are rhl and Cent OS and
even after that the attacking machine
that most of the hackers use in the
world is based out of Linux because
Linux is open source Linux is robust
it's customizable so you know everything
about it and you need to be learning
shell programming because even if you
don't have any tools with guis you'll
need to learn how to use them on command
line it's very important because as a
hacker you might have seen that command
line window a black screen or a green
text so that's very fancy right that is
what is terminal or a shell you need to
learn that to be cool just kidding
learning Linux is very easy you can
start from a beginner friendly OS like
yubu it's very easy to learn learn you
can just explore and try things there
learn tools and then you can switch to a
hacker OS called G you might have heard
about it right many things so then you
can learn how to use tools because it's
made for penetration testers byen
testers and there are many tools you can
uh you can Master you can learn the
techniques of hacking and it will be
very cool but first you need to make
sure that you're doing things right and
ethically and by shell programming in
Linux I mean Bash that's the current
standard of shell being used so there
are lot of commands many simp commands
once you keep typing you'll remember in
your subconscious mind LS CD PWD uh CP
all of these commands will be used in
your daily basis and the next thing is
programming do we need to learn
programming many people ask me this
question is there a need I don't know
how to code I'm very weak in that but
I'll tell you if you opt for a offensive
job in a pen testing world you need to
learn how to program and how code is
written because in a corporate world
there is wide box pen testing you get
access to the source code so you have to
extensively review the source code and
then find issues in that so there is no
way out eventually you'll need to learn
it but at the starting for a beginner
Ione say it's a big deal or a big
headache to uh conquer but you can keep
it on hold for some time just
familiarize yourself with cyber security
concept and once you feel you're ready
to learn programming on the site along
the way then you can just start it
because eventually you'll need to learn
it at the end so why not start early so
it's a very simple concept right how a
software is made what is it made of code
right so if you need to hack a software
you need to learn how it is coded how it
is written so you need to learn to read
code so you need to learn many basic
concepts of programming like data types
variables uh conditionals Loops classes
and objects and these are enough so
these are the major Concepts that you
need to learn in basic programming and
you can pick up any programming language
that you can Master but you don't know
which programming language will come
before for you to hack or test it can be
anything so you have to learn the basic
concept the syntax are different in all
the languages but the basic concept is
same so these are the prerequisites that
I will recommend you to learn at the
bare minimum and these are very crucial
so once you get through all of them and
do brainstorming and keep everything in
mind and you have learned everything
then you can start go learn cyber
security from various sources because
they're very scattered and even then
there is no single course of cyber
security there are many domains many
disciplines and each of them have
different things to learn and topics and
even here I have a bare minimum concept
to learn for you all is the oasp top 10
so what is oasp oasp is a foundation of
web security that is developed and
designed for web developers and security
researchers to make them aware about
cyber attacks and how they can secure
themselves and every 3 or four years
they will release an extensive list of
top 10 vulnerabilities or attacks that
is a result of sensus of all the issues
and attacks reported recently through
statistics and they have extensive
resource Factory for all of them
including labs and tools and they are
all free so if you see the list you will
see some examples like Access Control
security Miss configuration secure
design ssrf I'm not going to take all
the names but for each attack type they
have their own descriptive documentation
they'll make you understand as a hacker
and also as a developer how you can see
how we can identify the issue in your
code and how you can fix them optimally
and even for all the issues there are
Labs that you can solve to practice them
and realize them in real world they have
many Labs including OAS Juice Shop evap
you can just set up them on a local
machine or just run a cloud instance and
then just practice them and even they
conduct conferences by the name of oasp
they also have their YouTube Pages you
can learn from them and they have a lot
lot of documentation they have a tool
oasp Zap for pen testing just like BBU
so they have very good resources and
I'll tell you one thing that practice is
the key if you learn a concept today
don't just leave it like that the theory
won't help you in getting a job you need
to practice the concept each and every
attack issue framework viability you
need to practice them on your own
handson with your own Labs so I'll tell
you that you know already that how
technology changes drastically every day
so you need to get updated and be
proactive in learning new things this is
a complete practical field okay and then
there's another resource just like oasp
there is another resource called forger
they have their own Labs called Web
Security Academy where you can learn all
the concepts of Fab security and solve
the labs online which are free and also
they have a tool called BB s that's the
most popular tool that every hacker uses
when they want to pinest something so
even I use that even you'll use that
everyone uses that and every Cyber
attack has an impact and a risk involved
in that and there is a huge difference
between risk and impact that's where our
risk and compliance teams come into
place the risk management there is a
different job profile called GRC or
governance risk and compliance with many
other names but the concept is the same
that you find an issue but how to fix
that and how to fix the risk the risk is
associated to the business the risk and
compliance team will relate every risk
to the business impact or objective so
the basic goal of cyber security is to
identify and realize your risk and then
to contain it and reduces as much as
possible that's where hacker come in to
realize those risks and if I talk about
defensive jobs their job is to learn
digital forensics and incidents so they
need to learn how to do Incident
Management how to review the locks how
to use Siem tools and how to correlate
data so they'll have to find evidences
of all the attacks that recently
happened and continuously monitor the
network events and create alerts so that
they can respond to them so they have to
do a lot of Investigation correlation
and root cost analysis of the issue once
they find the root or the culprit
they'll try to reduce the risk and
prevent that from happening in the
future so likewise we have many domains
and each domain has its own deep
knowledge that you cannot gain that's
not possible you need to select a domain
of your choice you can only get by
research by self-study no College can
teach you that but I'll tell you one
more problem I told you everything that
you need to learn you learn everything
you gain all the skills you do a lot of
practice that you know that you know
everything that you can do and perform
those attacks but how will you tell the
HR how will the HR know so it's not just
about acquiring skills it's also about
proving your skills that's what happens
when you look for a job when you hunt a
job and look for a good career the first
thing is to build your resume
professionally that's the short listing
criteria you won't even get to the
interviews if you don't take this
seriously so I'll tell you what all
things you'll need to add in your resume
so the first thing is degree
unfortunately you need to do a degree in
CS or it Branch because most companies
want that and my preference for a degree
is btech then BCA and then BC but if you
are a math student the btech is the best
option if you are an Arts student then
you don't have any choice you can do BCA
or BSC if you are from any other Branch
like electrical mechanical civil you
haven't done Bachelor's in CS or it then
you can go for Masters you should go for
Masters but I won't say it's very hard
requirement or a very necessary thing to
do I didn't do Masters myself but if you
want you can do that it will be a good
option for a job if you're getting good
placements in that college but I'll tell
you that the degree is the only thing
that we require we don't care about
anything else and how you do it you just
need that certificate so you can do
private programs distant learning
anything doesn't matter the second thing
is projects they are very important as a
fresher especially because you don't
have any work experience so you need to
do something apart from your you're
learning so whatever you learned
whatever skills you gained you should
apply them somewhere to prove it like
that's the point so you can apply our
cyber security skills with any other
domain like AI uh Cloud security
blockchain web3 include anything combine
them and create a good project with many
project ideas that I can give you and
then you need to open source that
because you need to show the employer
because they will demand and require
your link that they can verify
themselves because there are many false
alarms out there
and I've already told you how you can do
projects in cyber security the simply
learn internship from mpci from that
advanced executive program will give you
four projects that's all you need that's
all you need to put so you can put that
link in your resume along with your
LinkedIn that's equally important and
the next thing is certifications and
I'll tell you that if you do a
certification then you don't need to do
a master's degree at all it's not
required do some good certifications
because they teach you a skill in a
particular niche in deep in a in a
shorter time so it won't take you 2
years it will just take you 1 month 2
months 3 months or Maximum 6 months if
you are good enough and there are many
certifications right now in the market
that you can choose but for India for an
HR I think C is the most basic
certification that they look because
they all know that but skill-wise eh is
not good it's just a theory Examination
for practical skills for actual skill
development you should give OSB because
HR loves it and also you'll get a better
job with a better salary in a better
company with OSP because it's more
skillful and more better than C holder
and also the problem is with OSP is the
price that's why not many people take it
it's more costly but if you want to be
cheaper and gain some practical skills
too you can do elearn certifications
like ejp ecpp or eccp you can correct me
ewx those are very practical and very
good certifications not on the level of
OSP very close to them but still they
are cheaper so it's a good deal the
there are more certifications that are
more relevant in outside countries like
Security Plus pentest plus crtp so that
you can do that if you're want a plan
for some foreign countries or foreign
jobs so likewise two three
certifications are more than enough and
now comes work experience the internship
I've already told you how to get an
internship just go to the simply Larn
program and you'll get it just enroll
there so that's not a problem for you
but if you want extra internships you'll
go to the LinkedIn create an account
today you'll need to be active L
involved in LinkedIn and don't use any
other social media more than LinkedIn
because it's going to help you in your
job search the most so connect with
people do an internship at least 3
months or maybe 6 months it will gain
you a good experience on how work is
done in an industry and then even that
company itself can give you a job offer
called popo and you can join with a good
package or a salary so now your resume
is strong enough you can actively look
for jobs and that too it will be the
same in LinkedIn so so you need to build
as much connections as possible with
good people working in a good company in
your desired cyber security domain
connect with HRS and approach them talk
to them personally share your resume be
professional be polite be kind and make
sure that you reveal a sense of passion
inside you and building a good Network
in LinkedIn helps a lot you will get a
lot of referrals if possible if you
don't know what referral is is you can
just get into a company with a trust of
another person that's already working in
that company and getting a referral
makes your job hunt much easier you'll
land a job much easier because you'll
get interviews and even if you make some
mistakes in your interviews it will be a
trust Factor they will be tolerable and
they'll select you and for a job hunt I
have seen people talking to me coming
back saying that they are not getting a
job they've tried hard enough but when I
ask them how many companies you have
applied on they say only five or 10 that
doesn't make sense you need to apply at
least 50 to 100 companies because the
average reward rate is 10% so if you
apply in 50 companies you'll get to
apply from five of them that's the rate
and keep that in mind try hard as you
can so when your resume is shortlisted
you'll have three to four technical
rounds with a managerial round these are
the average figures and if you're are
applying for an offensive job like a
pentester you'll get you'll expect OAS
top 10 and code review questions
definitely and scenario based questions
are very common in good companies today
because they'll have to test you on a
hypothetical situ ation how you handle
the situation what is a decision- making
approach and how you solve the problems
in very stressful environment how you
can work under stress and don't even
lose your composure and calm in those
situations so the technical skills are
not enough you need to have some soft
skills like communication skills
listening skills decision- making skills
and always have a growth mindset I'll
tell you one simple key to getting a job
in cyber security is to understand the
risk of your assets and learn how to
contain them and adapt to the ever
evolving and changing threat landscape
cyber security is an Ever evolving field
its scope is not going to get declined
anytime soon it will just keep improving
so the only problem with people is that
they don't learn consistently so you
need to learn consistently and be aware
of all the technological updates around
you and you should be good so all the
best for your next cyber security job if
you are someone who is interested in
building a career in cyber security by
graduating from the best universities or
a professional who El sits to switch
careers with cyber security by learning
from the experts then try giving a short
to Simply learn post graduate program in
cyber security with modules from MIT
schwarzman College of Engineering the
course link is mentioned in the
description box that will navigate you
to the course page where you can find a
complete overview of the program being
offered the topics that we are going to
discuss in this video are what exactly
hacking is the types of hackers the
classifications what is ethical hacking
the skills that are required of an
ethical hacker the process that is
utilized by ethical hackers in their
daily activities and then we lastly
we're going to discuss cryptography so
let's talk about hacking and what
exactly hacking is hacking refers to
exploiting weaknesses in a computer
network to obtain unauthorized access to
information a hacker is a person who
tries to hack into computer systems now
here there are some keywords that we
need to understand first and foremost
exploit when you're exploiting
weaknesses weaknesses are technically
called vulnerabilities which are
basically design flaws misconfiguration
errors usage of default usernames and
passwords which have not been modified
so any misconfiguration or anything that
has been left behind by a Security
administrator that can be misused which
means exploited by a hacker to gain
unauthorized access so the next term is
unauthorized access something that
you're not allowed to do and when you
say a hacker is a person who tries to
hack it's basically a person with
malicious intent trying trying to gain
access to a system or a resource that
they are not authorized to access in the
first place how do they do it they find
avability that is a weakness or a flaw
and then they misuse it to gain access
to that particular Network so here in
the diagram you can see that a sender on
the left hand side is trying to send
some data to the receiver on the right
hand side the hacker would try to gain
unauthorized access to the transmission
that is being sent and would try to
capture the data packets and read the
secrets within let's look at a business
case scenario iio into hacking now there
is an organization uh everybody's going
around their own business when they
realize that their systems may have been
compromised now they're trying to look
at the customer data to ensure that that
has not been compromised and trying to
assure the customers however they do
realize that some customer data has been
lost and even the company reports have
been modified as well now this is the
scenario where there have been some
security controls in place and those
controls have been identified they
realized that there is an attack that
that has happened and based on that
attack they have realized that the data
has now been compromised and the records
have been modified uh by the hacker
which means that the data is no longer
trustworthy and thus cannot be used by
the business for any legal transactions
so then the hacker gives a call to the
organization or gets connected to the
organization demanding a ransom for the
data to be replaced to be taken back
into the original state where it was
trusted and thus the organization can
utilize it for business transactions the
organization has probably no backup so
they decide that they want to pay the
lumsum to the hacker to restore that
data so that they can continue on with
the business does money exchanges and
the hacker is able to restore that data
and the business continues that as usual
however the activity here of a hacker
trying to Leverage The misconfiguration
of the weaknesses in the organization's
security thus being able to hack them
and uh make these ransomware demands so
the the company then wants to figure out
even if having a security system in
place how was the hacker able to hack
their systems thus one of the employees
comes up with a brilliant idea of
identifying vulnerabilities in the
network uh to proactively search for any
flaws that have been left behind uh so
that they can plug those flaws and
nobody can misuse them thus they figure
out that they want to hire a ethical
hacker who would help them identify the
security posture of the organization
identify the weaknesses vulnerabilities
and flaws and help them remedy those
flaws so that in future scenarios these
scenarios will not happen so before we
go into an ethical hacker let's
understand what are the types of hackers
so what are the types of hackers hacker
is a technically skilled person uh who
is very Adept with computers they have
good programming skills they understand
how operating system works they
understand how networks work they
understand how to identify flaws and
vulnerabilities within all of these
aspects and then they understand and
know know how to misuse these flaws to
get a outcome which would be detrimental
to the health of the organization so
there's six type of hackers that have
been identified black hat hackers white
hat hackers gray hat script kitties
nation sponsored hackers and a activists
so blackhe hat hackers are Bas basically
uh the malicious hackers who have
malicious intent and have criminalistic
Tendencies they want to harm the
organization by hacking into their
infrastructure by destroying their
infrastructure by destroying their data
so that they can gain from it from a
monetary perspective uh these guys are
also known as crackers the main aspect
of these uh people are that they have
malicious intent they try to do
unauthorized activities and they try it
for personal gain another important
aspect to remember is that a black hat
hacker will always try to hide their
identity uh they will spoof their online
digital identity by masking it by
spoofing their IP addresses Mac
addresses and try to remain anonymous on
the network a whiteed hacker on the
other hand is also an ethical hacker or
a security analyst who's an individual
who will do exactly the same thing that
a blackhead hacker would do minus the
malicious intent plus the intent of
helping the organization identifying the
flaws and remedying them so that nobody
else can misuse those vulnerabilities so
they are authorized to act on the
company's behalf they are authorized to
do that activity which would help the
company identify those flaws and thus
help the company mitigate those flaws
improving on their security posture so
these uh these kind of Security Experts
or ethical hackers would help
organizations defend themselves against
unauthorized attacks gr hat hackers is a
blend of both white hat and black hat
hackers so here they can work
defensively and offensively both they
can accept contracts from organizations
to increase their security posture at
the same time they can also get
themselves involved in malicious
activities towards other organizations
to personally gain or benefit from them
by doing unauthorized activity script
kites are people uh who are technically
not much aware about what hacking is uh
they rely on existing tools that have
been created by other hackers they have
no technical knowledge of what they're
doing it's just a hit or miss for them
so they just get their hands on a tool
they try to execute those tools uh if
the hack works it works otherwise it
doesn't so these people are basically
who are noobs or newbies who are trying
to learn hacking or uh just uh people
who with Mal's intent who just want to
have some fun or trying to impress
people around then we have the nation or
the state sponsored hackers as the name
suggest these hackers are sponsored by
their government now this may not be a
legitimate job but most of the
governments do have hackers uh enrolled
in their pay on um on their
organizations to spy on their enemies to
spy on various countries and try to
figure out uh the aspirations of those
countries so this is basically a spying
activity where you are technically
trying to get access to other Count's
resources and then try to spy on on them
to figure out what their activities have
been or what their future plans have
been and then we have the activists who
is an individual who has a political
agenda to promote and they promote it by
doing hacking so uh these guys what is
the difference between a blackhe hat
hacker and a activist the blackhe Hat
hacker hacker may try to hide their
identity a activist will claim
responsibility of what they have done so
for them it's a political agenda
political cause and they will try to
hack various organizations to promote
their cause they would probably do this
by defacing the website and posting the
messages that they want to promote on
these websites so what exactly is
ethical hacking then we have discussed
the types of hackers we have identified
a malicious hacker as a black hat hacker
with the intent uh of doing harm to an
organization's Network for personal gain
we have discussed what the ethical
hacker is so an ethical hacker would be
doing the same activity but in an
authorized manner so they would have
legal contracts that they would be
signing with the organization it would
give them a definite scope of what
they're allowed to do and what they are
not allowed to do and the ethical
hackers would function within those
Scopes would try to execute those test
scenarios where they would be able to
identify those flaws or those system
vulnerabilities and then they would be
submitting a report to the management of
what they have found they would also
help the management to mitigate or to
resolve those weaknesses so that nobody
else can misuse them later on they might
use the same techniques and the same
tools that blackhe hat hackers do
however the main difference here is that
these guys are authorized to do that
particular their activity they're doing
it in a controlled manner with the
intent of helping the organization and
not with the intent of personal gains so
who's an ethical hacker again ethical
hacker is a highly intelligent Highly
Educated person who knows how computers
function how programming languages work
how operating systems work they can
troubleshoot they're technically very
Adept at Computing they understand the
architecture they understand uh how
various components in a computer work
they can troubleshoot those components
and they can basically be uh very good
with programming as well now when I say
programming we don't want the ethical
hacker to be a good developer of
applications we want them to understand
programming in such a way that they can
create scripts they can write their own
short programs like viruses worms
Trojans or exploits which would help
them achieve the objective that they
have set out for so uh here you can see
the ethical hacker they are individuals
who perform a security assessment of the
companies with the permission of cons
concerned authorities so what is a
security assessment a security
assessment is finding out the exact
security posture of the organization by
identifying what security controls are
in place how they have been configured
and if there are any gaps in the
configurations themselves so an
organization will hire a ethical hacker
they they would give the ethical hacker
the information about what information
is or what security controls what
firewalls what idss ipss Inogen
detection or inen prevention systems
antiviruses are already in place and
then they will ask the ethical hacker to
figure out a way to bypass these
mechanisms and see if they can still
hack the organization what is the need
of an ethical hacker the need of an
ethical hacker is proactive security the
ethical hacker would identify all the
existing flaws in an organization and
try to resolve those flaws to help
secure the organization from blackhe hat
hackers so ethical hackers would prevent
Hackers from cracking into an
organization's Network by securing the
organization by improving on their
security on a periodic basis and they
would also try to identify system
vulnerab these Network vulnerabilities
or application Level vulnerabilities
that would have been missed or have
already been missed and then Tred to
figure out a way of plugging them or uh
resolving them so that they cannot be
misused by other hackers they would also
analyze and enhance an organization
security policies now what are policies
policies are basically documents that
have been created by an organization of
rules that all the employees need to
follow to ensure that the security of an
organization is maintained for example a
password policy a password policy would
would help users in an organization to
adhere to the standards the organization
has identified for a password complexity
for example a password when a user is
creating them should adhere to standards
where they are using random words they
are uh they contain the alphabet A
through Zed uppercase and lowercase 0
through 9 as numerics and special
characters and they're randomized so
that the password becomes more more
stronger to prevent from Brute Force
attacks so what would an ethical hacker
do at this point in time they would try
to test the strength of the passwords to
see if Brute Force attacks or dictionary
attacks are possible and if any of these
passwords can be cracked they would
ensure that all the employees are
following the policies and all the
passwords are are as secured as the
policies want them to be if there are
any gaps in the policies or the
implementation of the policy it is the
ethical Hacker's responsibility to
identify those gaps and warn the
organization about it similarly they
would also try to protect any personal
information any data that is owned by
the organization that that is critical
for the functioning of the organization
and they'll try to protect it by from
falling into the Hacker's hands now what
are the skills that are required of an
ethical hacker these are the following
skills so first and foremost they should
have good knowledge with operating
systems such as Windows Linux Unix and
Mac now when we say knowledge about
operating systems it's not only about
how to use those operating systems but
how to troubleshoot those operating
systems how these operating systems work
how these operating systems need to be
configured how can they be secured for
examp example securing an operating
system is not only installing a firewall
and an antivirus but you need to
configure permissions on an operating
system of what users are allowed to do
and what users are not allowed to do for
example limiting the installation of
applications how are we going to do that
we need to go into the system center the
security Center of Windows and we need
to configure security parameters over
there of what are acceptable softwares
and what are not same with Linux and uh
Mac softwares operating systems so we
need to know how we can secure these
these operating systems similarly all of
these would have desktop versions and
server versions of operating systems as
a ethical hacker we need to know the
desktop and server versions both how to
configure them and how to provide
services within the organization on
these servers so that they can be
consumed in a secure manner by all the
employees at the same time they should
also be knowledgeable of programming
languages or scripting languages such as
PHP python Ruby HTML for programming if
you will because web servers coming into
the picture so again they should not be
great developers where they can create
huge applications but they should be
able to develop scripts understand those
scripts analyze those scripts and figure
out what the output should be of those
scripts to achieve the hacking goals
that they have set out for an ethical
hacker should have a very good
understanding about networking no matter
whether you're in application security
you're in network security or you're in
host based security since a computer
will always be connected to a network
either a locally area network like a lan
or the internet we should know how
networking works we should know the
seven layers of the OSI model we should
know which protocols work on those seven
layers we should identify the tcpip
model and how OSI model can be mapped to
the tcpip model we should understand how
TCP and UDP work how how each and every
protocol is crafted how they are
supposed to behave for us to analyze and
understand any network based attacks we
should be very good in security measures
so we should know where those
vulnerabilities would like what are the
latest exploits available in the market
and we should be able to identify them
we should be able to know the techniques
and the tools of how to deal with
security how to analyze security and
then how to implement security to
enhance it as well along with that it is
important that a security analyst or
ethical hacker is aware of the local
security laws and standards why is that
because an organization cannot do any
illegal activity whatever responses that
they have whatever security mechanisms
whatever security Authority controls
they will Implement they need to be
adhering to the local law of the land
they should be legal in nature and
should not cause undue harm to any of
the employees or any of the third party
clients that they are dealing with so
the ethical hackers should be aware of
what security laws are before they
Implement security controls or even
before they start testing for security
controls and all of these should be
backed up by having a global
certification or a globally valid
certification related to networking
related to security ethical in the law
of the land anything and everything
maybe even programming uh it's good to
have a certification in PHP Pearl python
Ruby and so on so forth why because most
of the organizations when they hire
ethical hackers look out for these
certifications especially globally valid
certifications so that they can be sure
or they can be assured that the person
that they are hiring has the required
skill set so let's talk about a few of
the tools that a ethical hacker would
utilize uh in their testing scenarios to
be honest there are hundreds of tools
out there what you see on the screen are
just a few examples of them uh nessus is
a vulnerability scanner what is a
vulnerability scanner it is an automated
tool that is designed to identify
vulnerabilities within hosts within uh
operating systems within networks so
they come with their rade databases of
all the vulnerabilities that have
already been identified and they scan
the network against that database to
find out any possible flaws or any
possible vulnerabilities that currently
exist on the host store the operating
system or on the network similarly there
would be application scanners like acuns
or Arachne that would help you scan
applications and identify flaws within
those applications as well now all of
these are automated tools the essence of
ethical hacker is when these tools churn
out the reports the ethical haer hacker
can understand these reports analyze
them identify the flaws and then craft
their own exploits or use existing
exploits in a particular manner so that
they can get access or or they can
bypass the access security controls
mechanisms that are already in place how
can they do that with the tool called
metas sploid you see that Big M there on
the right hand side that M logo is for a
tool called Metasploit which is a
penetration testing tool what is a
penetration testing tool it is that tool
that will allow a ethical hacker to
craft their exploits or choose their
exploits for the vulnerabilities that
have been identified by nessus since we
are interacting with computers we will
always be interacting using tools right
so the first tool NS identifies the
flaws and the possible list of
vulnerabilities we do a penetration test
using Metasploit to validate those flaws
and to verify that those flaws actually
exist and try to figure out the
complexity of those flaws and that's
where metas helps us do that wire shock
would be used in the background while
you're doing both the activities using
nessus or Metasploit to keep a track of
what packets are being sent and by
received on the network which will help
us analyze those packets so whenever I
run an SS scanner I would run a y Shar
in the background it will capture the
data packets and I can go through those
data packets and analyze that data
packets to identify what nesses is
actually trying to do similarly when I
try to attack a machine using exploit on
metas exploit I will keep on wire shock
running in the background to capture the
data packets that have been sent and the
responses that I've received from the
victim so that I can also go through
those packets and analyze the responses
and analyze the attack whether it was
successful to what extent was it
successful and uh basically will also
give me a validation a proof of the
activity that has happened nmap is
another automated tool that allows me to
scan for open ports and protocols so why
would I use nmap because Pro ports and
protocols become an entry point for a
hacker to gain access to devices for
example when we connect to a web server
we connect through a web browser but we
automatically connect to Port 80 using
HTTP and Port 443 using https so if I'm
connecting to a web server using https
it is safe to assume that Port 443 on
the web server is open to accept those
connections similarly there would be
other services that may be left open on
the web server because nobody thought
about configuring it or they
misconfigured the web server and they
left unwanted Services running so nmap
will allow me to scan those ports and
services and allow me to understand what
services are being offered on that
server so then I can start analyzing
that server identify those flaws within
those services and then try to attack
them if the application that I'm
analyzing is connected to a database and
I want to do a SQL injection attack or
if I if nessus tells me that there's a
SQL injection attack that may be
possible on that particular application
I can use an automated tool called SQL
map or SQL map that would allow me to
automatically craft all the queries that
are required for a SQL injection attack
and help me do that attack at the same
time so here I do not have to manually
create my own queries uh the SQL map
tool would automatically create them for
me what I would do is I would use nessus
to identify that particular flaw if
nessus reports that flaw I would then go
use the tool SQL map configure it to
attack that particular web server and
when I fire off the tool it will then
automatically start directing queries
SQL injection queries to the database to
see if those uh databases are vulnerable
and if yes what data can be retrieved
from those databases so all of these
tools in a nutshell would help me hack
Networks applications operating systems
and host devices and this is what
ethical hacker does they use these kind
of tool sets they identify what attacks
they need to do they identify the right
tool for that particular attack and they
write their exploits they create those
attacks and then they start attacking
analyze the response and then give a
report to the management uh providing
them feedback about how the attack was
created or crafted what was the response
to that attack and whether the attack
was successful or not if successful they
would also give recommend ation of what
to do to prevent these attacks from
happening in the future so when we are
doing these attacks or when we want to
launch these attacks what is the process
that that we would follow so there are
six steps that we would do as an ethical
hacker if you are just a hacker you
probably wouldn't do the sixth step
which is a reporting step so the first
step that would be done is the
recognizance phase which is the
information gathering phase which is
very important from ethical Hacker's
perspective or a hacker's perspective
because if I want to attack someone or
something as a digital device I need to
know what I'm attacking I need to know
the IP address of the device the MAC
address of those devices I need to know
the operating system the build or the
version of that operating systems
applications on top the versions of
those applications so I know what I'm
attacking for example if I if I want to
attack a server I assume it's a Windows
based server and I use a particular tool
to attack it but it actually turns out
to be a Linux based server my attacks
are going to be unsuccessful so I need
to focus my attack based on what is
there at the other end so in my
information gathering phase I want to
identify all of that information once I
have that information done I'm going to
scan those servers using tools like nmap
that we just talked about and we're
going to try to see the open ports open
services and protocols that are running
on that server that can give me possible
entry points within the network or
within the device or within the
operating system at the same time along
with the scanning with nmap I would run
a vulnerability scanner the NS V scanner
we talked about or actic for
applications and then I would try to
identify vulnerabilities in those
applications operating systems or
networks once I've identified those
vulnerabilities in the scanning phase I
would then move on to the gaining phase
where I would then craft my exploits or
choose existing exploits and start
attacking the attacking the victim at
this point in time if my attack is
successful I will probably have gained
access uh by either cracking passwords
or escalating privileges or exploiting
avability that I may have found during
the scanning phase once I have gained my
access I want to maintain my access why
because the vulnerability may not be
there for long maybe somebody updated
the operating system and hence the flaw
was no longer exist existing or somebody
changed the password that may I may have
cracked does I no longer have access so
what do I do to maintain my access I
install Trojans or backd door entries to
those systems using which I can secretly
in a covert manner get access to those
devices at my own will at my own time as
long as those devices are available over
the network so that's where I maintain
my access I have hacked them now I want
to maintain my access so I install a
software which would give me a backd
door entry to that device no matter what
once I've done this I want to clear my
track so whatever activity that I've
been doing for example installing a
Trojan a Trojan is also a software that
would create directory directories and
files once installed on the victim's
machine so I want to hide that if I have
access data stores if I have modified
data I want to hide that activity
because if the victim comes to know that
something has happened they would start
they would start increasing their
security parameters they might start
scanning their devices they may take
them offline thus my hack would no
longer be efficient the reason I'm
clearing my tracks is that the victim
doesn't find out that they have been
hacked or they have been compromised or
even if they do find out that they've
been compromised they cannot trace the
compromise back to me so I would be
deleting references of any of the IP
addresses or Mac addresses that I may
have used to attack that particular
device and this is where I will be able
to identify where those logs were
created where those traces are once I
take off those traces the victim would
not be any wiser of whether they have
been compromised or who compromised
their system and if I am successful at
all of these stages or what to whatever
extent the success that I've achieved in
any of these stages I would then create
a report based on that and I would
report to the management about the
activities that we have been able to do
and whatever we have been able to
achieve out of those activities for
example we identifi 10 different flaws
there were 20 different attacks that we
wanted to do what attack did we do what
was the outcome of that attack what was
the intended or or the expected output
of that attack I'll create a report
which would give a detailed analysis of
all the steps that were taken along with
screenshots and evidences of what
activity was conducted what was the
output what was the expected output and
I would submit that report to the
management giving them an idea of what
vulnerabilities and flaws exist in their
environment or their devices that need
to be m ated so that the security can be
enhanced so these are the six steps that
the ethical hacking process would take
uh just going through this the uh
recognizance is where you're going to
use hiking tools like nmap HP to obtain
information about targets there are
hundreds of tools out there depending on
what information you want then in
scanning again n map next p these kind
of tools to be utilized to identify open
ports protocols and services in gaining
access you're going to exploit the
vulnerability by using the metas sploit
tool that we talked about in the
previous slide in the maintaining access
you're going to install back doors you
can use metas at the same time uh you
can craft your own scripts to create a
Trojan and install it on the victim's
machine once you have achieved that
clearing tracks is where you're going to
clear all evidences of your activity so
that you do not get caught or the victim
doesn't even realize that they have been
hacked and once you done all of this we
are going to create reports that are
going to be submitted to the management
to help them understand the current
security evaluation of their
organization so now let's see how we can
hack using social engineering now what
is social engineering social engineering
is the art of manipulating humans into
revealing confidential information which
they otherwise would not have revealed
so this is where your social skill and
your people skills come into the picture
if you're able to communicate
effectively to another person they would
probably give up more information that
they intended to give out let's look
look at examples right if you see on the
screen fishing activity what is fishing
we receive a lot of fake mails on
regular basis we have always received
those emails where we have won a lottery
of a few million dollars but we have
never realized that we didn't purchase a
lottery to win a lottery in the first
place we have always had those Nigerian
frauds where a prince died in some South
African country and you out of 7 billion
people on the planet have been
identified where they want to transfer a
few hundred million do through your
account and they want to give you 50% of
that money in return as thank you so
some very basic attacks where you go on
to websites and there's a banner
flashing at you saying congratulations
you're the 1 millionth visitor to this
website click here to claim your prize
all of these are social engineering
attacks fishing attacks fake websites
fake Communications being sent out to
users to pray on their Gully bity most
of humans always have that dream of
striking it rich winning a huge Lottery
once and for all and living their life
lavishly ever after but sadly in the
real world that's not that doesn't
happen that often and if you're
receiving those mails it is very
important that that you first research
the validity of those those
Communications before you even want to
act upon them so why are humans
susceptible to social engineering
because humans have emotion machines do
not try pleading with a machine to give
you access to a account that you have
forgotten a password to the machine
wouldn't even know what you're doing try
pleading with a human sympathy or
empathy where you could try to create a
social injuring attack where you can
plead with them saying if I do not get
access to this account immediately I
might lose my job and then that would
put my family into problems somebody
would feel empathy or sympathy towards
you and help you reset that password and
give you access to that account it's how
good the attack is and how convincing
you are for the success of this attack
to happen so what is a familiarity
exploit attackers interact with victims
to gain information which will benefit
the attackers to crack credentials as
passwords if we want to reset our
passwords what do we have as a mechanism
to resetting passwords we have some
security questions that we set up those
questions are nothing but personal
information that we would know but
through a social engineering attack it
would be easily be able to gather the
information that you have set for your
security questions the security
questions can be as simple as the first
school that you attended you probably
have that listed on your LinkedIn
profile where person can just go in
there and see your academic
qualifications and identify the school
that you were in right similarly it
might also be a question what was your
mother's maiden name that's a very good
attack and that's uh I mean if a person
can interact with you let's say they're
trying to take a survey and they
approach you for a feedback on a
particular product that you have been
utilizing and they ask you these
questions you wouldn't think twice
before giving those answers as long as
the request sounds legitimate to us we
are able to justify that request we do
answer those queries so it's upon us to
verify the authenticity of the request
coming in before we answer it fishing as
discussed would be fraudulent emails
which appear to be coming from a trusted
source so email spoofing uh comes into
mind uh fake website sites and so on so
forth exploiting human curiosity
curiosity killed the cat right so there
was there's so many physical attacks
where hackers just keep pen drives lying
around in a parking lot now this is a
open a generic attack whoever Falls
victim will fall victim so if I just
throw around a few USBS in the parking
lot obviously with Trojans implemented
on them some people who are curious or
who are looking for a couple of freebies
might take up those pen drives plug them
in their computers to see what data is
on the pen drives at the same time once
they plug in their those pen drives on
their computers the virus or the Trojan
would get infected and cause harm to
their machine then exploiting human
greed uh we just talked about the
Nigerian frauds and the lotteries those
kind of attacks the fake money-making
gimmicks now basically this is where you
pray upon the persons greed kicking in
and they clicking on those links in
order to uh get that money that has been
promised to them in that email so one of
the safest mechanism to keep data
private and to keep yourself secure is
using encryption now encryption can
happen through cryptography what is
cryptography cryptography is the art of
scrambling data using a particular
algorithm so that the data becomes
unreadable to the normal user the only
person with the key to unscramble that
data would be able to unscramble it and
make sense out of that data so we just
making it unreadable or non- readable by
using a particular key or a particular
algorithm and then we're going to send
the key to the end user the end user
using the uh same key would then decrypt
that data if anybody compromises that
data while it is being sent over the
network since it is encrypted they would
not be able to read it so the encryption
algorithm would be something like this
now if you see uh the computer word once
made into unreadable format would look
like EQ o r XV GT for a end user it
wouldn't make any sense but the person
who has a key to unscramble that would
be able to convert it back to computer
and then understand the meaning of that
word so this is just a substitution
Cipher that is being shown on the screen
so what is the alphabet the key is
alphabet plus three so C plus three
alphabets that becomes e o becomes q m
becomes o so the key that is utilized to
scramble that data is the character that
you are at the third character from
there would be the corresponding key so
the encrypted message is also known as a
cipher the decryption is just the other
way around where you know the key now
and you can now figure out what that e
corresponded to by going back three
characters in the alphabet most of the
times a certified ethical hacker must
decrypt a message without knowing the
secret key so let's say a ransomware has
affected your organization or has
affected a device and you want to figure
out uh or you want to decrypt that data
now as a ethical hacker you wouldn't be
for paying a ransom to the hacker would
you so it is now your prerogative of how
you're going to work around and how
you're going to try to crack them
encryption mechanism how to crack the
cipher to decrypt that message and see
what's within it right decryption
without the use of a secret key that is
known as a crypt analysis Crypt analysis
is the reversing of an algorithm to
figure out what the decryption was uh
without using a key so Crypt analysis
can be done using various formats the
first one is a Brute Force attack second
is a dictionary attack third one is a
rainbow table attack a Brute Force
attack is trying every combination
permutation and combination of the key
to figure out what the key was it is
100% successful but may take a lot of
time a dictionary attack is where you
have created a list of possible
encryption mechanisms a list of possible
cracks and then you try to figure out
whether those cracks work or not rainbow
tables are where you have an encrypted
text in hand and you're trying to figure
out uh the similarities between the text
that you have and the encrypted data
that you wanted to decrypt in the first
place so in the Brute Force attack
you're trying every possible combination
permutation of what the key would be in
dictionary attack you have a word list
that would tant amount to the key and if
you're you're trying to match all the
words listed in the text file or the
word list to see if any of those words
are going to work to decrypt that data
here in the rainbow table the cipher
text is compared with another Cipher
text you find out similarities and then
you try to work a reverse engineer your
way accordingly so let's have a quick
demo on cryptography before we be end
this session so to begin with the demo
of cryptography we are on website called
spam mic.com which will help us scramble
the message that we created into a
completely uh a format which would be
unrelated to the topic at hand so if I
say I want to encode a message or turn a
short message into spam so what this
does is you want to send across a secret
message you type in The Secret Message a
short one it will convert that into a
spam mail you send it across so
whoever's reading that spam mail would
never get an idea of the embedded
message within it so if I want to type
in a message here hi this is a secret
message the password is ASD atate 1 2 3
4 and I want to send this out to people
or to one of my colleagues but I want to
send it out in a secret manner so that
others are not aware of this so when I
press on encode what the algorithm would
do is it will convert this message into
a spam mail so my message hi this is a
secret message the password is at theate
1 234 or ASD at 1 234 gets convered into
this now if you read it dear e-commerce
professional this letter was specially
selected to be sent to you this doesn't
make sense there is no where or no
reference to the actual message that
I've already said so if I copy this
entire message and I send it let's say
via email to the recipient now the thing
is that the recipient needs to know that
I've encoded it using spam mimic the
algorithm needs to remain the same so
once they know that it is Spam mimic
what they can do is now in this instance
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
open up a new browser and I'm going to
go to the same website and at this point
in time I'm going to click on decode
when I click on decode I'm going to
paste the message that I have just
copied there we are and this message is
now being copied into a different
browser and if I decode this you will
see that it will convert it back to the
original message that there was so the
key is there at spam mimic and it is
embedded within the message so whenever
we we paste the message in the decode
Factor it knows what the key was and it
can decrypt that message and give me the
actual message that was embedded within
it there we are the entire message this
is what we created in the Google Chrome
browser and in the Firefox browser we
decoded similarly if I want to protect
these kind of messages there is an aspen
encrypt.me 8 1 2 3 4 and then I give it
a password to protect this message let's
say the word password and I use the
cipher to scramble this by using let's
say AES which is the strongest Cipher
right now and I say encrypt so this is
what the encryption would look like and
basically uh if I don't have the
password over here if I decrypt it you
would see that the error has occurred
now if I type in the password over here
and then decrypt it it will be able to
convert that back into the unscrambled
text and it will give me what the
original message was this is a secret
message the passord is ASD at theate 1
234 so if I want to keep my data secure
from hackers I want to scramble it in
such a way that they would not be able
to crack it or it would be very
difficult for for them to crack it and
this is one of the first mechanisms that
would be recommended by any ethical
hacker and before we begin if you're
someone who is interested in building a
career in cyber security or to become an
ethical hacker by graduating from the
best universities or a professional who
elicits to switch career with cyber
security or ethical hacker by learning
from the experts then try giving a short
to Simply Larch postgraduate program in
cyber security with modules from MIT
schwarzman College of computing the
course link is mentioned in the
description box below that will navigate
you to the course page where you can
find a complete overview of the program
being offered hello everyone and welcome
to this video on the hackers road map at
the simply land YouTube channel as vast
as the field of cyber security is
there's often an overflow of information
about it at the same time for people who
wish to know more about how to venture
into the cyber security or ethical
hacking space it is very important for
them to know what's the career
progression what are the skills needed
and how a person with know or bare
minimum knowledge can take the first
step in this amazing career well this
video is for all those individuals who
wish to pursue a career in the field of
cyber security and ethical hacking
whether you are an entry-level
professional a college graduate or an
experienced professional looking to
understand how a career in the field of
cyber security progresses and what
additional skills and responsibilities
would you need as you grow in the field
then you are at the right place so let's
get started with our topic the hackers
road map and before we begin if you are
someone who is interested in building a
career in cyber security by graduating
from the best universities or a
professional who at sits to switch
careers with cyber security by learning
from the experts then try giving a short
to Simply Larch postgraduate program in
cyber security with modules from MIT
shman College of Engineering the course
link is mentioned in the description box
that will now get you to the course page
where you can find a complete overview
of the program being offered and if
these are the types of videos you would
like to watch then hit the Subscribe
button like and press on the Bell icon
to never miss on further content so stay
tuned with us until the end of this
video and don't forget to register your
opinion in the comment section below and
now we will start with what is ethical
hacking and how is it different from
hacking so in the world of cyber
security hacking can be broadly
categorized into two types ethical
hacking and unethical hacking ethical
hacking involves using the same tools
and techniques as malicious hackers to
identify and fix security
vulnerabilities before they can be
exploited and these expert known as
Whitehead hackers work with a focus on
security rather on theft and on the
other hand we have unethical hacking
that refers to unauthorized access to
digital devices or networks with
malicious intent performed by black hat
hackers and additionally there are gray
hat hackers who process knowledge in
offensive and defensive computer use
sometimes working as security
Consultants during the day and engaging
in blackhe hat activities at night it is
important to understand these
distinctions to protect against cyber
threats effectively now we'll see the
objective or roles of an ethical hacker
ethical hackers also known as whad
hackers use their skills and expertise
to identify vulnerabilities in system
and network before malicious hackers can
exploit them their primary objective is
to simulate real world attacks and help
organization strengthen their security
measures the role of an ethical hacker
involves several key phases and we'll
see those roles and key phases so they
are responsible for reconnaissance
scanning can and maintain access clear
their tracks document their findings and
compile detailed reports so firstly they
conduct Toro Recon gathering information
about the target system or organization
this includes understanding the
organization structure Network
infrastructure and potential weak points
and through scanning they identify the
easiest and quickest methods to gain
access to the network and gather further
information and once access is gained
ethical hackers maintain it allowing
them to exercise their Privileges and
control the connected systems this step
helps them identify any potential
security flows and weaknesses within the
network they also work to clear their
tracks covering their footsteps to evade
detection and ensuring the security
personal cannot Trace their activities
and throughout the entire process
ethical hackers document their findings
compile detailed reports on the
vulnerabilities discovered and provide
recommendations to address and mitigate
the identified security issues their
vulnerability goal is to help
organization strengthen their defenses
prevent data breaches and protect
sensitive information from falling into
the wrong hands ethical hacking is a
crucial aspect of cyber security as it
allows organizations to stay one step
ahe of cyber threats by leveraging the
skills of ethical hackers businesses can
proactively identify and address
vulnerabilities ensuring the overall
security and integrity of their digital
infrastructure so now we'll see the
skills that needed to be an ethical
hacker so now we'll see the skills so
the first skill is knowledge of computer
networks then it's the programming
languages then the knowledge of web
applications databases ethical hacking
tools and knowledge of common attack
vectors and and techniques then what
certificates that are required for an
ethical Hecker now we'll start with
knowledge of computer networks
understanding computer networks is
fundamental for ethical hackers this
includes Concepts such as IP addressing
Network protocols example TCP IP routing
switching and firewalls a strong grasp
of how networks function will enable you
to identify vulnerabilities and
potential entry points the next is
programming languages Proficiency in
programming languages is essential for
for Effective ethical hacking languages
like python Java C++ and scripting
languages such as Pearl or Ruby are
widely used in this field programming
skills enable you to write custom
scripts and tools automate task and
exploit vulnerabilities and the next we
have is web applications in today's
digital landscape web applications are
often the target of attacks therefore a
solid understanding of web application
architecture protocols example HTTP and
security mechanisms example SSL TLS is
crucial knowledge of web programming
languages like HTML CSS JavaScript and
Frameworks like PHP or asp.net is also
beneficial then we have databases so
databases store and manage sensitive
data making them attractive targets for
hackers familiarize yourself with
database Management systems dbms such as
MySQL Oracle or Microsoft SQL Server
learn about database security including
access control encryption and vulnerabil
assessment then we should focus on the
skill to have a knowledge on ethical
hacking tools so to perform ethical
hacking task efficiently you should be
familiar with various hacking tools
these include Network scanners example
nmap vulnerability scanners example
nessus password crackers joone the riper
packet snipers wi shock and exploitation
Frameworks metas sploit mastering these
tools will enhance your Effectiveness as
an ethical hacker then you should have
knowledge of common attack vectors and
techniques that is understanding common
attack vectors and techniques is vital
for an ethical hacker this includes
knowledge of different types of malware
social engineering Network attacks that
is DDOS and web application
vulnerabilities example crite scripting
staying up to date with the latest
threats and attack methodologies is
crucial for Effective defense the next
is certificates so obtaining relevant
certifications demonstrates your
expertise and commitment to the field
certificates like certified ethical
hacker CH offensive security certificate
professional oscp or coma Security Plus
are highly regarded within the industry
they validate your skills and can boost
your credibility when seeking ethical
hacking opportunities the CH
certification is a multiple choice exam
that evaluates your understanding of the
penetration testing structure and the
tools that are utilized inside it it
gives job Seekers the information
security field a head start by ensuring
ining that the certificate holder
understands the fundamentals such as
information gathering attacking
computers or servers Wireless attacks
and social engineering so the objective
of CHS inform the public that
credentialed individuals meet or exceed
the minimum standards second establish
and govern minimum standards of credit
enity third professional information
security specialist in ethical hacking
so now we'll have an exam overview so
the exam name is EC Council certified
ethical hacker and the exam duration is
240 minutes and you will get questions
that is 125 questions you will get in
the exam and it is a multiple choice
question exam and the passing score you
need is
70% and to register for the exam you
should go to peon view or ECC Exam
Center and eligibility criteria for CHS
there are two ways to satisfy the
eligibility criteria that is is attend
official CH training and this can be in
any format example instructor Le
training computer Based training or live
online training as long as the program
is approved by EC Council and attempt
without official training in order to be
considered for the EC council
certification exam without attending
official training you must have two or
more years of documented information
security experience remit a
non-refundable eligibility application
fee of $100 submit completed CH exam
eligibility form in including
verification from an employer upon
approval EC Council will email your
voucher number to register for the CH
exam so this was all about the CH exam
and now we'll move to the steps to
become ethical hacker so ethical hacking
is an exciting and rapidly growing field
that requires a combination of technical
skills knowledge and a strong sense of
Ethics by following these steps you can
begin your journey towards becoming an
ethical hacker and contribute to
enhancing cyber security so step one
that is knowledge of computer systems
and networks step two you should have
Proficiency in programming languages
step three networking and security
Concepts you should have a knowledge of
it third knowledge of web application
and database fifth understanding of
operating systems step six familiarity
with ethical hacking tools step seven
problem solving and analytical thinking
step eight knowledge of common attack
vectors and techniques step nine
certifications so now we will elaborate
all the steps one by one
so we'll start with knowledge of
computer systems and networks so to
become an ethical hacker it is crucial
to have a deep understanding of computer
systems and networks this involves
familiarizing yourself with the inner
workings of computer system Network
protocols operating systems and how
different components interact within a
network environment by gaining this
knowledge you will be better equipped to
identify vulnerabilities and assess
potential security risk and the next is
Proficiency in programming language
so programming languages are an
essential tool for ethical hackers by
gaining Proficiency in programming
languages such as python C++ Java
JavaScript SQL per and Ruby you will be
able to develop your own scripts
automate task and create exploit codes
these programming languages provide the
foundation for writing secure and
efficient code as well as manipulating
and analyzing data the next step is
networking and security Concepts to
effectively assess and secure networks
it is important to have a solid
understanding of networking and security
concept this includes familiarizing
yourself with topics such as Network
protocols network security principles
encryption techniques and firewall
configurations understanding how data is
transmitted secured and protected in a
network environment will enable you to
identify potential vulnerabilities and
Implement appropriate security measures
step four knowledge of web application
and database knowledge so in today's
interconnected World web applications
and databases are common targets for
hackers therefore it is crucial to
develop a strong understanding of web
application architectures web protocols
and database systems pay special
attention to Common vulnerability
specific to web applications such as SQL
injection crite scripting xss and crite
request forgery csrf by gaining
expertise in these areas you will be
able to effectively assess the security
of web applications and databases and
provide appropriate recommendations for
securing them and the next step is
understanding of operating systems so
operating systems form the backbone of
computer systems and are often targeted
by hackers it is important to gain a
comprehensive understanding of different
operating systems such as Windows Linux
or Mac OS this includes understanding
system configurations file permissions
user management and security mechanism
specific to each operating system this
knowledge will enable you to identify
vulnerabilities apply patches and sec
your operating systems effectively step
six familiarity with ethical hacking
tools ethical hackers rely on a variety
of tools to assess and secure systems
and networks familiarize yourself with
popular ethical hacking tools such as
met spotli wire shock and map BB suit Ki
Linux canvas SQL ninja and B these tools
provide functionalities for
vulnerability scanning Network sniffing
exploit development and penetration
testing understanding how to use these
to effectively will enhance your
capabilities as an ethical heer now
we'll see the step seven that is problem
solving and analytical thinking so being
an ethical hacker requires strong
problem solving skills and the ability
to think analytically you will often
encounter complex systems and face
intricate security challenges developing
your problem solving abilities and
analytical thinking will help you
approach these challenges systematically
identify vulnerabilities and device
effective strategies to mitigate risk it
is is essential to stay updated with the
latest security Trends and Technologies
to enhance your problem solving skills
and the step eight is knowledge of
common attack vectors and techniques so
to defend against potential threats you
must familiarize yourself with common
hacking techniques and attack vectors
used by malicious hackers this include
social engineering fishing attacks
password cracking network based attacks
and more understanding how these attacks
work and the methodologies used will
enable you to proactively identify and
prevent potential security breaches and
now the step nine that is certifications
while certifications are not mandatory
to start a career in ethical hacking
they can provide a structured learning
path and validate your skills and
knowledge consider pursuing
certification such as certified ethical
hacker CH offensive security certified
professional OSP certified information
system security professional CSP
certified penetration Testing Engineer
cpte and certified security analyst e
SAA these certifications demonstrate
your expertise and dedication to the
field enhancing your credibility as an
ethical hacker now we'll see the job
roles in ethical hacking field so
starting with like there are several job
roles in ethical hacking such as here's
an elaboration on each job role in
ethical hacking and we'll see some of
the major ethical hacker job roles so
starting with ethical hacker so an
ethical hacker is a skilled professional
who legally attempts to penetrate
computers system and networks to
identify vulnerabilities and weaknesses
they use their knowledge to strengthen
the security infrastructure and protect
against cyber threats and the next is
network security engineer network
security Engineers specialize in
securing and maintaining computer
networks within an organization they
Implement and manage security measures
such as firewalls intrusion detection
systems and virtual private networks
that is VPN to protect sensitive data
then we have cyber security analyst so
cyber security analyst Monitor and
analyze systems for potential security
breaches or incidents they investigate
threats develop security protocols and
Implement measures to protect against
attacks the next is penetration tester
penetration testers also known as
ethical hackers simulate real world
attacks to identify vulnerabilities in
computer systems networks and
applications they conduct thorough
assessments and provide recommendations
for improving security the next is
information security manager information
security managers are responsible for
overseeing an organization's overall
security strategy and ensuring the
protection of sensitive data they
develop and Implement security policies
manage security teams and handle
incident response and the next is cyber
security engineer so cyber security
Engineers design and Implement security
systems including firewalls encryption
protocols and intrusion detection
systems they also conduct risk
assessments and perform security audits
to maintain a security environment and
the next is security consultant Security
Consultants provide expert advice and
guidance on security strategies and
solutions they assess vulnerabilities
develop security plans and assist
organizations in improving their overall
security posture in the United States
these requirements are very high and
this was all for this tutorial did you
know that in August this year Google
openly admitted that some of its Gmail
accounts were hacked by an Iranian group
fortunately the event was isolated and
was taken care ER of but rarely are
security breaches this easy to stop with
more and more data moving to the cloud
the prospects of hacks like these have
grown in the past decade exponentially
consequently organizations have now
discovered the need to secure the
digital infrastructure against various
attack vectors fueling the need for
ethical hackers in the IT industry so
today's video is all about how you can
learn the ins and outs of hacking and
cyber security irrespective of your
learning background so welcome to our
video on how to become an ethical hacker
by simply learn before we get started
and show your subscribe to the channel
so you always stay updated with the
latest Technologies and Trends let's
first clear the air on an ethical
Hacker's role the term hacking has
inherently negative connotations however
this will only be applicable until the
duty of an ethical hacker is properly
understood ethical hackers are the good
people in the hacking field wearing the
white hat so what exactly is the
responsibility of an ethical hacker
instead of utilizing the extensive
computer expertise for criminal purposes
ethical hackers find gaps in data and
computer security for businesses and
organizations worldwide to defend
themselves against hackers with less
than noble intentions ethical hacking is
a subcategory of cyber security that
involves lawfully breaking a system
security mechanisms in order to discover
possible threats and data leaks on the
network ethical hackers can work for
cooperation as independent Freelancers
in house security staff for its website
or its applications or as simulated
offensive cyber Security Professionals
as well all of these careers need
knowledge of current attack
methodologies and tools albe the
in-house expert may need to be
knowledgeable about a single kind of
software or digital asset but how can
you hone your ethical hacking skills
let's take a look at few steps one can
take while starting a career in this
field the first step is getting
comfortable with Linux there are
operating systems catered specifically
to ethical hackers like Ki Linux and
parad security both are based on Linux
derivatives and have a plethora of tools
to make your hacking workflow easy and
relatively stressfree the better vers
you are with Linux and its terminal the
quicker you can achieve things when
hacking
the next would be to master the mother
of all programming languages which is
the C programming language since Linux
and a lot of backend code are written in
C having a strong hand over this
programming language is very important
it's always helpful to learn a couple
more relevant languages like python or
JavaScript which will help you dissect
giant pieces of server code like
butter remaining Anonymous is vital in
the hacking sphere since giving a
malicious actor news of your existence
on a Target Network can cause him then
to flee or attack your device instead
the user of Mac address randomizers and
proxy chains is highly beneficial and
recommended when monitoring networks for
criminal activity and speaking of
proxies ethical hackers must understand
networking fundamentals and exactly how
they are established learning about
various networks and protocols might
help you exploit flaws an ethical hacker
with an extensive understanding of
networking tools such as wire shock nmap
and others can overcome field incidents
relatively unscathed the fifth skill in
our list is traversing the darkware
using the famous store browser most of
the internet is hidden behind the Tor
networks and getting a closer look at
the people who often are at the
Forefront of the hacking industry in the
dark web directly can help you
familiarize yourself with a certain
domain Secrets while keeping you updated
with the latest happenings in the cyber
crime World A major advantage that can
tip the skills in the famor of an
ethical hacker is the knowledge of
cryptography or encryption encryption is
used in various elements of information
security including authentication data
Integrity anonymity and others passwords
and other sensitive information are
always encrypted on a network a hacker
must understand how to recognize and
break these encryption standards
exploring vulnerabilities make you a
better ethical hacker simply keeps you
aware of the security measures that are
kept in place as industry standards
while handing you the most advanced
penetration testing tools on the market
learning how to scan networks and
systems for vulnerabilities that might
result in a security Beach ethical
hackers may also attempt to write
vulnerabilities to exploit the system in
question as a final tip join forums for
conversations with other hackers
worldwide to trade share expertise and
collaborate Discord Reddit Telegram and
other platforms all have communities
where you can join and collaborate with
fellow Learners to broaden your learning
Spectrum now that we understand some
basic skills ethical hackers need to
excel in this domain let us look at the
road map fun can follow to get started
many ethical hackers begin their careers
by studying computer science you can
also acquire an A+ certification from
comp Tia by appearing for and passing
two additional tests these test assess
an individuals understanding of PC
components and their ability to
disassemble and reassemble a PC however
before advancing in your profession you
must gather experience and obtain a
network Plus or a ccns certification the
network plus certification certifies
fundamental Network expertise such as
Network Administration maintenance
deployment and troubleshooting the CCNA
certification guarantees the same skills
and stripes for foundation level
proficiency once qualified you can
advance to the next level of your career
in network support you'll be responsible
for monitoring and upgrading installing
security software and testing for
vulnerabilities you'll obtain expertise
in network security and your goal should
be offered as a position as a network
engineer as a network engineer you will
build and plan networks rather than
simply maintain them your focus should
now be on the security part of your
journey to becoming an ethical hacker
this is the time to focus on earning a
security certifications such as Security
Plus or cissp the US Department of
Defense has approved the Security Plus
accredition which covers testing on
critical areas such as Access Control
identity authentication and cryptography
the cisp certification is a worldwide
recognized security accredition that
validates the expertise of risk
management Cloud technology and
application development The Next Step
would be to start working in the
information security division an
information security analyst study
systems and network security engages
with security beaches and strives to
implement Security Solutions for this
profession you should focus on
penetration testing to gain Hands-On
experiences some of the most essential
tools of the trade getting the certified
ethical hacker or the C certification
should be your top priority the training
will teach you all you must understand
to become a productive and ethical
hacker you'll be engaged in a Hands-On
environment where you will be guided
through breaking into a network and
finding any security flaws after
obtaining this certification you can
begin marketing yourself as a
professional ethical hacker you have
already covered some skills one needs to
learn when starting their Journey
however an ethical hacker has certain
roles and ason responsibilities that
must be carried out meticulously the
first of which is threat modeling threat
modeling is optimizing network security
by identifying bner abilities and
determining counter measures for
avoiding or reducing an attack's impact
on the system a threat is a real or
projected negative incident jeopardizing
the organization's assets the role of an
ethical hacker is to give a thorough
assessment of potentially harmful
assaults and their potential
consequences they can also conduct
information security audits or a
risk-based evaluation of a company
security these regular exercises assess
security Readiness identify it system
weaknesses and offer strategies for
reducing future attack threats they also
assess how successfully security related
policies are implemented resulting in a
report that includes discovered flaws
and appropriate Solutions ethical
writers must be able to collect data
detect vulnerabilities and correlate
risks to create clear and unambiguous
professional reports these evaluations
are frequently used to justify
finalizing security asset expenditures
the market for train ethical hackers has
never been this expensive according to
various surveys the job outl for ethical
hackers and information security analyst
is supposed to grow by 33% between 2020
and 2030 companies like IBM Google and
Microsoft are always on the lookout for
trained cyber security personal in this
climate of data breaches and security
vulnerabilities we hope this video has
cleared some doubts regarding where to
start and what to learn during this
journey when it comes to web app hacking
it generally refers to the exploitation
of applications by HTTP which can be
done by manipulating the applications
via its graphical user interface this is
done by tampering with the uniform
resource identifier also known as a URI
or tampering with the HTTP elements
directly which are not a part of the URI
the hacker can send a link via an email
or a chat and may trick the users of a
web application into executing actions
in case the attack is on an
administrator account the entire web
application can be compromised
anyone who uses a computer connected to
the internet is susceptible to the
threats that computer hackers and online
Predators post these online vain
typically use fishing scams spam email
or instant messages and bogus websites
to deliver dangerous malware to your
computer and compromise your computer
security computer hackers can also try
to access your computer and private
information directly if you're not
protected by a firewall they can monitor
your conversations or puru CH the back
end of your personal website usually
disguised with a bogus identity
Predators can lure you into revealing
sensitive personal and financial
information a web server which can be
referred to as the hardware the computer
or the software which helps to deliver
content that can be accessed through the
internet the primary function of a web
server is to deliver these web pages on
the request to clients using the
hypertext transfer protocol or
HTTP so hackers attack the web web
server to steal credential information
passwords and business information by
using different types of attacks like GS
attacks syn flooding ping flood port
scan and social engineering attacks in
the area of web security despite strong
encryption on the browser server Channel
web users still have no Assurance about
what happens at the other
end although wireless networks offer
great flexibility they have their own
security problems a hacker can sniff the
network packets without having to be in
the same building where the network is
located as wireless networks communicate
through radio waves a hacker can easily
sniff the network from a nearby location
most attackers use Network sniffing to
find the SSID and hack a wireless
network an attacker can attack a network
from a distance and therefore it is
sometimes difficult to collect evidence
against the main
hacker social engineering is the art of
manipulating users of a Computing system
into revealing confidential iial
information which can be later used to
gain unauthorized access to a computer
system the term can also include
activities such as exploiting human
kindness greed and curiosity to gain
access to restricted access buildings or
getting the users to installing backdoor
software knowing the tricks used by
hackers to trick users into releasing
vital login information is fundamental
in protecting computer
systems coming to our main focus for
today let us have a look at the top five
most essential ethical hacking tools to
be used in
2021 at the top of the chain lies
nmap nmap which stands for network
mapper is a free and open-source utility
for network discovery and security
auditing many systems and network
administrators also find it useful for
tasks such as Network inventory managing
service upgrade schedules and monitoring
host or service up time it is most
beneficial in the early stages of
ethical hacking where a hacker must
figure the possible entry point to a
system before running the necessary
exploits thus allowing the hackers to
leverage any insecure openings and thus
breach the
device nmap users raw IB packets in
novel ways to determine what hosts are
available on the network what service
they are running what operating systems
are installed what type of packet
filters and firewalls are in used and
dozens other characteristics it was
designed to rapidly scan large networks
but works finds against single host as
well since every application that
connects to a network needs to do so via
a port the wrong port or a server
configuration can open a can of worms
which lead to a thorough breach of the
system and ultimately a fully hacked
device next on our list we have
Metasploit the metlo framework is a very
powerful tool that can be used by cyber
criminals as well as ethical hackers to
probe system atic vulnerabilities on
both networks and servers because it's
an open source framework it can be
easily customized and used with most
operating
systems with Metasploit the ethical
hacking team can use readymade or custom
code and introduce it into a network to
probe for weak spots as another flavor
of threat hunting once the flaws are
identified and documented the
information can be used to address
systemic weaknesses and prioritize
Solutions once a particular
vulnerability is identified and the
necessary exploit is fed into the system
there are a host of options for the
hacker depending on the vulnerability
hackers can even run root commands from
the terminal allowing complete control
over the activities of the compromise
system as well as all the personal data
stored on the
device a big advantage of Metasploit is
the ability to run full-fledged scans on
the target system which gives a detailed
picture of the security index of the
system along with the necessary exploits
that can be used to bypass the antivirus
softwares having a single solution to
gather almost all the necessary points
of attack is very useful for ethical
hackers and penetration testers as
denoted by its high rank in the
list moving on we have the actic
framework actic is an endtoend web
security scanner which offers a 360
degree view of an organization security
it is an application security testing
tool that helps the company address
vulnerability across all their critical
web
assets the need to be able to test
application in depth and further than
traditional vulnerability management
tools has created a market with several
players in the application security
space acuns can detect over 7,000
vulnerabilities including SQL injections
cross-site scripting misconfigurations
weak passwords exposed database and
other outof band vulnerabilities
it can scan all pages web apps and
complex web applications running HTML 5
and JavaScript as well it also lets you
scan complex multi-level forms and even
password protected areas of the
site actic is a dynamic application
security testing package which has
definite perks over status application
security testing Frameworks which are
also known as sast scanners s tools only
work during development and only for
specific languages and have a history of
reporting lot of false positives whereas
Dynamic testing tools also known as D
have the ability to streamline testing
from development to deployment with
minimal
issues next on our list we have
airgeddon this is a multi-use bash
script used for Linux systems to hack
and audit wireless networks like our
everyday Wi-Fi router and its
counterparts along with being able to
launch denial of service attacks on comp
romis networks this multi-purpose wi-fi
hacking tool has very rich features
which support multiple methods for wi-fi
hacking including WPS hacking modes WP
attacks handshake captures evil twin and
so much
more it usually needs an external
network adapter that supports monitor
mode which is necessary to be able to
capture Wireless traffic that Traverse
the air
channels thanks to its open source
nature air Garden can be used with
multiple Community plugins and addons
thereby increasing its Effectiveness
against a wide variety of routers both
in the 2.4 GHz and the 5 GHz
band finally at number five we have John
the Ripper John the Ripper is an
open-source password security auditing
and the password recovery tool which is
available for many operating
systems John the Ripper jumbo supports
100 of hash and Cipher types including
for user passwords of operating systems
web apps database server servers
encrypted keys and document files some
of the key features of the tool include
offering multiple modes to speed up the
password cracking automatically
deselecting the hashing algorithm used
by the passwords and the ease of running
and configurating the tool to make it
password cracking
easier it can use dictionary attacks
along with regular brute forcing to
speed up the process of cracking the
correct password without wasting
additional resources the word list being
used in these dictionary attacks can be
used by the users end allowing for a
completely customizable
process we also have a few honorary
mentions in our list that just miss the
cut netsparker for instance is an
automated yet fully configurable web
application security scanner that
enables you to scan websites web
applications and web services the
scanning technology is designed to help
you secure web applications easily
without any fuss so you can focus on
fixing the reported
vulnerabilities
the bub suit professional is one of the
most popular penetration testing and
vulnerability finder tools and it's used
for checking web application security
the term bur as it is commonly known is
a proxy based tool which is used to
evaluate the security of web based
application and to do Hands-On testing
moving away from websites and
applications Yak is a free and
open-source packet analyzer which was
launched in 2006 it is used for Network
troubleshooting analysis software and
Communications protocol development and
education it captures Network traffic on
the local network and stores data for
offline analysis ysha captures Network
traffic from ethernet Bluetooth wireless
networks and frame relay
connections now that we learn about the
different types of tools that can be
used when conducting an ethical hacking
audit let's learn about some potential
benefits of such campaigns and why
organizations prefer to pay for such
audits
being able to identify defects from an
attacker's perspective is gamechanging
since it displays all the potential
Avenues of a possible hack one can only
prepare for the known vulnerabilities as
a defensive specialist but proactively
trying to breach a network or device can
make hackers think of techniques that no
defense contractors can account for this
kind of unpredictability goes a long way
in securing a network against malicious
actors
another advantage of hiring ethical
hackers is the ability to preemptively
fix possible weak points in a company's
Network infrastructure as seen on many
occasions a real breach will cause loss
of data and irreparable damage to the
foundation of an organization being able
to gauge such shortcomings before they
become public and can be used exploited
is a benefit most organizations make use
of this is not to imply that such
security audits are only beneficial to
with the organization paying for it when
coming across companies that provide
certain Services a reliable third party
security audit goes a long way in
instilling trust and confidence over
their craft if the ethical hackers
cannot find any major vulnerabilities
that can be leveraged by hackers it just
accentuates the technical bence of the
organization and its Engineers thereby
increasing the clientele by a
substantial amount in this we are going
to discuss ethical hacking and
penetration testing so we're going to
talk about the concepts of about what
constitutes an ethical hack and what is
a penetration test we're going to talk
about the different types of penetration
test and how they can be done we're
going to talk about an operating system
called KH Linux and we're going to talk
about its usage and its importance in
cyber security we will also be
discussing the different phases of
penetration test and how people or
hackers would utilize these phases uh to
gain their objectives we will also be
discussing in what areas can we do a
penetration test how to do those
penetration test we'll be discussing
quite a few bit of penetration testing
tools that are available in the Ki Linux
space and then we'll be looking at a
couple of demos at the end of the
session to understand how these tools in
the operating system can be utilized for
various hacks so let's start with with
what is ethical hacking now plainly
defined ethical hacking is locating
weaknesses or vulnerabilities of
computers and information systems using
the intent and actions of a malicious
hacker the major difference is here that
we are hired to discover those
weaknesses in a legal and ethical manner
that means first and foremost our intent
should not be malicious we do not wish
any harm to the organization and
whatever we discover is reported back
and not misused once we report back we
would also be trying to help them out to
mitigate or remove those weaknesses or
vulnerabilities to enhance the company
security posture so essentially we would
have the same training or the same
knowledge as that of a malicious hacker
except that the intent is going to be
different the intent is going to help
the organization achieve security to
protect themselves against malicious
hackers and the second most important
thing about ethical hacking is that we
authorized to do that activity I cannot
in good faith hack somebody and then
tell them you know what I just I just
wanted to help you out and uh here are
your vulnerabilities and uh this is the
way you can prevent them I first need
the authorization from the other party
and only then can I perform an ethical
hack so in this example hacker attacks
an individual with malicious intent and
makes misuse of whatever information
they have gotten they steal the data
they maybe fry the operating system
Hardware destroy it and thus uh they
leave the victim without uh a device
with authorization an ethical hacker can
also attack the same individual minus
the destruction of course and the intent
is good so they're willingly finding out
the vulnerabilities and helping the
victim plug them out so that they
wouldn't be a victim of a malicious
attack now here the first thing is
authorization from the victim and the
second thing is the good intent where we
do not misuse those vulnerabilities and
we report them back to the victim or to
the client and help them uh patch those
vulnerabilities that's the main
difference between a white hat and a
black hat so Security Experts are
normally termed as white hat hackers
malicious hackers are termed as black
hats now the responsibilities of ethical
hacker are multifold first and formost
you have to create scripts test for
vulnerabilities first have to identify
those in the first place so there's a
vulnerability assessment identifying
those vulnerabilities and then you're
going to test them to see the validity
and the complexity of those
vulnerabilities so your one of your
responsibilities would be to develop
tools to increase security as well or to
configure Security in such a way that it
would be difficult to breach performing
risk assessment now what is a risk risk
is a threat that is posed to an
organization by a possibility of of
getting hacked so let's say I as a
ethical hacker run a vulnerability
scanner on a particular client I
identify 10 different vulnerabilities
within those 10 vulnerabilities I do a
risk assessment to identify which
vulnerability is critical would have the
most impact on the client and what would
be the
and the loss could not only be loss of
data it could be Financial losses it
could be loss of reputation penalties
they have to pay to the client for
breaches or penalties that they may have
to pay for pay the governments in case
of breaches that happened that uh
couldn't be controlled another
responsibility of the ethical hacker is
to set up policies in such a way that it
becomes difficult for hackers to get
access to devices or to protected data
and finally train the staff for network
security so uh we got a lot lot of
employees in an organization we need to
train the staff of what is allowed and
what is not allowed how to keep
themselves secure so that they don't get
compromised thus becoming a
vulnerability themselves to the
organization the policies that we have
talked about are administrative policies
to govern the employees of the
organization for example password
policies most of the organizations will
have a tough password policy where they
say you have to create a password that
meets a certain level of complexity
before that can be accepted and tell you
create that password you're not allowed
to log in or you're not allowed to
register so let's move on to understand
what is penetration testing now for
penetration testing there's a phase
called vulnerability assessment that
happens before this vulnerability
assessment is nothing but running a
scanning tool to identify a list of
potential flaws or vulnerabilities
within the organization once you have
identified the list of those
vulnerabilities you would then move on
to penetration test this is the part of
ethical hacking where it specifically
focuses on penetration only of the
Information Systems so you have
identified that flaw maybe it could be a
database with a SQL injection or it
could be a buffer over overrun flaw or
it could be a simple password cracking
attempt your idea is to create those
tools create those attacks and try to
penetrate into those areas where
security is weak uh the essense of
penetration testing is to penetrate
Information Systems using various
attacks the attacks could be anything
like a fishing attack a password
cracking attack a denal of service
attack or any other vulnerabilities that
you have identified during the VAB scan
so what is Ki Linux and why is it used K
Linux is an operating system oftenly
used by hackers and ethical hackers both
because of the tool sets that the
operating system contains it is
Operating System created by
professionals with a lot of embedded
tools it is a dbn based operating system
with Advanced penetration testing and
security auditing features there are
more than 600 plus odd tools on that
operating system that can help you
leverage any of the attacks man in the
middle attacks sniffing password
cracking any of these attacks would be
possible with all the tools available
you just need to know how to utilize the
operating system and its tools contains
like I said a hundred of hundreds of
tools that are used for various
information security tasks like uh
computer forensics rever reverse
engineering information finding even uh
getting access to different machines and
then uh creating viruses worms Trojans
and anything that you will 600 plus
tools in the Kali Linux operating system
there are periodic updates that are
given out to the operating system as
well it is open source that means it is
free to utilize you can even have the
source code you can modify it if you
want to there's customizations available
for all the tools you can download third
party tools and install them if you want
there's a white support for wireless uh
network cards multiple languages are
being supported at the time at the same
time as well and you can create a lot of
of attacking uh scripts you can create
attacking tools and you can write your
own exploits as well on K Linux so this
all all in all helps you create a very
robust system where you can create your
own attacks and then launch them against
unsuspecting victims now that is illegal
so as far ethical hacking is concerned
once you have authorization you're going
to identify which tools should be
utilized you're going to get the
appropriate permissions and only then
are you going to attempt those attacks
let's talk about the phases of
penetration testing now there are five
different phases the first one is the
recognizance phase also known as the
information gathering phase this is the
most important phase for any hacker this
is where the hacker or the ethical
hacker if you will will gather as much
information about the target's victim or
V vers the V the victim right so once
you have that information you would then
be able to identify what tool sets to
include and how to attack the victim for
example you want to find out the IP
address the domains subdomains the
network architecture that is being
utilized you want to identify operating
systems that are being utilized the
network IP ranges that are being
utilized and so on so forth you might
want to identify employees within an
organization for social engineering
attacks in the future email addresses
telephone numbers anything and
everything that will help you validate
and give you information about the
target is something that you want to do
in the recognizance phase at this point
in time we are not going to question
whether what whatever information we are
getting is useful or not only time will
tell depending on the various attacks
that we will be building up later on
this becomes your Baseline this becomes
your database with all the information
about the victim so that you can come
back from later stages back to the
recognizance phase to look at the
information that You' have gathered and
then you can find tune your attacks once
you have done that you're going to uh
then start the scanning phase based on
the information that you have gathered
you're going to identify live machines
within a network once youve identified
the live machines you'll scan them for
open ports protocols and procedures any
processes that are running and then we
going to identify vulnerabilities Within
These processes and Within These open
ports so in the scanning phase uh why do
we need to find live machines because we
want to find out the machines that have
booted up have an operating system and
are running on the network if an machine
is not available on the network or is in
a shutdown mode that machine cannot be
hacked through a technical attack then
it will be a physical attack where you
physically go to the machine and then do
whatever you want to do with it for a
technical attack you will have to
identify the machines that have booted
up then you're going to scan the open
ports because that's going to be our
entry point and on the port would be a
service that is running so you scan the
service as well identify the version of
the service and then do a vulnerability
scan to identify if there are any
vulnerabilities on those services that
are running and then based on all of
this information we are going to develop
our attacks as we go on so once we have
this we go onto the gaining access phas
where we are going to attack and try to
get access to our victims machines could
be a social engineering attack based on
the information gathering we have done
in the technical assessment in scanning
phase if you have identified a
vulnerability you're going to identify a
relevant exploit and then use that
exploit to try to gain access or we
might just craft a Trojan and try to uh
execute that trojen on the victim's
machine to uh check if we can get access
through that particular manner once we
have the access could be even a simple
password cracking attack which we have
been able to accomplish and we have
cracked the password of the person and
now we have gained access to that
person's computer right but these
attacks would be temporary for example
we have cracked a password somebody
changes the password every 30 days after
that period our attack would be useless
if a Trojan is executed we get a
connection to that machine for once but
then how do we get get a repeated
connection over and over again if we
want to reconnect to that machine so
that's where we come into the
maintaining access phase where we
install uh root kits key loggers
sniffers and things like that where we
could get a back door entry to the
victim's machine if we have already been
successfully installed a Trojan we would
want to add the Trojan to the startup
menu so that every time the operating
system starts the Trojan gets
automatically executed and thus we
maintain the back door entry to that
victim's machine once we have done all
of this all these activities are going
to leave a trace in the victim's machine
so if you install a a Trojan being an
application would create directories and
files a virus would be destructive in
nature if you're executing a script it
will leave some logs behind if we even
login through the cracked password that
we have it will create a login entry at
for that particular time stamp along
with the IP address that we utilized in
the covering tracks we are essentially
trying to avoid detection by deleting
traces of our activity that means that
we need to identify where logs are been
stored we need to address those logs and
we need to delete them or modify them in
such a way that our activity is not
traceable so these are the five main
phases of a penetration test gather as
much information as you can scan for
machines ports protocols and services
running on the victim's device try to
gain access by password cracking inions
exploits for the V lities if any
maintain that access by installing
further software which will allow you to
get back door access to that particular
system and then try to cover your tracks
by deleting all traces of your activity
once successful the victim will have no
idea and you have a backd door entry and
you can monitor the victim to the extent
that you want now in an ethical hacker
perspective this penetration test can be
done in multiple aspects so again
understand the fact that we are doing an
authorized activity we have identified
the tools that we have to use identified
the attacks we have got the appropriate
authorization and based on that
authorization we are conducting a
penetration test the penetration test
may be asked to be done in one of these
manners first is the blackbox test the
blackbox test is where no information is
given to the ethical hacker about the it
infrastructure so they have no idea what
it is they start right from the first
phase of the information gathering
gather as much information they can and
based on the gathered information they
try to create and launch attacks to see
if they are going to be successful now
not only does it test the knowledge of
the penetration tester it would also
test the security implementations that
the organization has done to see whether
they can identify the attack and prevent
it in the first place so this isign
ation of a malicious hacker scenario
where a malicious hacker having no idea
about the organization first tries to
gather information and then tries to
attack that organization so no source
code knowledge no technological
knowledge nothing they're just going to
try to gather information scan those
devices and then try to gain access the
second test is a gray box test where
some information is given or some
knowledge of the it infrastructure is
given think of it from a employes
perspective a regular employee in an
organization who doesn't have extra
privileges uh like an administrator but
is just a uh regular employee does that
means that they got limited access
within the organization based on which
they get some knowledge of the it
infrastructure so this is an attempt of
an Insider uh simulation attack where a
regular user may want to try to misuse
the access that they've been given and
then try to gather information or try to
gain access to other devices which they
are not authorized to the third test is
white box where there's full knowledge
of the it structure that has been given
so this is again a simulation of an
Insider attack a malicious Insider if
you will but at this point in time the
person has complete knowledge of the
infrastructure could be in an
administrative position and then they
are trying to leverage their access to
see if they can get information or they
can compromise any stuff any of the data
so the three attacks would be the first
one blackbox where we are simulating uh
external threat a hacker sitting outside
the organization trying to gain access
the gray box is an Insider threat where
there's a regular employee who is trying
to get access to infrastructure that
they are not authorized for and then the
third audit is a white box audit where
there's an administrator who has all the
leverage all the access and the
visibility within the infrastructure and
then they're trying to misuse their
access to see what else they can get
from whatever access has been authorized
to them now let's look at the areas of
penetration testing where all could we
do a penetration test does compromising
the security of the application or of
the server or of the user so first and
foremost Network Services it finds
vulnerabilities and weaknesses in the
security of the network infrastructure
so for example we have switches routers
firewalls in the network all of these
are devices that need a configuration if
they have been not correctly configured
or if they have not been correctly
secured they would leave some V
liabilities behind if we as ethical
hackers are able to identify these flaws
these misconfigurations these
vulnerabilities we could then try to
exploit them and try to gain access to
the network and devices within that
Network by uh getting access to the
network in the first place then we have
the web applications web applications
are nothing but softwares that are
developed over or deployed over a web
server and are made available over the
intranet or the internet for example uh
websites that we visit or web
applications like Facebook if you will
right so if these applications have
vulnerabilities within them we then try
to attack the web based applications and
thus try to bypass authentication or get
access to database or try to leak
information through those applications
if not then we try to attack the client
side now web application is at the
server level and is hosted by the
deployer so that's at the server side
the client side is where we as users are
using a computer with a browser and
trying to interact with the web
application now the browser and the
operating system that we are utilizing
would have its own vulnerabilities thus
identifying a client side varability and
then exploiting it to either either hack
the client or then piggy back on the
client's connection and try to get
access to the server so either you could
attack the network the web application
or the client side itself or you could
attack wireless networks this test would
examine all the wireless devices which
are used in a corporation most of the
wireless would have laptops smartphones
tablets faets all of those connected to
them if you're able to access any of
these devices through the wireless it
would help you gain access to other
devices on the wireless as well and then
social engineering so this is where
you're trying to attack huge humans you
tricking an employee of a corporation to
reveal some confidential information
knowingly or unknowingly by tricking
them with fake mails or fake websites or
malicious emails that you have sent to
them uh which they have failed to
recognized as malicious and they click
on it thus getting victimized social
engineering attacks are always uh
successful because of the gullibility of
humans empathy sympathy humans basically
have emotions emotions can be toyed with
and then taken advantage of if the
person is not careful enough for example
the most common social engineering
attack that we see is the Nigerian fraud
where we receive an email that someone
somewhere has died and has left a huge
estate behind a few hundred million doar
and we have been identified as the
person through whom they want to
transfer the money to a foreign land to
save on taxes what are the chances of
that happening on a daily basis right
how many princes are there so that's
something that we do not verify it's
just the I guess the greed if you will
of striking it rich quickly that makes
us believe these kind of emails uh we
have also received emails of lottery
tickets that we have won over a period
of time without even having bought a
lottery ticket so if you haven't bought
one what did you win but we don't ask
these questions we just get excited
about the amount of money that we have
won and then we try to bet on our luck
and try to see if that uh email is going
to fructify or is it just under of the
scam so social inuring attacks are dime
a dozen these days and we need to be
very careful on what we trust on on the
internet let's look at the penetration
testing tools there are hundreds and
thousands of tools out there most of
these have been concised and collected
together and hosted on a operating
system known as KH Linux that we have
talked about earlier now the predecessor
to KH Linux was backtrack backtrack is
no longer continued it has been
discontinued and K Linux has taken uh
the place of backtrack within which are
all the tools that you see on your
screen Metasploit is one of the most
favorite penetration testing tools of of
hackers and ethical hackers uh there are
a lot of inbuilt exploits over there and
we'll be doing a demo at the end of the
session on this nmap is the information
gathering tool which will scan for live
devices scan for open ports protocols
and services beef would be an
application testing tool that would help
us uh find exploits within applications
nessus vulnerability scanner is a
network and a host based scanner that
would help you identify V abilities
within such hosts wi shock is a network
sniffer which allows you to capture
Network packets and and analyze them to
see if there are there is any
information worth capturing within those
packets SQL map is a automated tool used
for SQL injection attacks so you don't
even have to craft your queries for sqil
injection it will be done by the SQL map
tool you just need to identify whatever
is possible through the queries that
this SQL is going to create and then
based on the activity that you've
identified you just need to redefine
your search parameters to get access to
the database we'll be doing a demo on
SQL map or SQL map as well and then
there is John the Ripper John the Ripper
is a tool that is used for password
cracking so dictionary attacks Brute
Force attacks are done using John the
Ripper what is a dictionary attack a
dictionary attack is an attack where we
create list of all probable passwords
store them in a txt file and run that
list against the password tool to see if
any of those passwords are going to
match a Brute Force attack is trying the
same attack but with every per
permutation and combination of the
alphabet that we have and we're going to
try to figure out uh if we are able to
crack the password at all so these are
just some of the tools for every tool
there are another supporting 100 tools
or more than that uh like for NS
vulnerability scanner you'll have Callis
vulnerability scanner you have uh GFI
lanard and there are other lots of other
softwares out there but these are some
of the most commonly utilized tools
let's look at the Metasploit attack
Metasploit is a framework of penetration
testing that makes hacking very simple
you just need to know how to utilize the
tool you need to identify the
vulnerability associated with a
particular exploit and then run the
exploit on metas sploit uh we'll be
demoing this during the Practical so
there are active exploits and passive
exploits in active exploits exploits a
specific computer runs until execution
and then exits uses brute force and
exits when an error occurs in a passive
exploit these exploits wait for incoming
requests and exploit them as soon as
they connect they can also be used in
conjunction with emails and web browsers
so in passive exploits we create a
payload we uh like a reverse connection
payload we send it to the victim once
the victim installs that software the
machine will then initiate a connection
to us our machine will be in a listen
mode and then we will once the software
is executed at there and we would then
try to connect and exploit that
particular vulnerability this is the uh
practical that we'll be doing on
Metasploit so let's move on with the
demos and then we'll see uh what we can
discuss amongst them all right let's
have a look at some of the demos that we
had talked about in the ethical hacking
and penetration testing module we are
going to look at three different demos
the first one is going to be a SQL
injection attack that we're going to
perform on this tool that we have the
second one is a password cracking attack
on Windows 7 and the third one is a meta
based or a metas sploit based shellshock
attack on a Linux based web server so
let's get cracking I've powered on this
virtual machine uh which is the ovas
broken web application it is a tool that
is provided for people who want to
enhance their skills and they can
practice uh how to do these attacks in a
legal manner so we are going to go to
this site I'm just going to open up my
browser the IP address is 7113 to and
that's the OAS broken web application
that we want to utilize we're going to
head off to mutil Day 2 and we are going
to look at a SQL injection attack where
we want to bypass authentication now
this takes us to the login screen so we
can just try our luck here and see that
the Authentication mechanism works the
account does not exist so the username
and password that we have supplied is
not the correct one so we want to ensure
that there's a SQL database and uh we
can uh try to attack it and see uh if we
can bypass the authentication now uh
what we want to do is we want to create
a SQL based malformed query that can
give us a different output so I'm just
going to type in a single quote over
here and type login and you can see that
this is now suddenly recognized as a
operator and there a error that is given
out compared to the login that we tried
uh earlier when we used a proper text
based login mechanism it gave us the
account does not exist but here the
single code gave us a error and it shows
us how SQL works this is the query that
we had created now in the trainings that
you have for ethical hacking there would
be explanations of what these queries
are all about how the syntax works here
we just going to see if we can create a
malform query to log in as a user in
this case so what I'm going to do is uh
create the query over here and we're
going to give it a comparison so we're
going to give it R 1 = 1 space hyphen
hyphen space and if you now click login
you should be able to bypass
authentication and you can see user has
been authenticated and we now have admin
access to this application now here the
SQL queries need to be crafted in such a
perspective that they're going to work
so there would be a lot of exercise in
identifying what the database is there's
a Microsoft database and Oracle database
and so on so forth and then you have to
choose those proper commands but
identifying that would come in the
training right now we're just looking at
at a demo this is how a SQL injection
attack works now let me log out here
similarly now we are in a login page the
same query worked wonders where it
allowed us to bypass authentication so
it also depends on what kind of a page I
am and what query would be accepted at
this point in time so here application
understanding would also come into the
picture where uh which function we
calling upon when we connected to a
particular page now this is a user
lookup function right so again here we
try the same method test test that's not
going to work authentication error bad
user on password and if you type in the
same query over here single quote or and
give it a condition single quote or 1
equals 1 space hyphen hyphen space now
here it is not going to log Us in
because this is not a login page this is
a user lookup form so here it would
instead give us a dump of all the
databases that it has so you can see all
the usernames and password passwords
coming in that are stored in the user
lookup field so this is where the
understanding comes in of which query to
create at what page we are depending
upon the function that is being called
right so that's the SQL uh injection
attack that we wanted to look at let's
move on to password cracking now this is
a Windows 7 machine that we have I'm
just going to do a very basic password
cracking example we're just going to log
in now here the assumption is that we
are able to log in we have access to a
computer and we want to check out other
users who are using this computer and
see if we can find out their passwords
so that uh we can log in as a different
user steal data if required and we
wouldn't be to blame if there are any
locks that are created so here we've got
a tool called can enable that is
installed right here now I'm already an
administrator on this machine I'm
checking out other administrators who
share the same privileges or any other
user who may be on this system whose
password I can crack and thus I would be
able to get access through their account
and then do any malicious activity right
so this allows me to go into a cracker
tool and it allows me to enumerate this
machine and identify all the users and
passwords that are there in this
particular machine right so I'm just
going to click on the plus sign and I'm
going to import uh hashes from a local
system so where are these files stored
where does Windows store its passwords
in what format are they stored and what
this tool does to retrieve those that's
something that we all need to know as a
ethical hacker right so import the
hashes from the local system click on
next it's going to enumerate that file
and it is going to give you a list of
all the users that are there so you can
see the users or hacker admin test the
one that we are logged in as and then
there's a user called virus as well and
you can see that this is the hash value
of the password that is being utilized
now there's a particular format uh for a
hash value for Windows and how it stores
but once we have these hash values let's
say if I want to crack this password
there are various attacks that we can do
for example a dictionary based attack or
a Brute Force attack let's try a Brute
Force attack right ntlm is the hashing
mechanism that is used by windows so
we're going to try to create an ntlm
hash attack and here we're going to use
a predetermined rule set for example we
are not sure what characters are being
utilized over here so we just create an
attack like this using all characters
and uh lower case a through Zed upper
case a through Zed numeric 0 through 9
and all the special character characters
let's say the password is between 7 and
16 characters and this is the character
set that we want to try the Brute Force
attack on what is a root Force attack it
is an attack where the computer is going
to try each and every permutation and
combination out of this character set
and try to figure out if the password is
going to be correct so if we click Start
it's going to start with a particular
characters and then it is going to
identify if that ntlm hash is going to
work against this character and you can
see the time is going to be phenomenal
over here so so it's not necessary that
this attack would be viable it will be
100% successful given the time frame
however the time frame is huge enough
for this attack to become a little bit
redundant there are other attacks that
we can do which can easily identify this
data for us as well but that is
something that we will look on in future
videos so that's how you can get access
to users and passwords uh there are
different mechanisms where let's say we
don't have login access then what are we
going to do how we can create a fake
user login or how we can remotely access
a machine and then try to get the same
access and that is what we going to try
to do in the next demo on a Linux
machine so what we are doing in a Linux
machine could also be doable on the
Windows machine with a different exploit
so what I'm going to do is this is the
Linux web server that I have that I'm
going to power on I'm going to use a
Kali Linux machine to hack that device
and I'm going to just power off my
Windows 7 machine give it a minute till
it boots up now this is also a demo
machine that we have which has has its
own preconfigured vulnerabilities so
here we've got something from the
pentesters lab uh and has a shell shock
vulnerability implemented inside shell
shock vulnerability affects Linux Mac
and Unix based operating systems for a
particular version of The Bash shell
bash is the bone again shell which is
the command line interface in these
operating systems so what we are trying
to do here is we are going to use the Ki
Linux machine try to find out the
vulnerability over here and if it exists
we're going to use metas sploit to
attack this machine now the first and
foremost thing is we want to identify
the IP address we have no idea what the
IP address is we are in the same subnet
so we are assuming that we able to
connect to this machine so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to open up a
tool called zenmap I'm going to open up
a command line interface find out what
my IP address is and my IP address is
this with a subnet mask of 2555 255
255.0.0.0 and we are doing a ping Swip
over here to identify which machines are
live in a minute we'll get all the IP
addresses 71.1 2 133 254 and 128 we know
that we are 128 at this point in time uh
254 is the DHCP server so we assuming
that 133 is the machine that we want to
look at and let's then try to see if we
can scan that machine 133 and we're
going to do an intense scan to find out
which ports are open what services are
running over there and if it is whether
the pentest machine that we were looking
for you can see of the start Port 22 and
Port 80 and somewhere here it's going to
give us the ports that are open and the
details about those ports and somewhere
here it will tell us that this is the
pentester lab machine that we wanted
which is correct so now we want to do a
vulnerability analysis on this what
we're going to do is I'm going to use
another GUI based tool called Sparta
which I can just find out from here
Sparta uses two tools in the background
uh and map tool and a tool called ncto
so we just going to start scanning 192
71133 was the IP address add to scope
and over a period of time you can see
all of these will start populating with
information there we are that's the nto
tool coming in scanning on Port 80 which
is uh which means that it's a web server
using HTTP it tells us it's an Apache HT
httpd
2.2.2 and that gives us the 22 port
number as well if we head over to the
tab of ncto or let's look at the
screenshot first this is what the
website would be looking like and ncto
gives us the options over here it tells
us that there is a vulnerability over
here for shell shock and this is the
path where the vulnerability is going to
exist so what we going to do we go back
to the command line sorry we open up a
new one minimize all these other windows
and we going to open up Metasploit
Metasploit is a penetration testing tool
that is used by most hackers and ethical
hackers to test applications and test uh
existing exploits and vulnerabilities so
just give it a minute till it starts you
can see there are already around 1,700
exploits right here uh we're going to
see all those exploits with these
commands there we are sorry for the typo
and it will just give us a list of all
the exploits that are stored in metas
spit in this version so all of these are
windows based if we scroll up we will be
looking at other vulnerabilities as well
or exploits the uni space exploits LX
OSX multi exploits and we're looking for
a exploit for um multi- based Apache or
HTTP let's go up uh let's look at so
this is the one that we're looking for
Apache mod CGI bash environmental
executable so what we're going to do is
we just going to copy it go back to the
bottom say use exploit and paste the one
that we wanted press enter say show
options so it will ask us to configure
this I'm just going to configure it
based on the knowledge that we have set
our host which is the remote host the
victims machine so we put in the IP
address it asks us for the Target URI so
that's the path that we saw set Target
URI to CGI hyphen bin SL status enter
now with the exploit we need to find a
payload that is going to give us the
output that we want so we say show
payloads and it will give us a list of
all the compatible payloads with this
exploit and we want to create a reverse
TCP connection which is this so we know
it's a Linux operating system we want
this uh payload to be set so set payload
press enter that's the payload coming in
show options now that we have set the
payload this is the options for the
exploit and now we want to set our
options for the payloads as well so we
are creating a reverse TCP connection
which means we are remotely executing
code at the victim side and making the
victim connect back to our machine which
means we need to set up a listener so I
need to put my IP address over here set
local host or lhost 192
16871 128 which was our IP address show
options again just to ensure everything
is fine which looks like it is and we
then type in the word exploit so that it
will start this attack I can see that it
has created a MPR session at the victim
site and it has opened up a session so
if I do a PWD now PWD is a Linux command
for present working directory and it
will show us that we'll connected to
where dub dubdub CGI has in bin do an LS
it will list all the files that's the
status file over there do a CD back
slash it will take us to the root of
this machine if you are someone who is
interested in building a career in cyber
security by graduating from the best
universities or a professional who alits
to switch careers with cyber security by
learning from the experts then try
giving a short to Simply learns
postgraduate program in cyber security
with modules from Mitman College of
Engineering the course link is mentioned
in the description box that will
navigate you to the course page where
you can find find a complete overview of
the program being offered in a world
where digital Footprints are traced
censorship looms and cyber threats lurk
in the shadows the need for a shielded
connection has never been more crucial
that's where VPN swoop in like digital
superheroes whisking you away into a
realm of secure browsing Anonymous
identities and unrestricted access to
the vast wonders of the web welcome back
tech Enthusiast and curious minds today
we are diving into the mysterious realm
of vpns but how exactly does this
technological Marvel operate how does at
clock your online activities and your
true location feeling curious well today
we will dystify the inner workings of
VPN and help you with the knowledge
picture this you are sipping your
favorite beverage at a local cafe
enjoying the convenience of public Wi-Fi
little do you know lurking nearby could
be cyber criminals itching to snatch
your sensitive information but fret note
with a VPN by your side your connection
transforms into a impregnable Fortress
encrypting your data and shielding it
from prying eyes so grab your
metaphorical pass passports fter your
virtual seat belts and join me on this
captivating Expedition through the inner
workings of VPN technology without
further Ado let the quest to unve the
wonders of VPN begin before we begin if
you are someone who is interested in
building a career in cyber security by
graduating from the best universities or
a professional who elicits to switch
careers with cyber security by learning
from the experts then try giving a short
to Simply learns postgraduate program in
cyber security with modules from MIT
schwarzman College of Engineers
the course link is mentioned in the
description box that will navigate you
to the course page where you can find a
complete overview of the program being
offered if these are the types of videos
you would like to watch then hit the
Subscribe button like and press the Bell
icon to never miss on further content
now let's get started here we will start
with what is a VPN then we'll see how
does a VPN work and then we will see the
types of vpns and then see the
advantages of VPN and then explore the
disadvantages of VPN so starting with
what is a VPN VPN stands for virtual
private Network it's a service that
helps you stay private and secure while
browsing the internet a VPN creates a
secure encrypted connection between your
device and the internet making it
impossible for anyone to intercept your
data and now we'll see how does a VPN
works so to understand how a VPN Works
let's imagine and let's imagine a tunnel
that connects your device to the
internet and all your data pass through
this tunnel ensuring privacy and
security when you use a VPN it encrypts
all your data on your device before
sending it through the tunnel to the
internet this encryption ensures that
even if someone intercepts your data
they won't be able to decipher it your
data is encrypted and your IP address is
hidden making it difficult for any to
trace your online activities the
encryption tunnel created by a VPN
protects your data from hackers cyber
criminals and even your intern interet
service provider it works by scrambling
your data into an unreadable code that
can only be decrypted by your device and
the VPN server when you connect to a
website through a VPN server your
connection appears to come from the
server rather than your device this
helps protect your privacy and prevents
websites from tracking your real
location so this is how a VPN works now
moving on uh but before moving on you
could just see this diagram and you
would be very clear how does this VPN
works so here is the VPN tunnel through
which the encrypted data flows so when
the encrypted data flows from the VPN
tunnel even the internet service
provider can't detect your IP address
and this IP address or this encrypted
data that would be converted into some
codes and that would be detected by the
VPN server and that increases the
privacy and then you would access the
internet or the website you want to
access
so we are done with how VPN works now
we'll see some types of VPN so there are
two main types of VPN the first one is
Remote Access VPN and the second is side
to side VPN so remote access vpns allow
individuals to securely connect to a
private Network while s side to side VPN
they are used by businesses to connect
multiple locations and vpns use
different encryption protocols to ensure
the security of your connection and here
we have openvpn that is an example exle
and is an open- Source protocol known
for its strong security features it's
important to choose a VPN provider that
uses reliable encryption protocols to
safeguard your data now we'll see why we
use VPN or why you need a VPN now that
we have understood how a VPN Works let's
talk about why we need one so first and
foremost a VPN offers privacy by
encrypting your data and routing it
through secure servers a VPN Shields or
online activity from your internet
service provider that is ISP government
agencies or hackers it keeps your
personal information such as browsing
history passwords and credit card
details away from Prime eyes and the
next feature is anonymity it's an
another significant advantage of using a
VPN when you connect to the internet
through a VPN it mask your original IP
address and assign you a different one
this makes it difficult for anyone to
track your online activities back to
your real location or identity the next
feature we have is security it's a top
priority when using a VPN by encrypting
your data a VPN ensures that it remains
confidential and secure during
transmission this is particularly
crucial when using public Wi-Fi networks
which are often vulnerable to cyber
attacks a VPN adds an extra layer of
protection safeguarding your sensitive
information from potential hackers
lurking on the same network now moving
to another feature that is bypass filter
filters and unlock websites so this is
one of the key features of a VPN and its
ability to pass that is bypass filters
and unlock websites in certain scenarios
websites may be restricted or blocked by
organizations schools or governments
with a VPN you can bypass these
restrictions and gain access to the
content you desire whether it's social
networking sites streaming platforms or
any other blocked content a VPN allows
you to enjoy internet Freedom the next
we have is these Regal restrictions so
Regional restrictions can also be
overcome with the VPN some online
services and websites are available only
to specific regions or countries by
connecting to a VPN server in the
desired location you can change your IP
address and appear as if you are
accessing the internet from that region
this enables you to access Geo blocked
content and take advantage of exclusive
offers or services and now the next
feature is changing your IP address so
using a VPN also allows you to change
your IP IP address which enhances your
online privacy and security your ISP can
track your online activities and collect
data on your browsing habits however
when you use a VPN your real IP address
is hidden making it difficult for anyone
including your internet service provider
to monitor your internet usage online
anonymity is a valuable benefit of using
a VPN by masking your IP address and
encrypting your data a VPN helps protect
your identity online websites and online
services won't be able to track
activities or collect personal
information about you without your
consent while vpns offer numerous
advantages it's important to be aware of
some potential disadvantages so vpns
slow down your internet connection and
it could be sometimes that they slow
down your internet connections that is
due to the encryption and rerouting of
data the distance between your device
and the VPN server as well as the server
capacity can impact your connection
speed another consideration is that vpns
may keep logs of your activities despite
claims of a no logs policy some VPN
providers May store certain data it's
essential to research and choose a
reputable VPN service that prioritizes
user privacy and has transparent
policies regarding data retention next
block VPN users that is limitation on
data usage or speed lastly while there
are free VPN services available they
often have limitations on data usage or
speed for regular and reliable VPN usage
opting for a paid subscription is
recommended premium VPN Services
typically offer better speeds more
server locations and stronger security
features in conclusion a VPN is a
valuable tool for protecting your online
security privacy and anonymity it
encrypts your data masks your IP address
and allows you to bypass restrictions
and access blow content while there are
a few drawbacks to consider the
advantages of using a VPN far out with
the potential downsides so whether you
are browsing the internet using public
Wi-Fi or accessing Geo blocked content a
VPN is an effective solution to
safeguard your online identity and keep
your data secure with that we have
reached the end of this tutorial let's
take a minute to hear from our Learners
who have experienced massive success in
their careers with the next generation
of Internet exchanges focused on maximum
privacy and security a variety of ways
have been enforced to maintain them as
such censorship has been shifted from
the streets to the digital domain it
forces the standard citizen to derive
alternative ways to maintain anonymity
major weapon in this battle for privacy
and security is the T browser an
independent browser meant to browse the
internet while reing information through
the T Network it serves as a meaningful
alternative to the standard internet
browsing habits to better understand the
purpose of this browser and such we must
learn about the work of the T Network
featuring its own routing protocol the
top browser is an easy way to maintain
anonymity while browsing without
emptying one's wallet let's take a look
at the topics to be covered
today we start at the explanation of
what is the T Network and its
significance in the working of the to
browser we take a look at the onion
routing protocol and how it transmits
the data from the client devices to the
Tor directories in order to circumvent
government
censorship moving on we learn a few
features of the to browser and the
distinct advantages the T Network
provides next we learn the difference
between using a VPN and a t to anonymize
internet usage and finally we have a
live demonstration of the T browser
anonymization features in
action let's move on to learning about
the T
Network T short for the onion router
it's an open-source privacy Network that
permits users to browse the web
anonymously the T was initially
developed and solely used by the US Navy
to protect sensitive government
Communications before the network was
made publicly available the digital era
has disrupted the traditional way of
doing things in every sector of the
economy the rapid rise in development
and innovation of digital products has
given way to frequent data breaches and
cyber thefts in response consumers are
increasingly opting for products that
offer data privacy and cyber security T
is one such underground Network that was
implemented for the purpose of
protecting users identity
the to network is one example of the
many emerging technologies that attempt
to fill a data privacy void in a digital
space plagued by cyber security
concerns the to network intercepts the
traffic from your browser and bounces a
user's request of a random number of
other user IP addresses then the data is
passed to the user requester Final
Destination these random users are
volunteer devices which are called as
nodes or relays the Tor Network
disguises your identity by encrypting
the traffic and moving it across
different to relays within the network
the T Network uses an onion routing
technique for transmitting data hence
the original name of onion router to
operate within the T Network a user has
to install the T browser any address or
information requested using the browser
is transmitted through the T Network it
has its own feature set which we will be
covering over later in this
video as we discussed already the data
passing to the to network must follow a
unique protocol known as The Onion
routing protocol let us learn more about
its unique
characteristics in our normal Network
usage the data is transmitted directly
the sender has data packets to transmit
which is done directly over a line of
communication with either a receiving
party or a server of some kind however
since the data can easily be captured
while being transmitted the security of
this exchange is not very reliable
moreover it becomes very easy to trace
the origin of such requests on many
occasions websites with questionable and
controversial content are blocked from
the ISP this is possible since the ISP
is able to detect and spy on user
information passing through the network
apart from isps there is a steady chance
of your private information being
intercepted by hackers unfortunately
easy detection of the source and
contents of a web request make entire
network extremely vulnerable for people
who seek anonymity over the internet
however in the onion routing protocol
things take a longer route we have a
sender with the to browser installed on
the client system the network sends the
information to node one's IP address
which encrypts the information and
passes it on to node 2's address which
performs another encryption and passes
it on to node 3 address this is the last
address which is also known as the exit
node this last node decrypts the
encrypted data and finally relays the
request to the Final Destination which
can be another device or a server end
this final address thinks the request
came from the exit node and grants
access to it the encryption process
across multiple computers repeats itself
from the exit node to the original user
the to network obfuscates user IP
addresses from unwanted surveilance by
keeping the users's request untraceable
with multiple servers touching the data
it makes the tracking very difficult for
both isps and malicious
attackers now that we understand the way
T Works let us learn more about the T
browser the to browser was developed by
a nonprofit organization as a part of
the T project in 2008 and its first
public release was announced the to
browser is a browser Fork from the
popular Firefox that anonymizes your web
traffic using the to network if you're
investigating a competitor researching
an opposing litigant in a legal dispute
or just think it's creepy for your ISP
or the government to know what websites
you visit the to browser might be the
right solution
before the to browser were developed
using that Network to maintain anonymity
was a huge task for everyday consumers
starting from the setup to the usage the
entire process demanded a lot of
knowledge and practice the to browser
managed to make it easy for users to
Traverse the relay servers inour and
guarantee the privacy of the data
exchange a major feature of the tour
browser is the ability to delete all
browser history cookies and tracking
data the moment it is Cle closed every
new launch of the browser opens an empty
slate having a usage habits from being
tracked and singled out a major feature
that is the highlight of the to network
is the availability of onion links only
a small portion of the worldwide web is
available to the general public we have
the Deep Web that contains links that
are not allowed to be indexed by
standard search engines like Google and
Bing the dark web is a further subset of
the Deep Web which contains onion links
to browser gives you access to these do
onion websites which are only available
within the to network onion is a special
use top level domain which designates an
anonymous onion service which is also
known as a hidden service similar to The
Links of the Deep Web these onion links
provide services like online shopping
cryptocurrency and many other products
not available in the consumer Internet
space often being considered as a Haven
for illegal activities and sales onion
links provide both information and
assets in a private manner without the
risk of spying
authorities browsing the web over tour
is slower than the clear net due to the
multiple layers of
encryption some web services also block
to users to browser is also illegal in
authoritarian regimes that want to
prevent citizens from Reading publishing
and communicating anonymously
journalists and dissidents around the
world have embraced t as a Cornerstone
of democracy and researchers are hard at
work at improving TS anonymity
properties let us take take a look at
some of the advantages of using the T
browser over standard web
browsers the highlight of using the T
browser is to maintain anonymity over
the Internet the cause for such requests
can differ from person to person but all
of these concern are answered by the to
network outing the information via
multiple nodes and relay servers make it
entirely difficult for the ISP to keep a
track of usage
data the entire to project is designed
to be completely free and open source
allowing the code for the browser to be
inspected and audited by Third parties
helps in the early detection of faulty
configurations and critical bugs it is
present for multiple operating system
starting from laptops to mobile
devices a number of websites are blocked
by governments for a variety of reasons
journalists under authoritarian regimes
have difficulty in getting the word out
regarding the situation since the onion
routing protocol transfers data between
multiple servers of random countries the
domains being blocked blog become
available when used via T usage of these
encryption messaging platforms is easily
enforced using the T browser which
otherwise would have been a difficult
task under oppressive
circumstances many people believe that a
VPN offers the same benefits as the top
browser let's put both of them to the
test and see the differences between
them coming to the first point of
difference to is completely free and
open source all of the code for the
browser and the network can be audited
and has been cleared for security
concerns when it comes to VPN there are
many different brands which have open
source clients but the same cannot be
said for their counterparts some have
partly open source while some have
completely locked up their code so that
they cannot be stolen
further moving on Tor has multiple relay
points in his data transfer protocol
between the server and the receiver
there are three different IP nodes that
number can increase but it'll always
always be more than two once the data is
passed from the cender it goes through
all of those relay points while in the
case of a VPN the connection is made
from the client device to the VPN server
and then to the requested destination
there is no other IP node that comes
into work here thereby making the
connection a one to one between the
client and a
VPN as a next Point since store handles
multiple layers of encryption and the
data passes through multiple systems
along the way the performance is slow
compared to a VP n where the performance
is relatively fast due to the less
number of nodes the data passes
through similarly the multi layer
encryption of T is consistent if you use
T browser every single request passes
through the same layer of encryption and
follows the same routing protocol in the
case of a VPN different companies offer
different levels of encryption some have
multihop some prefer a single onetoone
connection and these kind of differences
make the choice much more variable
finally the nodes and relays being used
in the Tor Network are volunteer there
is no company holding over them so
jurisdiction becomes relatively
straightforward for inance in the case
of vpns many such vpns are hosted by
adware companies or are being monitored
by Central governments to note the usage
information now that we have a better
understanding of the T browser and its
routing let us take a look at how the T
browser can anonymize and protect our
internet user
M on opening up the tour browser for the
first time this is the page that you're
going to be welcomed with you have the
option of connecting to the to network
before we start our
browsing so let's press
connect and we can see that it is
connected coming to the
anonymization let's check my current
location on Google
Chrome currently is showing as Navi
Mumbai in
Maharashtra if you check this same link
on the tour browser we should get a
different
address now every link that we open in
the T browser will be little delayed and
the speed will be hampered because of
the multiple layers of encryption like
we discussed now as you can
see it's showing a German IP and the
state of
Bavaria this is how the anonymization
works there is no VPN configured there
is no proxy attached it's straight up
the out of the box settings that come in
built with the tour browser similarly we
have an option of cleaning up the data
let's say if you want to refresh your
location and you want to use a different
ID for the next browsing session if you
just restart it once and we can have to
check it
again we should be seeing a different
country this
time as you can see we have Netherlands
right now so this is how you can keep
refreshing your address you can keep
refreshing your host location so that
you cannot be tracked when in browsing
the internet like we discussed we have
some onion links that can only be used
on the T
Network as you can see these kind of
links do not open in the Google Chrome
browser but once we copy these over to
the T
browser as you can see we have opened
the hidden wiki which is available only
on the toret Network this is kind of an
alternative Wikipedia website where we
can find articles to read and more
information to learn similarly we have
another onion link over
here which is once again available only
for the toall
browser now these kind of delays are
expected but they are a valid compromise
because they maintain the anonymity that
many people desire similarly we have
found a hidden wallet which is a
cryptocurrency wallet which is
specifically for dark web
members this operates over the Tor
Network and this is used by mostly
journalists and people who want to
anonymize their internet transactions
when it comes to dealing
money all of the transactions that occur
over the T Network are almost impossible
to track therefore these kind of
cryptocurrency wallets are very big on
the Deep Web this is just one example
while having multiple different wallets
for every single cryptocurrency
available in this video we will cover
topics like what is rware attack how
does a ransomware attack work types of
ransomware attacks effects of ransomware
on the business how to prevent from the
ransomware attack and the last one is
popular ransomware attacks and let me
tell you guys that we have regular
updates on multiple Technologies if you
are a tech geek on a continuous ear for
the latest technological Trends then
consider getting subscribe to our
YouTube channel and press that Bell icon
to never miss any update from Simply
learn as we know the demand for cyber
security Personnel is SK skyrocketing so
if you want to master the field of cyber
security then simply learn postgraduate
program in cyber security in
collaboration with MIT is clearly the
right choice for you so this
postgraduate program in cyber security
is designed to equip you the skills
required to become an expert in the
rapidly growing field of the cyber
security this cyber security program
aims to help you to stay ahead of all
the latest cyber security Trends so key
features of this program is simply and
postgraduate program certificate master
classes from MIT faculty featuring
modules from MIT SSC and EC Council
access to C kit 25 plus Hands-On project
and many more this cyber security
certification program began with
introductory level skills and then
progress to the Advan cyber security
techn this programs cover all the
essential skills you will need to become
an expert in the field of cyber security
cyber security is one of the top concern
of the business today in an industry
from securing data to anticipating cyber
attacks and placing Enterprise wide
safeguards to prevent them employers
worldwide are increasingly looking for
qualified cyber security professional to
join them so what are you waiting for
find the course link mentioned in the
description box below and enroll today
so let's get started in 2015 the Tesla
Crypt ransomware rapidly spread causing
significant disruption to numerous
Gamers following extending gaming sens
Gamers were alarmed to find an
unfamiliar text file label Ransom note
on their desktop the content of this
text file is informed that the hacking
group had taken control of their game
files and private document encrypting
them in an unreadable format to regain
access to their valuable data each gamer
was required to pay a ransom of $500
worth of bitcoin to a specific Bitcoin
address upon payment they would receive
the master key necessary to dictate
scrypt their files this was the Tesla
Crypt ransomware move on to the
understanding what exactly a ransomware
attack is all about so what is a
ransomware attack a ransomware attack
refers to a type of malware designed to
encrypt personal information and
document prompting the victim to pay a
ransom in order to decrypt them this
payment is typically made using
cryptocurrency to maintain anority
although other payment methods may also
be utilized even after the money has
been sent there is no guarantee that the
hacker will send the encryption key or
unlock the files but in certain
sensitive situation victim makes the
payment hoping for the best so the
attackers bringing out the attacks
mainly the targeted renowned names of
any organization which leads to a lot of
damage and theft to a valuable
information so now let's understand how
such an attacks works so how does a
ransomware attack work the first one the
spread of ransomware mly start with
fishing attacks a ransomware attack
gains access to a victim device through
through infected emails messages and
malicious sites and encrypt the data in
that device the ransomware uses simple
asymmetric encryption algorithms blocks
a user files and make them difficult to
decrypt without knowing the key and the
third one is it also Maps the location
for targeted files type that include
file stored locally and mapped and
unmapped network accessible devices and
the fourth one is it can also spread via
malware transmitted via untrusted
application installation or even a
compromised wireless network and the
fifth one is rans adds instruction files
describing the pay for description
process then uses those files to present
a ransom node to the user now let's
understand types of rer attacks so there
are numerous types of ransomware
available but they mainly fall into
three categories the first one is Locker
ransomware it is a type of malware that
blocks standard computer functions from
being accessed until the payment to the
hacker is not complete it shows a lot
lock screen that doesn't allow the
victim to use the computer for primary
purposes and the second one is crypto
ransomware this ransomware encrypts the
local files and documents to computers
once the file are encrypted finding the
decryption key is impossible unless the
ransomware varient is old and the keys
are already available online and the
third one is scareware it is a fake
software that claims to have detected a
virus or other issue on your computer
and direct you to pay to resolve the
problem some scar
logs the computer while other flood the
screen with popup alerts without
damaging the files so after seeing types
of ransomware let's move forward and see
some effects of ransomware on the
businesses so the impact on ransomware
attacks on a business can severely
destructive as per the report lens ofare
has inflicted staggering cost of over 8
billion on business in the past year so
let's see what are the reasons first one
is data loss businesses may suffer
significant data losses resting in
criticals information being inaccessible
or permanently destroyed the second one
is downtime and infrastructure
compromise ransomware compromise the
business infrastructure leading to
disruptive downtime periods and the
third one is costly recovery efforts the
recovery process after ransomware attack
can be expensive the expensive might
surpass the actual Ransom amount and the
fourth one is customer loss The Fallout
from a ransomware attack may lead to
losing customers who may seek Services
elsewhere so these effects highlight the
severity of ransomware attacks and
underscore the importance of robust
cyber security measure to safeguard
businesses against such threat so now
let's move forward and see how to
prevent the ransomware attacks so how
can one prevent ransomware attacks
Security Experts recommend the following
measures to protect against ransomware
threats so the first one is regularly
backup on Computing devices to ensure
data can be restored in case of any
attack and the second one is conduct an
inventory like of all assets to have a
comprehensive understanding of the
organization digital lands and the third
one is keep software including antivirus
programs up to- date address known
vulnerabilities and the fourth one is
educate educate and users to avoid
clicking on links in emails or opening
emails attachment from unknown sources
so by implementing these methods
individuals and organization can enhance
their defense against and someware and
mitigate potential risk effectively so
so now let's move forward and see some
popular enware attacks in history so
here are five most popular enware
attacks that occurred in recent year and
grabbed the entire world's attention the
first one is vry vry ransomware first
emerged in 2017 and infected thousands
of computer in over 150 countries the
second one is paa p rware is an
encrypting malware that first surfaced
in 2016 it encrypts critical files and
hold them hostage unless you pay and the
third one one is server server appeared
in 2016 that SP through fishing emails
and encrypted users files and data with
Advanced encryption methods and the
fourth one is bad rabit bad rabit
ransomware is reported to be an improved
variant of the Peta ransomware it locks
of the victims computer servers and the
other files preventing them from
regarding access until a ransom in the
form of Bitcoin is paid and the last one
is Loi released in 2016 Loi is a file
type of ransomware sent using emails
demand payment through an invoice in the
form of tented Microsoft Word document
containing infectious micros if you are
someone who is interested in building a
career in cyber security by graduating
from the best universities or a
professional who Elites to switch
careers with cyber security by learning
from the experts then try giving a short
to Simply Larch postgraduate program in
cyber security with modules from MIT
schwarzman College of Engineering the
course link is mentioned in the
description box that will navigate you
to the course page where you can find a
complete overview of the program being
offered malware is a malicious software
that is programmed to cause damage to a
computer system Network and Hardware
devices many malicious programs like
prion viruses bombs and Bots which cause
damage to the system are known as
malware most of the malware programs are
designed to steal information from the
targeted user or to steal money from the
Target by stealing sensitive
data let's take a look at the
introduction for two different types of
malware virus and
firstly let's take a look what exactly
is a virus
program a computer virus is a type of
malicious program that on execution
replicates itself they get attached to
different files and programs which are
termed as host programs by inserting
their code if the attachment succeeds
the targeted program is termed as
infected with a computer virus now let's
take a look at the Trojan Horse Trojan
hor Pro program is a program that
disguises itself as a legitimate program
but harms the system on installation
they hide within the attachments and
emails then transfer from one system to
another they create back doors into a
system to allow the cyper criminal to
steal our
information let's take a look how they
function after getting installed into
our
system firstly we have virus programs
the computer virus must contain two
parts to infect the system first is a
search routine which locates new files
and data that is to be infected by the
virus program and the second part is
known as the copy routine which is
necessary for the program to copy itself
into the targeted file which is located
by the search routine now let's take a
look at the troan horse
functioning for Trojan horses entryway
into our system is through emails that
may look legitimate but may have unknown
attachments and when such files are
downloaded into the device the troen
program gets installed and infects the
system they also infect the system on
the execution of infected application or
the executable file and attacks the
system now that we understand what virus
and rions are let's understand different
types of virus and
rions let's take a look at different
types of viruses the first one is known
as the boot sector virus this type of
virus virus damages the booting section
of the system by infecting the masterb
record which is also known as MBR this
damages the boot sector section by
targeting the hard disk of the
system then we have the macro virus
macro virus is a type of virus that gets
embedded into the document related data
and is executed when the file is open
they also are designed to replicate
themselves and infect the system on a
larger scale and lastly we have the
direct action
virus this type of virus gets attached
to executable files which on execution
activates the virus program and infects
the system once the infection of the
file is completed they exit the system
which is also the reason it is known as
a non-resident virus let's take a look
at different types of
prions the first type of troan is the
back door troan they are designed to
create a back door in the system on
execution of an infected program they
provide remote access of a system to the
hacker this way the Cyber criminal can
steal our system data and may use it for
illegal activities next we have cricos
droan they enter the system by clicking
the random popups which we come across
on the internet they attemp the user to
give their personal details for
different transactions or
schemes which may provide remote access
of a system to the Cyber
criminal and the last Trojan type is
Ransom troan this type of troan program
after entering the system blocks the
user from accessing its own system and
also affects the system
functioning the Cyber criminal Demands a
ransom from the targeted user for the
removal of the trojen program from the
device now that we understand some
details regarding viruses and prion
let's solve a question
the question is Jake was denied access
to his system and he wasn't able to
control the data and information in his
system now the actual question is what
could be the reason behind this system's
problem option a macrovirus option b
Ransom troan option C back door rosion
give your answers in the comment
section now let's understand how to
detect the activity of viruses and troan
in our
system to detect virus or prion activity
in our system we can refer to the
following points for viruses we have
slowing down of the system and frequent
application freeze shows that the
infection of the virus is present in the
system then we have the viruses can also
steal sensitive data including passwords
Account Details which may lead to
unexpected log out from the accounts or
Corruption of the sensitive data and
lastly we have fre system crashes due to
virus infection which damages the
operating system for troan we have
frequent system crashes and system also
faces slow reaction time then we have
there are more random popups from the
system which may indicate rosion
activity and lastly we have modification
in the system application and change of
the desktop appearance can be also due
to the infection of a troan
program next let's take a look at a
famous cyber attack for virus and a
trojen
hor for virus we have the myom virus
which was identified in the year 2004
which affected over 50 million systems
by creating a network of sending spam
emails which was to gain back door
access into our
systems next for the troan horse we have
the emotet rosan program which is
specifically designed for financial
theft and for stealing Bank related
information next we have few points for
how to prevent virus entry or troan
attack for a
system the most basic way of virus
protection is to using antivirus and do
regular viruses can this will prevent
virus entry in the system and also
having more than one antivirus provides
much better
protection then avoid visiting
uncertified websites can also prevent
virus entry into us
system then we have using regular driver
updates and system updates to prevent
virus entry for troan we have using
certified softwares from legal sites to
prevent any troan activity in our
system and also avoid clicking random
popups that we often see on the internet
and lastly using antivirus and Fireballs
for protection against troan horses is a
good habit
now that we have reached the end of the
video Let's Take a look what we learned
for the first part we saw the main
objective of the virus is to harm the
data and information in a system whereas
for the troan we have stealing of the
data files and information effect of
viruses is more drastic in comparison to
the Trojan
horses then we have viruses which are
non- remote programs whereas troen
horses are remote accessed and lastly
viruses have the ability to replicate
itself to harm multiple files where
asosan does not have the replication
ability so let's begin with what is SQL
injection as the name suggest SQL
injection vulnerability allows an
attacker to inject malicious input into
a SQL statement so SQL stands for
structured query language which is a
language used by an application to
interact with a database now normally
this attack is targeted towards a
database to extract uh the data that is
stored within however the vulnerability
does not line the database itself the
vulnerability will always lie in the
application it is the developers
prerogative of how to develop the
application how to configure it to
prevent SQL injection queries from
happening a database is created to
answer questions and if a question is
asked it is supposed to answer it
database needs to be configured for some
amount of security but the vulnerability
the flaw here for SQL injection will
always lie in the application itself it
is how the application interacts with
the database that needs to be modified
that needs to be maintained by the
developer rather than just configuring
the database itself so the attacker at
this point in time when they send a
query to the application will form a
malformed query by injecting a
particular command or an operator that
is recognized by the SQL language and if
that operator is passed through the
application to the database then the
database uh basically gets cracked or
does a data dump because of that
unwanted character coming in so this
character needs to be filtered at the
application Level itself now let's look
at a quick demo so what we have done
here is I have this virtual machine
called oasp broken web applications
virtual machine version 1.2 I'm going to
power this
on
till this poers on I'm going to show you
where we can download this uh utility
from so you can just look for oasp
broken web application project download
you'll find it on sourceforge.net click
on the
link you can download the broken web
application project from here this is a
1.9gb download and you can have a zip
machine directly for VMware or Oracle
virtual
box now this is an application that has
been developed by oasp which stands for
open web application security project
which is a not for-profit organization
and uh periodically uh releases the most
top 10 risks that an application uh will
face for that particular
year so they have given a web
application uh with inbuilt
vulnerabilities for professionals like
us to practice upon to develop our our
skills upon because doing this in the
real world is illegal I cannot go onto a
website to demonstrate how a SQL
injection attack Works uh neither should
you try your hands on it till you become
very well rehearsed with it so till to
upgrade your skills to upskill yourself
please download this machine hosted in a
VM workstation or Oracle virtual box and
you can uh then try your skills on it
right so uh just going back to the
browser here if I open up uh a new tab
you'll see that this machine has booted
up and has an IP address called 71. 132
so if I just go on to that IP address
and I type in 192 168 71.
132 and you'll see the OAS broken web
application project and there are lot of
training applications realistic
intentionally vulnerable applications
old versions of real applications and so
on so forth so there is a lot of
applications in built over here that you
can try your skills upon we are going to
try to use the ovas mutil day over here
uh this gives you the uh o top 10 risks
for 2010 2013 2017 is the latest one so
far uh but the difference between 2013
and 2017 is that some of these have
changed but not all of them uh the order
has changed a little bit but you can see
that SQL injection is on the top A1
amongst the injection attacks right and
you can see there are multiple types
that have been given here the SQL
injection for extracting data or SQL
injection for bypass authentication or
insert your injection uh attacks blind
SQL injection and then there is a tool
called SQL map which is available freely
on your Linux machines Ki Linux or parot
Linux whichever you want to use uh for
your practice targets and so on so forth
so if I just take you here for bypass
authentication and this is a regular
lock Lo in page that an application may
have right you look at a username you
look at password you type that in and
you log in so let's say I don't know a
password here I'm just going to type in
the username test password is PSS swrd I
try to log in and it shows me that the
account does not exist so the
authentication mechanism does work I did
try type in a username and password it
wasn't recognize so the account does not
exist now let's try to type in a SQL
query here I'm going to just give it a
single quote which is an operator that
is recognized by the SQL language which
when the database tries to execute uh
will cause the database to uh dump some
data or to bypass authentication in this
case and I'm going to give it a
condition single
quote r 1 equal 1 space hyphen hyphen
space and I'm going to click on login
now right now I'm not logged in at all
and we tried our username and password
and we weren't able to log in so now if
I log in you will see that it give me a
status update saying the user has been
authenticated and I'm logged in as admin
got root so that is what these SQL
queries can achieve I'm going to log out
right now and uh we're going to look at
the basics of SQL injection so looking
at that small demo looking now let's
look at what types of SQL injections are
available so the first is inband SQL
injection the there are two subtypes
within inband error based injection
attack and a union based injection
attack the second type is blind SQL
injection attack where there's a Boolean
based and a Time based attack and the
third one is outof bound SQL injection
attack now what is inband SQL injection
attack inband is where we either
attempting the error based or the union
based what is error based uh we send a
query to the database we craft a query
to the database and and uh it generates
an error me message and it dumps the
error message right in front of us on
the screen that makes us realize that
there is a flaw and there there is some
information that is dumped on the screen
which we can then further utilize to
craft our further queries as we go ahead
whereas Union base is the it is where we
combine multiple statements at the same
time so if you look at the URL earlier
in the URL you would see a large
structure in that URL uh we can try to
add more two or more statements within
the URL itself to combine them and then
confuse the database into executing both
the statements together and giving a
data dump at the same time right so what
would a error based uh SQL injection
look like if I go back to the same
database uh which is here right and if
you remember in the username we gave it
a single quote or one equals one space
hyphen hyphen space we gave it the
condition right so basically what it did
was this a single code is an operator
that goes to the database selects the
default uh table uh in the user tables
in this database column and then
Compares it to the condition that is
given so the condition that we gave was
1 equals 1 which is always true so what
it did was it selected the default uh
user table that was available in the
data
and instead of comparing it to a
password it compared it to the condition
so if I give it 1 equals 2 where the
condition is false and if I log in you
will see that the account doesn't exist
comes back again because the condition
was false and instead of comparing the
user account to the password it
basically uh compared the user account
to the condition so if I give it a
single quote or one equals 1 hyphen
hyphen space uh and log in you can see
that this is this is a correct condition
and thus we are able to log in now
before we even go to that extent if I
just forget the condition over here and
it just give it a single code the
operator and I send this operator to the
database and I click on login you will
see that it generates an error which is
right on top and it tells us the line
the uh file where the error happened and
you can see it happened in the MySQL
handler. PHP file right and then it give
us the message you have an error in your
SQL syntax check the manual that
corresponds to your MySQL server version
for the right syntax to use now why
would a hacker want to do this in the
first place because there are different
types of databases so there is a MySQL
Ms SQL or Microsoft SQL Oracle SQL IBM
db2 all of these are variations of the
SQL database uh they use the SQL
language however every database has its
own Command right they they have their
own syntax they have their own uh spe
specific commands that are utilized for
the database so in this scenario the
hacker wants to identify what database
is being currently utiliz so they can
craft those particular queries so now
with this injection with just me sending
the quote and the error getting
generated I now come to know that we are
using a MySQL server and the version of
that server is
5173 and uh the rest of the information
about uh where the handlers are located
and so on so forth right this gives the
information to the hacker of how they
want to proceed next what kind of
queries they want to create what kind of
syntax they want to utilize so error
based attack is where you generate these
kind of Errors uh and you get this
information the union base is where you
craft your queries within the URL or you
can try to combine multiple statements
within the input fields and try to
generate a response from that then we
come to Ian based SQL injection uh sends
a SQL query to the database which forces
the application to return a different
result depending on whether the query
return returns a true or a false result
so basically if the input is false the
input both the inputs are false the
output would be false uh there's one
input that is false the other input that
is true input B the output would be true
and so on so forth right so depending on
the result from the inputs the attack
will come to know which input is true
with this he can then access the
database of the website so you're trying
to figure out by sending out multiple
inputs uh and then analyzing the output
to see what exactly uh which command
exactly worked what was the resultant
output of that command thus from this
kind of an information the hacker can
infer their next step forward then you
have time based SQL injections uh now
there are times when a database
administrator an application
administrator has done some security
configuration and does have disabled
verbos error messages now what is a
verbos error message the error message
that we saw right here is a verbos error
message that means that the message
gives out details the message gives out
details about what the database is the
version and whatnot so if they have
sanitized these
errors and you no longer can generate
these errors and thus you cannot figure
out what database is then what do you do
right for example if I just take you to
Simply
learn
and take you to a URL that is supposedly
not accessible you can see that it gives
a generic error oops like it looks like
you have crash landed on Mars it doesn't
give you a verbos error that we saw here
so this gives us a detail error of what
went wrong where it gives us the
database the version of the database and
uh where the query went wrong and etc
etc etc whereas on this side where
there's some there's a lot of security
that goes in here so you can see that it
doesn't generate a error it just get a
generic page in front of you so in that
case what does a hacker do so the hacker
then injects a Time
based uh query in the URL which allows
us to verify whether the command is
being executed or not so uh we put in a
time
weit let's say 10 seconds of time weit
so if we the moment we inject the query
if the query times for 10 seconds and
then gets executed that means that the
SQL injection is possible however if we
inject the query and uh it just gets
executed without the delay that means
that the time uh injection attack would
not be uh possible on that particular
site out of bound is not a very common
attack it depends on the features being
enabled on the database management
system that is being used by the web
application so this can be a somewhat of
a misconfiguration error uh by the
database administrator where you have
enabled functions and not sanitized them
so you have not done in Access controls
properly you have not given account
control so queries should never be
executed at an administrative level they
should always be uh executed at a user
level with minimum privileges that are
required for that query to be executed
now if you're allowing these kind of
functions to be uh to be enabled at the
dbms and there's an administrative
account that can have access to them at
that point in time an outof bound
injection attack is possible so let's
look at how a website works right uh how
SQL works on a website now the website
is constructed of HTML hypertext markup
language uh which would include
javascripting for functionality casking
stylesheets for the mapping of the
website right and then reactjs and
whatnot uh for further functionality now
when we send a query to the website it
is normally using the HTTP protocol or
https protocol when the query reaches
the application the application would
then go go ahead and generate the SQL
query uh at the client side you'll have
uh all these scripting languages coming
in uh on the front end uh that we can
utilize to craft queries and then send
them across at the server side you'll
have uh databases like Oracle MySQL Ms
SQL and so on so forth that will then
execute those queries right so just to
give you an example if I use a tool
called
Postman what we generally do uh when we
craft a query is we send out a uh get
request to the website and then we
receive a response from the site uh with
the HTML code and everything so this is
a tool that is utilized by software
testers to test the responses that
you're going to get from various
websites so on the left hand side you
can see I've uh used it on quite a bit
uh here we have a example for gmail.com
so let's continue with that so this is a
get request being sent to to Gmail the
moment I send it it's going to create an
HTTP request and send it across the
response that I get is this this is the
HTML code for
gmail.com right these are the cookies uh
these are the headers uh that include
information so you can see this is a
text HTML character set utilized is
utf8 and the configuration uh that has
been done with the application right so
this is where uh everything comes in
this is the cookie that has been sent
with that particular uh request that I
had sent out now if you Analyze This
query right so when we went onto this
application and I typed in that single
quote and we generated this error right
uh you can see that the application
converted this into a SQL query so the
query was select username from accounts
where the username in quote single
quotes and we use the quote right the
single quote right there so uh that's
where we use that operator and that's
where the exception error occurred so
these are the kind of queries that are
structured by the application and then
taken on to the database for execution
when we type in uh it is a HTTP get
request with the username and password
within that query uh that is sent to the
application the application converts it
into a SQL query sends it to the
database and the database responds with
the appropriate response so how do we
prevent SQL injection in the first place
use prepared statement and parameterized
queries
uh these statements make sure that the
parameters passed into SQL statements
are treated in a safe manner so for
example we saw that the single code was
an operator this shouldn't be allowed to
be utilized in the first place right so
here what we are doing here is a secure
way of running a SQL query in the jdbc
using a parameterized statement Define
which user we want to find so there's a
string the email comes in connection to
the database we are going to figure out
how the connection is going to be passed
how it is going to be created construct
the SQL statement we want to run
specifying the parameter right so we
Define how is it going to be uh created
what is going to be created what can be
passed to the database and what should
not be passed to the database so that is
one way of utilizing prepared statements
and parameterized queries then we have
object relational mapping most
development uh teams prefer to use OB
object relational mapping Frameworks to
make the translation of SQL results set
into code object more seamless so this
is an example of object relational
mapping where we map certain objects and
allow that to be executed and then
escaping inputs it a simple way to
protect against most SQL injection
attacks many languages have standard
functions to achieve this right so you
need to be very careful while using
Escape characters in your code base when
a SQL statement is constructed not all
injection attacks rely on abuse of quote
characters so you need to know what
characters are being utilized uh in the
configuration that you have created in
the structure that you have created in
the code that you have created uh which
characters are being recognized as
operators you need to sanitize those
operators and you need to uh basically
ensure that these operators cannot be
accepted as user input if they are they
feed out by the application and they
never reach the database other methods
of uh preventing SQL injection are uh
password hashing so that passwords
cannot be bypassed the passwords cannot
be recovered passwords cannot be cracked
uh third party authentication you use o
or some other service for a single sign
on mechanism does uh you rely on a third
party to maintain the security of
authentication and uh what kind of
parameters are passed for example uh
using LinkedIn logins or Facebook logins
right uh for the Layman you normally go
on to Facebook and you allow if you're
using a game right if you start playing
a game you're allowed to log into the
game using your Facebook credentials or
your Google credentials now that is not
just for ease of use but the game user
the developer has outsourced the
authentication mechanisms to third party
such as Facebook or Google because they
understand that that authentication
mechanism is as safe as can be Facebook
and Google are wealthy organizations uh
High are a lot of Security Experts and
the development for their authentication
mechanisms is topnotch small
organization cannot spend that kind of
money on security itself right so you
use a third party authentication
mechanism to ensure that these kind of
attacks may not happen then web
application firewalls uh having a web
application firewall and configuring it
properly uh for SQL injection attacks is
one of the shhot method of uh mitigating
or minimizing the uh threat in the first
place so at this point in time you have
realized that the application has some V
abilities for SQL injection and instead
of recording or restructuring the
application uh you want to take the
easier way out or the cheaper way out so
what you do is you uh you install a web
application firewall and you configure
the web application firewall to identify
malicious queries and stop them uh at
the firewall level itself so they never
reach the application and thus the
vulnerabilities on the application don't
get executed
buy better software and keep on updating
the software so it's not necessary that
once you have a software install it it's
going to be safe for Life new
vulnerabilities are discovered every day
every hour and it may so happen what is
secure today maybe completely insecure
tomorrow or the day after right so you
need to keep on upgrading the software
if there are no upgrades available and
the vity still exist you might want to
migrate to a better software and does uh
ensure that you don't get hacked right
always update and use patches
organizations keep on sending out
updates and patches as and when they are
released you need to install them to uh
enhance your security postures and then
continuously monitor SQL statements and
databases use protocol monitors uh use
different softwares use the firewalls to
keep on monitoring what kind of queries
you uh getting and based on those
queries you want to ensure the inputs
and the queries that are created
are not detrimental to the health of the
software that you have Jane is relaxing
at home when she receives an email from
a bank that asks her to update her
credit card pin in the next 24 hours as
a security measure judging the severity
of the message Jane follows the link
provided in the email on delivering her
current credit card pin and the
supposedly updated one the website
became unresponsive which prompted her
to try sometime later however after a
couple of hours she noticed a
significant purchase from a random
website on that same credit card which
she never authorized frantically
contacting the bank Jane realized the
original email was a counterfeit or a
fake message with a malicious link that
inail credit card fro this is a classic
example of a fishing attack fishing
attacks are a type of social engineering
where a fraudulent message is sent to a
Target on the premise of arriving from a
trusted Source its basic purpose is to
trick the victim into revealing
sensitive information like passwords and
payment information it's based on the
word fishing which works on the concept
of baits if a supposed victim catches
the bait the attack can go ahead which
in our case makes Jane the fish and the
fishing emails the bait if Jane never
opened the malicious link or was
cautious about the email authenticity an
attack of this nature would have been
relatively
ineffective but how does the hacker gain
access to these credentials a fishing
attack starts with a fraudulent message
which can be transmitted via email or
chat applications even using SMS
conversations to impersonate legitimate
sources is known as smishing which is a
specific category of fishing attacks
irrespective of the manner of
transmission the message targets the
victim in a way that coaxes them to open
a malicious link and provide critical
information on the requisite website
more often than not the websites are
designed to look as authentic as
possible once the victims submit
information using the link be it a
password or credit card details the data
is sent to the hacker who designed the
email and the fake website giving him
complete control over the account whose
password was just provided often carried
out in campaigns where an identical
fishing mail is sent to thousands of
users the rate of success is relatively
low but never zero between 2013 and 2015
corporate giants like Facebook and
Google were tricked off of $100 million
due to an extensive fishing campaign
where a known common associate was
impersonated by the hackers apart from
credit access some of these campaigns
Target the victim device and install
malware when clicked on the malicious
links which can later function as a botn
net or a target for ransomware attacks
there is no single formula for there are
multiple categories of fishing attacks
the issue with Jane or the hacker Cal or
Bank credentials falls under the
umbrella of deceptive fishing a general
email is sent out to thousands of users
in this category hoping some of them
fall prey to this scam spear fishing on
the other hand is a bit customized
version the targets are researched
before being sent an email for example
if you never had a Netflix subscription
sending you an email that seems like the
Netflix Team sends it becomes pointless
this is a potential drawback of
deceptive fishing techniques on the
other hand a simple screenshot of a
Spotify playlist being shared on social
media indicates a probable point of
entry the hacker can send counterfeit
messages to the Target user while
implying the source of such messages
being Spotify tricking them into sharing
private information since the hacker
already knows the target uses Spotify
the chances of victims taking the bait
increase substantially for more
important targets like CEOs and people
with a fortune on their back the
research done is 10f with which can be
called a case of wailing the hackers
prepare and wait for the right moment to
launch their fishing attack often to
steal industry secrets for rival
companies or sell them off at a higher
price apart from just emails farming
focuses on fake websites that resemble
their original counterparts as much as
possible a prevalent method is to use
domain names like Facebook with a single
o or YouTube with no e these are
mistakes that people make when typing
the full URL in the browser leading them
straight to a counterfeit web page which
can fool them into submitting private
data a few more complex methods exist to
drive people onto fake websites like ARP
spoofing and DNS cach poisoning but they
are rarely carried out due to time and
resource constraints now that we know
how fishing attacks work let's look at
ways to prevent ourselves from becoming
victims while the implications of a
fishing attack can be extreme protecting
yourself against these is relatively
straightforward Jane could have saved
herself from credit card fraud had she
checked the link in the email for
authenticity and that it redirected to a
secure website that runs on the https
protocol even suspicious messages
shouldn't be entertained one must also
refrain from entering private
information on random websites or popup
Windows irrespective of how legitimate
they seem it is also recommended to use
secure anti- fishing browser extensions
like cloudfish to sniff out malicious
emails from legitimate ones the best way
to prent fishing is browsing the
internet with care and being on alert
for malicious attempts at all times
start by learning about cross-site
scripting from a Layman's
perspective cross-site scripting also
known as xss is a type of code injection
attack that occurs on the client side
the attacker intends to run harmful
scripts in the victim's web browser by
embedding malicious code in a genuine
web page or online application the real
Attack takes place when the victim hits
the malicious Cod infected web page or
online application the web page or
application serves as a vehicle for the
malicious script to be sent to the users
browser forums message boards and online
pages that enable comments are
vulnerable vehicles that are frequently
utilized for cross scripting
assaults a web page or web application
is vulnerable to xss if the output it
creates contains unsanitized user input
the victim's browser must then pass this
user input in VB script ActiveX Flash
and even CSS cross-side scripting
attacks are conceivable they are
nevertheless most ubiquitous in
JavaScript going to the fact that
JavaScript is most important to most
browser experiences
nowadays the main purpose of this attack
is to steal the other users identity be
it via cookies session tokens and other
information in most of the cases this
attack is being used to steal the other
person's cookies as we know cookies help
us to log in automatically therefore
with the stolen cookies we can log in
with other identities and this is one of
the reasons why this attack is
considered as one of the riskiest
attacks it can be performed with
different client side programming
languages as
well cross side scripting is often
compared with similar client side
attacks as client side languages are
mostly being used during this however an
xss attack is considered riskier because
of its ability to damage even less
vulnerable technology
most often this attack is performed with
JavaScript and HTML JavaScript is a
programming language that runs on web
pages inside your browser the client
side code adds functionality and
interactivity to the web page and is
used extensively on all major
applications and CMS platforms unlike
serers side languages such as PHP
JavaScript code runs inside your browser
and cannot impact the website for other
visitors it is sandboxed to your own
Navigator and can can only perform
actions within your own browser window
while JavaScript is client site and does
not run on the server it can be used to
interact with the server by performing
background requests attackers can then
use these background requests to add
unwanted spam content to a web page
without refreshing it they can then
gather analytics about the client's
browser or perform actions
asynchronously the manner of attack can
range in a variety of ways it can be a
single link which the user must click on
to initiate a JavaScript piece of code
it can be used to show any piece of
images that can be later used as a front
end for malicious code being installed
as malware with the majority of Internet
users unaware of how metadata works or
the ways in which web requests are
called the chances of victims clicking
on a redirecting links is far too high
cross-side scripting can occur on the
malicious script executed at the client
site using a fake page or even a form
that is displayed to the user on
websites with displayed advertisements
malicious emails can also be sent to the
victim these attacks occur when the
malicious user finds the vulnerable
parts of the website and send it as
appropriate malicious
input now that we understand the basics
of cross-side scripting let us learn
more about how this kind of attack
works in the first place we have the
website or the web browser which is used
to show content to the victim or which
is the user in our case whenever the
user want wants to grab some content
from the website the website asks the
data from the server the server provides
this information to the website and the
web browser which ultimately Rees the
victim how the hacker comes into play
here it passes on certain arguments to
the web browser which is can be then
forwarded back to the server or to the
user at hand the entire cross-site
scripting attack Vector means sending
and injecting malicious code or script
this attack can be performed in
different ways
depending on the type of attack the
malicious script may be reflected on the
victim's browser but stored in the
database and executed every time when
the user calls the appropriate function
the main reason for this attack is
inappropriate users's input validation
where the malicious input can get into
the output a malicious user can enter a
script which will be injected onto the
website's code then the browser is not
able to know if the executed code is
malicious or not therefore this
malicious script is being executed on
the victim's browser or any faked form
if that is being displayed for the users
there are many ways to trigger an xss
attack for example the execution could
be triggered automatically when the page
loads or when a user hovers over
specific elements of the page like
hyperlinks potential consequences of
cross-site scripting attacks include
capturing keystrokes of a user
redirecting a user to malicious websites
running web browser based exploits
obtaining cookie information of of a
user who is logged into a website and
many more in some cases cross-side
scripting attack leads to complete
compromise of the victim's account
attackers can trick users into entering
credentials on a fake form which can
then provide all information to the
attacker with the basic working of a
cross-side scripting attack out of the
way let us go over the different ways
hackers can leverage vulnerable web
applications to gather information and
eventually breach those
systems the prime purpose of Performing
xss attack is to steal the other
person's identity as mentioned it may be
cookies session tokens
Etc xss may also be used to display
faked Pages or forms for the victim
however this can be performed in several
ways we have a reflected attack this
attack occurs when a malicious script is
not being saved on the web server but is
reflected in the website results
reflected xss code is not being saved
permanently in this case the malicious
code is being reflected in any website
result the attack code can be included
in the faked URL or in the HTTP
parameters it can affect the victim in
different ways by displaying faked
malicious page or by sending a malicious
email in a reflected cross-side
scripting example the input of a search
form is reflected on the page to show
what the search key was an attacker May
craft a URL that contains malicious code
and then spread the same URL via email
or social media a user who clicks on
this link opens the valid web
application which then runs the
malicious code in the browser this
script is not stored in the web
application and malicious code is shown
only to one user the user that opens the
link executes the script and the attack
is not necessarily visible on the server
side or to the app owner
itself the next variant is a stored
cross-side scripting attacks this occurs
when a malicious script is being saved
on the web server
permanently this can be considered a
riskier attack since it has leverage for
more damage in this type of attack the
malicious code or script is being saved
on the server for example in the
database of the website it is executed
every time the users call the
appropriate
functionality this way stored xss attack
can affect many users also as the script
is being stored on the web server it
will affect the website for a longer
time in order to perform stored access
attack the malicious scripts should be
sent through the vulnerable input form
for example can be a comment field or a
review
field this way the appropriate script
will be saved in the database and
evaluated on the page load or
appropriate function
calling in a stored xss example the
script might have been submitted via an
input field to the web server which did
not perform a sufficient validation and
stores the script permanently in the
database the consequence of this might
be that the script is now being
delivered to all users visiting the web
application and for example able to gain
access to the user session
cookies in this attack the script is
permanently St in the web app the users
visiting the app after the information
retrieve the script the malicious code
then exploits the flaws in the web
application and the script and the
attack is visible on the server side or
to the app owner as
well the third variant is Dom based
cross-site scripting attacks
this type of attack occurs when the Dom
environment is being changed but the
client side code does not change when
the Dom environment is being modified in
the victim's browser the client side
code executes differently in order to
get a better understanding of how xss
domor attack is being performed Let Us
analyze the following example if there
is a website called texting.com we know
default is a parameter therefore in
order to perform xss Dom attack we
should send a script as
parameters a Dom based accss attack may
be successfully executed even when the
server does not embed any malicious code
into the web page by using a flaw in the
JavaScript executed in the browser for
example if the client side JavaScript
modifies the Dom tree of the web page it
can be based on an input field or the
get parameter without validating the
input this allows the malicious code to
be
executed the malicious code that
exploits flaws in the browser on the
user side and the script and the attack
is not necessarily visible on the server
side or to the app
owner by now it is clear that cross-side
scripting attacks are difficult to
detect and even tougher to fight against
there are however plenty of feels one
can Safeguard against such attacks let's
go through some of these preventive
measures like mentioned earlier exus
attacks as sometimes difficult to detect
however this can be changed if you get
some external help a way to prevent
accesses attacks is using automated
testing tools like crash test security
suit or actic security
suit still manual testing is highly time
consuming and costly and therefore not
possible to be done for every iteration
of your web
application consequently your code
shouldn't be untested before any release
using automated security you can scan
your web application for cross-side
scripting and other critical
vulnerabilities before every release
this way you can ensure that your web
application live version is still
secured whenever you alter or add a
feature input fields are the most common
point of entry for xss attack script
therefore you should always screen and
validate any information input into data
fields this is particularly important if
the data will be included as HTML output
this can be used to protect against
reflected exess cess
attacks validation should occur on both
the client side and server side as an
added precaution this helps validating
the data before it's being sent to the
servers and can also protect against
persistent xss scripts this can be
accomplished using JavaScript xss
attacks only appear if any user input is
being displayed on the web page
therefore try to avoid displaying any
untrusted user input if possible if you
need to display user data restrict the
places where the user input might appear
any input displayed inside a JavaScript
tag or a URL shown on the site is much
more likely to be exploited than the
input that appears inside a division or
a span element inside the HTML body
protecting against accss vulnerabilities
typically requires properly escaping
user provided data that is placed on the
page rather than trying to determine if
the data is user provided and could be
compromised we should always play it
safe and Escape data whether whether it
is user provided or not unfortunately
because there are many different rules
for escaping you still must choose the
proper type of escaping before settling
on a final
code encoding should be applied directly
before user controllable data is written
to a page because the context you're
writing into determines what kind of
encoding you need to use for example
values inside a JavaScript string
require a different type of escaping to
those in an HTML context
sometimes you'll need to apply multiple
layers of encoding in the correct order
for example to safely embed user input
inside an event handler you need to deal
with both JavaScript context and the
HTML context so you need to First
Unicode escape the input and then HTML
encoded content security policy or CSP
is a computer security standard
introduced to prevent cross-site
scripting clickjacking and other code
injection attacks resulting from the the
execution of malicious content in The
Trusted web page context it is a
candidate recommendations of the w3c
working group on web application
security it's widely supported by modern
web browsers and provides a standard
method for website owners to declare
approved origins of content that browser
should be allowed to load on that
website HTTP only is an additional flag
included in a set cookie HTTP response
header using the HTTP only flag when
generating a cookie helps mitigate the
risk of client side script accessing the
protected cookie that is if the browser
supports it if the HTTP only flag is
included in the HTTP response header the
cookie cannot be accessed through a
client side script again this is if the
browser supports this flag as a result
even if a cross-side scripting flaw
exists and a user accidentally accesses
a link that exploits this flop the
browser will not reveal the cookie to a
third
party if a browser does not not support
HTTP only and a website attempts to set
an HTTP only cookie the HTTP only flag
will be ignored browser browser thus
creating a traditional script accessible
cookie as a result the cookie becomes
vulnerable to theft of modification by
any malicious script next on our docket
is a live demonstration where we solve a
set of cross-site scripting problems
starting from the basic level to the
topmost level six we're going to start
at level one
in this verb application it demonstrates
the common cause of crosslite scripting
by user input is directly included in
the page without proper
escaping if you interact with a
vulnerable application window here and
find a way to make it execute JavaScript
of our choosing we can take actions
inside the vulnerable window or directly
edit its URL bar this task needs only
basic knowledge let's see why the most
primitive injections work here right
away let's do a simple query and inspect
the resulting HTML
page I'm going to use this
phrase with a single quote as a special
character we can now inspect the HTML
page we can see here in this line
the special character single code
appears in the result over
here the provided query text is placed
directly in a b tag as in a body element
we need to perform a reflected xss into
the web application because they are
non-persistent xss attacks and the P
load should be included in the URL to
perform successful
exploitation we can use any payload but
we're going to use the simple one to
perform an alert in this web application
it's simple and can be shown
easily just going to write the script
over
here I'm going to press
search as you can see we have
successfully launched our first
cross-side scripting attack we can see
an alert box pop up with the necessary
message and a similar process can be
used to steal browser cookies and
passwords albeit with different
commands now we have the option to move
to level
two in this web application it shows
that how easily accss bugs can be
introduced in complex chat
applications chat app conversations are
stored in a database B and retrieved
when a user wants to see the
conversation therefore if a malicious
user injects some JavaScript code all
visitors will be infected this kind of
cross-site scripting attack is more
powerful and it is more riskier than
reflected cross-site scripting attacks
and that's why is known as stored
xss I posted my
query with a special character of a
single quote and this is what I
get whatever I typed in simply a
appeared on the page right after I click
on share status let's see the
source you can see here the text I
posted seems directly put inside a block
code tag so even a simple script tag we
used in level one should work here but
it will not let us examine the code to
understand
why we're going to toggle the code of a
here and check the index.html
file important
part is line
32 the generated HTML fragment which is
the HTML variable in the code is added
to the male HTML using the inner HTML
method so when the browser passing this
HTML fragment it will not execute any
script tag defined within that HTML
fragment HTML parer will not execute a
script tag when it passes htmls via this
method this is why the script tag like
we used in level one is not going to
work here our solution is to use events
events will execute the defined
JavaScript we're going to use an image
over
here
and when we press on share
status in the above injection we are
loading an image that doesn't exist
which causes to trigger an on error
event in on error event the it will
execute our alert
method with that we are able to beat
level two and we can now move up to the
next level in our
challenge as you can see clicking on any
tab causes the tab number to be
displayed in the URL
fragment this hints that the value after
the hashtag controls the behavior of the
page that is it is an input variable to
confirm let's add analyze the
code as you can see in line 43 inside
the event
handling the value provided after the
hash in the
URL is directly passed onto the chew tab
method no input validation is being
performed the value passed to the choose
tab method is directly injected into the
IMG tag in line
this is an unsafe assignment and it is
the vulnerable part of the code now all
we have to do now is to craft a payload
that would adjust the IMG tag to execute
our JavaScript remember the script tag
from level one would not work here since
the variable HTML is used to add the Dom
dynamically hence the events are ases
here once again I will choose to use the
existing IMG tag and change the source
to something that doesn't exist hence
forcing it to fall in to execute an on
error even which I will pass the
URL
once we visit that URL we can see that
our Java popup has opened up here with
the same message of xss level 3 has been
completed with this we can now move on
to level four which is going to present
a different kind of
attack in this web application there is
a timer on the page that means whatever
numbers we put in the Box a countdown
starts and then when it finishes the
application alerts that the countdown is
finished and we can see the time is a
popup appearing over here and this
resets the timer again now it is obvious
that the value entered in the text box
is transferred to the server over the
timer parameter in the
URL let us examine the code to see how
the timer parameter is being
handled we're going to visit timer. HTML
over
here and we're going to check over
here in line
21 the start timer method is being
called in the onload event however the
timer parameter is being directly passed
to the start timer method we need to
perform a popup Alert in the web
application which escapes the content of
the function start timer without
breaking the JavaScript code the
parameter value is directly added to the
start timer method without any filtering
what we can try to do here is to inject
an alert function to be executed inside
the on loone event along with the start
timer
method we're going to remove this
argument and put our script over
here
now I me press on create
timer and we have a popup with the xss
level 4
completed we can now move on to level
five in this web application this
application xss is different cuz this
challenge description says cross-side
scripting isn't just about correctly
escaping
data sometimes attackers can do bad
things even without injecting new
elements into the Dom it's kind of open
redirect cu the attack payload is
executed as a result of modifying the
Dom environment in the victim's browser
this environment is used by the original
client side script so that the client
side code runs in an unexpected manner
the vulnerability can be easily detected
if the next Link in the signup page is
inspected
the href attribute value of next link is
confirm which is exactly the value of
the next URL query
parameter as you can see over here this
means using the next query parameter can
be used to inject a JavaScript code to
the href attribute of the next
link the following is the best way to do
it as soon as the user clicks on the
link the script will be
triggered
going to press anything random and now
that we click next we can see the xss
level 5 that we had provided in the URL
as a parameter to the next
variable since the value of next
provided appears on a popup we can
consider the attack a success and move
on to the final level
six in this sub application it shows
some of the external Javascript is
rried if you analyze the URL you can see
that the script is loaded already the
vulnerability lies within how the code
handles the value after the
hashtag if you check on line 45 the
value right after the hashtag is taken
as the gadget name and then in line
48 the value is directly passed on to
the include Gadget method and the
include Gadget method that we can see
over
here you can see in line
18 a script tag is is created and the
URL Gadget name parameter value is
directly used as the source attribute of
the script tag in line
28 this means we can completely control
the source attribute of the script tag
that is being
created that is with this vulnerability
we can inject our own Javascript file
into the code we can inject a URL of our
own hosted JavaScript into the web
applications URL after the hashtag and
the URL should not be using https but
anything like that to BU bypass the
regular expression for security
checking going to remove the pre-stored
URL and we're going to load our own
Javascript
file
finally we have reached the end of our
challenge we completed six different
varieties of cross scripting attacks and
use different solutions for all of the
six questions with work from home being
the norm in today's era people spend
considerable amount of time on the
internet often without specific measures
to ensure a secure your session apart
from individuals organizations worldwide
that host data and conduct business over
the internet are always at the risk of a
Dos attack these dos attacks are getting
more extreme with hackers getting easy
access to botet farms and compromised
devices as can be seen in the graph
three of the six strongest DDOS attacks
were launched in 2021 with the most
extreme attack occurring just last year
in 2020 lately cyber criminals have been
actively seeking out new services and
protocols for amplifying these DS
attacks active involvement with hacked
machines and botet allow further
penetration into the consumer space
allowing much more elaborate attack
campaigns apart from General users
multinational corporations have also had
their fair share of problems GitHub a
platform for software developers was the
target of a DS attack in 2018 widely
suspected to be conducted by Chinese
authorities this attack went on for
about 20 minutes after which the systems
were brought into a stable condition it
was the strongest DS attack to date at
the time and made a lot of companies
reconsider the security practices to
combat such attacks even after years of
experimentation DS attacks are still at
large and can affect anyone in the
consumer and corporate space hey
everyone this is B from Simply learn and
welcome to this video on what is a Dos
attack let's learn more about what is a
DS attack
a distributed denial of service attack
or dos is when an attacker or attackers
attempt to make it impossible for a
service to be delivered this can be
achieved by thating access to virtually
anything servers devices Services
networks applications and even specific
transactions within applications in a
Dos attack it's one system that is
sending the malicious data or requests a
DS attack comes from multiple systems
generally these attacks work by Drowning
a system with requests for data this
could be sending a web server so many
requests to server page that it crashes
under the demand or it could be a
database being hit with a high volume of
queries the result is available internet
bandwidth CPU and RAM capacity become
overwhelmed the impact could range from
a minor annoyance from disrupted
services to experiencing entire websites
applications or even entire businesses
taking off offline more often than not
these attacks are launched using
machines in a botnet a botnet is a
network of devices that can be triggered
to send requests from a remote Source
often known as the command and control
center the bots in the network attack a
particular Target thereby hiding the
original perpetrator of the Dos campaign
but how do these devices come under a
botnet and what are the requests being
made to the web servers let's learn more
about these and how DS attack works
a DS attack is a two-phase process in
the first phase a hacker creates a
botnet of devices simply put a vast
network of computers are hacked via
malware ransomware or just simple social
engineering these devices become a part
of the botn net which can be triggered
any time to start bombarding a system or
a server on the instruction of the
hacker that created the botn net the
devices in this networks are called Bots
or zombies
in the second phase a particular Target
is selected for the attack when the
hacker finds the right time to attack
all the zombies in the botnet network
send these requests to the Target
thereby taking up all the servers
available bandwidth these can be simple
ping requests or complex attacks like SN
flooding and UDP flooding the aim is to
overwhelm them with more traffic than
the server or the network can
accommodate the goal is to render the
website or service inoperable
there's a lot of wiggle room when it
comes to the type of DS attack a hacker
can go with depending on the target's
vulnerability we can choose one of the
three broad categories of Dos
attacks volume based attacks use massive
amounts of bogus traffic to overwhelm a
resource it can be a website or a server
they include icmp udap and spoofed
packet flood attacks the size of volume
based attack is measured in bits per
second these attack focus and clogging
all the available bandwidth for the
server thereby cutting the supply short
several requests are sent to the server
all of which warrant a reply thereby not
allowing the target to cater to the
general legitimate
users next we have the protocol level
attacks these attacks are meant to
consume essential resources of the
target server they exhaust the load
balancers and fire walls which are meant
to protect the system against the dors
attacks these protocol attacks in
include SN floods and Smurf DDOS among
others and the size is measured in
packets per second for example in an SSL
handshake server replies to the Hello
message sent by the hacker which will be
the client in this case but since the IP
is poofed and leads nowhere the server
gets stuck in an endless loop of sending
the acknowledgement without any end in
sight finally we have the application
Level attacks application lay attacks
are conducted by flooding applications
with maliciously crafted requests the
size of application ler attacks is
measured in request per second these are
relatively sophisticated attacks that
Target the application and operating
system level
vulnerabilities they prevent the
specific applications from delivering
necessary information to users and hog
the network bandid up to the point of a
system crash examples of such an attack
are HTTP flooding and bgp hijacking a
single device can request data from a
server using HTTP post or get without
any
issues however when the requisite botn
net is instructed to bombard the server
with thousands of requests the database
bandwidth gets jammed and it eventually
becomes unresponsive and
unusable but what about the reasons for
such an attack there are multiple lines
of thought as to why a hacker decides to
launch a DS attack on unsuspecting
targets let's take a look at a few of
them the first option is to gain a compe
ative Advantage many ds attacks are
conducted by hacking communities against
rival groups some organizations hire
such communities to stagger their Rivals
resources at a network level to gain an
advantage in the playing field since
being a victim of a DS attack indicates
a lack of security the reputation of
such a company takes a significant hit
allowing the rivals to cover up some
ground secondly some hackers launched
these DS attacks to hold multinational
corporations at transom the resources
are jammed and the only way to clear the
way is if the target company agrees to
pay a designated amount of money to the
hackers even a few minutes of inactivity
is detrimental to a company's reputation
in the global market and it can cause a
spiral effect both in terms of market
value and product security index most of
the time a compromise is reached and the
resources are freed after a while toos
attacks have also found use in the
political segment certain activists tend
to use DS attacks to voice their opinion
spreading the word online is much faster
than any local Rally or Forum primarily
political these attacks also focus on
online communities ethical dilemas or
even protest against corporations let's
take a look at a few ways that companies
and individuals can protect themselves
against three do
attacks the company can employ load
balancers and firewalls to help protect
the data from from such attacks load
balancers reroute the traffic from one
server to another in a DS attack this
reduces the single point of failure and
adds resiliency to the server data a
firewall blocks unwanted traffic into a
system and manages the number of request
made at a definite rate it checks for
multiple attacks from a single IP and
occasional slowdowns to detect a Dos
attack in
action early detection of a Doos attack
goes a long way in recovering the data
lost in such an event once you've
detected the attack you will have to
find a way to respond for example you
will have to work on dropping the
malicious DS traffic before it reaches
your server so that it doesn't throttle
and exhaust your bandwidth here's where
you will filter the traffic so that only
legitimate traffic reaches the server by
intelligent routing you can break the
remaining traffic into manageable chunks
that can be handled by your cluster
resources the most important stage in
DOS mitigation is is where you will look
for patterns of Ross attacks and use
those to analyze and strengthen your
mitigation techniques for example
blocking an IP that's repeatedly found
to be offending is a first
step Cloud providers like Amazon web
services and Microsoft Azure who offer
high levels of cyber security including
firewalls and threat monitoring software
can help protect your assets and network
from DS criminals the cloud also has
greater bandwidth than most private
networks so it is likely to fail if
under the pressure of increased DS
attacks additionally reputable Cloud
providers offer Network redundancy
duplicating copies of your data systems
and equipment so that if your service
becomes corrupted or unavailable due to
a DS attack you can switch to a secure
access on backed up versions without
missing a beat one can also increase the
amount of bandwidth available to a host
server being targeted since GS attacks
fundamentally operate on the principle
of overwhelming systems with heavy
traffic simply provisioning extra
bandwidth to handle unexpected traffic
spikes can provide a measure of
protection this solution can prove
expensive as a lot of that bandwidth is
going to go unused most of the
time a Content delivery Network or a CDN
distributes your content and boost
performance by minimizing the distance
between your resources and end users it
stores the cached version of your
content in multiple locations and this
eventually mitigates dos attacks by
avoiding a single point of failure when
the attacker is trying to focus on a
single Target popular CDN include acomi
CDN Cloud flare AWS cloudfront
Etc let's start with a demo regarding
the effects of DS attacks on a system
for a demo we have a single device that
will attack a Target making it a do
attack of sorts once a bot net is ready
multiple devices can do the same and
event entually emulate a DS attack to do
so we will use the virtualization
software called VMware with an instance
of parro security operating system
running for a Target machine we will be
running another vmw instance of a
standard Linux distribution known as
Linux light in a Target device we can
use wire shark to determine when the
attack begins and see the effects of the
attack
accordingly this is Linux light which is
our Target machine and this is parad
security which is used by the hacker
when trying to launch a DS attack this
is just one of the dror that can be
used to launch the attack we must first
find the IP address of our
Target so to find the IP address we open
the
terminal we use the command if
config and here we can find the IP
address now remember we're launching
this attack in VMware now the both the
instances of parot security and Linux
light are being run on my local network
so the address that you can see here is
192.168 72.1 129 which is a private
address this IP cannot be accessed from
outside the network basically anyone who
is not connected to my Wi-Fi when
launching attacks with public servers or
public addresses it will have a public
IP address that does not belong to the
subnet once we have the IP
address we can use a tool
called hping
3 hping3 is an open-source packet
generator and analyzer for the TCP IP
protocol to check what are the effects
of an attack we will be using wire shark
wire shark is a network traffic analyzer
we can see whatever traffic that is
passing through the Linux light drro is
being displayed over here with the IP
address the source IP and the
destination IP as to where the request
is being transferred to once we have the
Dos attack launched you can see the
results coming over here from The Source
IP which will be par security Now to
launch the hping 3 command we need to
give pseudo access to the console which
is the root
access
now we have the root access for the
console the hping 3 command will have a
few arguments to go with it which are as
you can see on the
screen minus s and a
flood a hyphen
V hyphen p80 and the IP address of the
target which is 192
1229 in this command we have a few
arguments that such as the minus s which
specifies SN packets like in an SSL
handshake we have the SN request that
the client sends to the server to
initiate a connection The Hyphen flood
aims to ignore the replies that the
server will send back to the client in
response to the SN packets here the par
security OS is the client and Linux
slide being the
server minus v stands for verbosity as
in where we will see some output when
the requests are being sent the hyphen
p80 stands for Port 80 which we can
replace the port number if we want to
attack a different port and finally we
have the IP address of our
Target as of right now if we check wire
shock it is relatively clear and there
is no indication of of a DS attack
incoming now once we launch the attack
over
here we can see the requests coming in
from this IP which is 192 168 72.1
128 till now even the network is
responsive and so is Linux
light the request keep on coming and we
can see the
HTTP flooding has started in flood mode
after a few seconds of this attack
continuing the server will start
shutting down now remember Linux light
is a drro that can focus on and that
serves as a
backend now remember Linux light is a
drro and such Linux dros are served as
backend to many servers across the world
for example a few seconds have passed
from the attack now the system has
become completely irresponsive this has
happened due to the huge number of
requests that came from par
security you can see whatever I press
nothing is responded even the wi Shar
has stopped capturing new request
because the CPU usage right now is
completely 100% and at this point of
time anyone who is trying to request
some information from this Linux drro or
where this Linux drro is being used as a
backend for a server or a database
cannot access anything else the system
has completely sto responding and any
request any legitimate request from
legitimate users will be
dropped once you stop the attack over
here it takes a bit of time to settle
down now remember it's still out of
control but eventually the traffic dies
down and the system regains its strength
it is relatively easy to gauge right now
the effect of a Dos attack now remember
this Linux light is just a VM instance
actual website servers and web databases
they have much more bandwidth and are
very secure and it is tough to break
into that is why we cannot use a single
machine to break into them that is where
a DS attack comes into play what we did
right now is a Dos attack as in a single
system is being used to penetrate a
Target server using a single request now
when a DDOS attack multiple systems such
as multiple pyro security instances or
multiple zombies or SPS in a botnet
network can attack a Target server to
completely shut down the machine and
drop any legitimate request thereby
rendering the service and the target
completely unusable and
inoperable as a final note we would like
to remind that this is for educational
purposes only and we do not endorse any
attacks on any domains only test this on
servers and networks that you have
permission to test on cyber security has
become one of the most rigid Industries
in the last decade while simultaneously
being the most challenged with every
aspect of corporate culture going online
and embracing cloud computing there is a
plethora of critical data circulating
through the internet all worth billions
of dollars to the right person
increasing benefits require more complex
attacks and one of these attacks is a
Brute Force attack a brute force or
known as Brute Force cracking is the
Cyber attack equivalent of trying every
key on your key ring and eventually
finding the right one boot Force attacks
are simple and reliable there is no
prior knowledge needed about the victim
to start an attack most of the systems
following prey to Brute Force attacks
are actually well
secured attackers let a computer do the
work that is trying different
combinations of usernames and passwords
until they find the one that works due
to this repeated trial and error format
the strength of password matters a great
Dr although with enough time and
resources brute force will break a
system since they run multiple
combinations until they find the right
passcode hey everyone this is B from
Simply learn and welcome to this video
on what is a Brute Force attack let's
begin with learning about Brute Force
attacks in
detail a Brute Force attack also known
as an exhaustive search is a
cryptographic hack that relies on
guessing possible combinations of
targeted password until the current
password is discovered it can be used to
break into online accounts encrypted
documents or even Network peripheral
devices
the longer the password the more
combinations that will need to be tested
a Brute Force attack can be timec
consuming and difficult to perform if
methods such as data off fisc are used
and at times downright
impossible however if the password is
weak it could merely take seconds with
hardly any effort dictionary attacks are
an alternative to Brute Force attacks
where the attacker already has a list of
usernames and passwords that need to be
tested against the target it doesn't
need to create any other the
combinations on its own dictionary
attacks are much more reliable than
brute force in a real world context but
the usefulness depends entirely on the
strength of passwords being used by the
general
population there is a three-step process
when it comes to brute forcing a system
let's learn about each of them in
detail in step one we have to settle on
a tool that we are going to use for
brute forcing there are some popular
names on the market like hashcat
Hydra and John the Ripper while each of
them has its own strength and weaknesses
each of them perform well with the right
configuration all of these tools come
pre-installed with certain Linux
distributions that cater to penetration
testers and cyber security analysts like
K Linux and parot
security after deciding what tool to use
we can start generating combinations of
alpha numeric variables whose only
limitation is the number of characters
for example
while using Hydra a single six-digit
password will create 900,000 passwords
with only digits involved add alphabets
and symbols to that sample space and
that numbers grows
exponentially the popular tools allow
customizing this process let's say the
hacker is aware of the password being a
specific 8-digit word containing only
letters and symbols this will
substantially increase the chances of
being able to guess the right password
since we remove the time taken to
generate the longer ones we omit the
need for including digits in such
combinations these small tweaks go a
long way in organizing an efficient
brost Force attack since running all the
combinations with no filters will
dramatically reduce the odds of finding
the right credentials in time in the
final step we run these combinations
against the file or service that is
being broken we can try and break into a
specific encrypted document a social
media account or even devices at home
that connect to the internet let's say
there is a Wi-Fi router the generated
passwords are then fed into the
connection one after the other it is a
long and harders process but the work is
left to the computer other than someone
manually clicking and checking each of
these
passcodes any password that doesn't
unlock the router is discarded and The
Brute Force tool simply moves on to the
next one this keeps going on until we
find the right combination which unlocks
the
router sometimes reaching the success
stage takes days and weeks which makes
it cumbersome for people with low
computing power at their disposal
however the ability to crack any system
in the world purely due to bad password
habits is very appealing and the general
public tends to stick with simple and
easy to ous
passwords now that we have a fair idea
about how Brute Force Works let's see if
you can answer this question we learned
about how complex passwords are tougher
to crack by Brute Force among the ones
listed on the screens which one do you
believe will take the longest to be
broken when using Brute Force tools
leave your answers in the comment
section and we will get back to you with
the correct option next
week let's move on to the harmful
effects of getting a system compromised
due to brot force
attacks a hacked laptop or mobile can
have social media accounts logged in
giving the hackers free access to the
victim's connections it has been
reported on multiple occasions where
compromised Facebook accounts are
sending malicious links and attachments
to people on their friends
list one of the significant reasons for
hacking malware infusion is best done
when spread from multiple devices
similar to Distributing spam this
reduces the chance of circling back the
source to a single device which belongs
to the hacker once brute forced A system
can spread malware via email attachments
sharing links file upload via FTP
Etc personal information such as credit
card data usage habits private images
and videos are all stored in our systems
be it in plain format or root folders a
compromised laptop means easy access to
these information that can be further
used to impersonate the victim regarding
Bank verification among other
things once a system is hacked it can
also be used as a mail server they
distributees spam across lists of
victims since the hack machines all have
different IP addresses and Mac addresses
it becomes challenging to trace the spam
back to the original hacker with so many
harmful implications arising from a boot
Force attack it's imperative that the
general public must be protected against
such let's learn about some of the ways
we can prevent ourselves from becoming a
victim of Brute Force
attacks using passwords consisting of
alphabets letters and numbers have a
much higher chance of with standing
Brute Force attacks thanks to the sheer
number of combinations they they can
produce the longer the password the less
likely it is that a hacker will devote
the time and resources to bruteforce
them having alpha numeric passwords also
allows the user to keep different
passwords for different websites this is
to ensure that if a single account or a
password is compromised due to a breach
or a hack the rest of the accounts are
isolated from the
incident two-factor authentication
involves receiving a one-time password
on a trusted device before a new login
is allowed this OTB can be obtained
either via email SMS or specific tofa
applications like Ai and Aegis email and
SMS based otps are considered relatively
less secure nowadays due to the ease
with which SIM cards can be duplicated
and mailboxes can be hacked applications
that are specifically made for 2A course
are much more reliable and
secure captur are used to stop Bots from
running through web pages precisely to
prevent brute forcing through their
website since Brute Force tools are
automated forcing the hacker to solve
capture for every iteration of a
password manually is very challenging
the capture system can filter out these
automated Bots that keep refreshing the
page with different credentials thereby
reducing the chances of Brute Force
considerably a definite rule that locks
the account being hacked for 30 minutes
after a specific number of attempts is a
good way to prevent Brute Force attempts
many websites lock account for 30
minutes after three failed password
attempts to secure the account against
any such attack on an additional note
some websites also send an email
instructing the user that there have
been three insecure attempts to log into
the
website let's look at a demonstration of
how Brute Force attacks work in a real
world situation the world has gone
Wireless with Wii taking the re in every
household it's natural that the security
will always be up for debate
to further test the security index and
understand Brute Force attacks you will
attempt to break into the password of a
Wi-Fi router for that to happen you
first need to capture a handshake file
which is a connection file from the
Wi-Fi router to a connecting device like
a mobile or a laptop the operating
system used for this process is parot
security a Linux distribution that is
catered to penetration testers all the
tools being used in this demo can easily
be found pre-installed in this operating
system if getting your learning started
is half the battle what if you could do
that for free visit scaleup by simply
learn click on the link in the
description to know
more to start our demo we're going to
use a tool called air gedon which is
made to hack into wireless network
specifically at this point it's going to
check for all the necessary scripts that
are installed in the
system
to crack into a Wi-Fi and to capture the
handshake file we're going to need an
external network card the significance
of the external network card is a
managed mode and a monitor mode for now
the WL X1 named card is my external
network adapter which I'm going to
select to be able to capture data over
the air we're going to need to put it in
monitor mode as you can see above it's
written it is in managed mode right now
so we're going to select option two
which is to put the interface in monitor
mode and its name is now dou land zero
monitor the monitor mode is necessary to
capture data over the air that is the
necessary reason why we need an external
card since a lot of inbuilt cards that
come with the laptops and the systems
they cannot have a monitor mode
installed once we select the mode we can
go into the fifth which is the handshake
tools menu
in the first step we have to explore for
targets and it is written that monitor
mode is necessary to select a Target so
let's explore for
targets and press
enter we have to let this run for about
60 seconds to get a fair idea about the
networks that are currently working in
this locality for example this ESS ID is
supposed to be the Wi-Fi name that we
see when connecting to a network go24
recover me these are all the names that
we see on our mobile when trying to
search for the Wi-Fi this BSS ID is
supposed to be an identifier somewhat
like a MAC address that identifies this
network from other devices the channels
features on one or two or there are some
many channels that the networks can
focus
on this here is supposed to be a client
that is connected to one one such
Network for example the station that you
can see 56 26 this is supposed to be the
MAC address of the device that is
connected to a router this BSS ID is
supposed to be which wi-fi it is
connected to for example 5895 d8 is this
one which is the go24 router so we
already know which router has a device
connected to it and we can use our
attack to capture this
handshake now that we it has already run
for 1 minute now that we press contrl
C it will be asked to select a Target
see it has already selected the number
five which is the ge24 router as the one
with clients so it is easy to run an
attack on and it is easy to capture a
handshake
for select Network 5 and we run a
capture
handshake it says we have a valid WPA
WPA2 Network Target selected and that
the script can
continue now to capture the handshake we
have a couple of attacks a do or a do
air replay attack what this attack does
is kick the clients out of the network
in return when they try to reconnect to
the Wi-Fi as they are configured that
way that when a client is disconnected
it tries to reconnect it immediately it
tries to capture a handshake file which
in turn contains the security key which
is necessary to initiate the
handshake for our demo let's go with the
second option that is the do replay
attack select a timeout value let's say
we give it 60
seconds and we start the
script we can see it capturing data from
the ge24 network and here we go we have
the WPA handshake
file once the handshake file is captured
can actually close this and here we go
congratulations in order to capturing a
hand shake it has verified that a pmk ID
from the target network has successfully
been captured this is the file that is
already stored a do cap file for the
path we can let's say we can keep it in
a
desktop okay we give the
path and the Hand Shi file is generated
we can already see a Target over here
same go24 router with the BSS
ID now if we return to its main menu we
already have the handshake file captured
with us now our job is to Brute Force
into that handshake capture file the
capture file is often encrypted with the
security key of the Wi-Fi network if we
know how to decrypt it we will
automatically get the security key so
let's go to the offline WPA wp2 decrypt
menu since we'll be cracking personal
networks we can go with option
one now to run the Brute Force tool we
have two options either we can go with
the air crack or we can go with the
hashcat let's go with air plus crunch
which is a Brute Force attack against a
handshake file we can go with option
two it can already detect the capture
file that we have generated so we select
yes the BSS ID is the one which denotes
the go24 router so we're going to select
yes as well the minimum length of the
key for example it has already checked
that the minimum length of a Wi-Fi
security key which is a WPA2 psk key
will always be more than eight digits
and Below 64 digits so we have to select
something in between this range so if we
already know let's say that the password
is at least 10 digits we can go with the
minimum length as 10 and as a rough
guess let's say we put the maximum
length as
20 the character set that we're going to
use for checking the password will
affect the time taken to Brute Force for
example if we already know that or we
have seen a user use the password while
connecting to the router as something
that has only numbers and symbols then
we can choose accordingly let's say if
you go with only upper case characters
and numeric
characters go with option
seven and it's going to start
decrypting so how aircrack is working
looking right here you can see this pass
phrase over here the first five or six
digits are a it starts working its way
from the end from the last character it
keeps trying every single combination
you can see the last the fourth
character from the right side the D
it'll eventually turn to
e because it keeps checking up every
single character from the end this will
keep going on until all the single
characters are tested and every single
com combination is tried out since the
handshake file is encrypted using the
security key that is the WPA2 key of the
router whichever pass phrase is able to
decrypt the handshake key completely
will be the key of the Wi-Fi router this
is the way we can Brute Force into Wi-Fi
routers anywhere in the world cyber
attacks are frequently making headlines
in today's digital environment at any
time everyone who uses a computer could
become a victim of a Cyber attack there
are various sorts of cyber tanks ranging
from fishing to password attacks in this
video we look into one such attack that
is known as botet but before we begin if
you love watching Tech videos subscribe
to our Channel and hit the Bell icon
never to miss an update to begin with
let's take a look at some of the famous
bot attackes the first one is miray
botman which is a malicious program
designed to attack vulnerable iot
devices and infect them to perform a
network of bots that on command perform
basic and medium level denial of service
attacks then we have the zo bot is
specifically designed for attacking the
system for Bank related information and
data now let's see what exactly a botnet
is botnet refers to a network of
hijacked interconnected devices that are
installed with malicious codes known as
malware each of these infected devices
are known as Bots and the hijek crial
known as B harder remotely controls them
the BS are used to automate large scale
attacks including Data Theft server
failure malare
propagation and denial of service
attacks now that we know what exactly a
bot net is let's dive deeper into
learning how bot net works during the
preparation of a botnet network the
first step involves preparing the bot
net Army after that the connection
between the bot net Army and the control
server established in the end the
launching of the attack is done by the
bot Herer let's understand through a
illustration firstly we have a b Herer
that initiates the attack according to
the control server commands the devices
that are infected with the malware
programs and begins to attack the
infected system let's see some details
regarding the preparation of the botnet
army the first step is known as the
prepping the bot net Army the first step
is creating a bot net is to infect as
many as connected devices as possible
this ensures that there are enough Bots
to carry out the attack this way it
creates Bots either by exploiting the
security gaps in the software or
websites or using fishing attacks they
are often deployed through troan
horses for the next step we have
establishing the connection once it
hacks the device as per previous step it
infects it with a specific malware that
connects the device back to the control
Boton server a bot Herer uses command
programming to drive the bot's
actions and the last step is known as
launching the attack once infected a bot
allows access to atmin level operation
like Gathering and stealing of data
reading and rewriting the system data
monitoring user activities performing
Deni of attacks including other cyber
crimes now let's take a look at the
important
architecture the first type is known as
client server model the client server
model is a traditional model that
operates with the help of a command and
control center server and communication
protocols like
IRC when the B Herer issues a command to
the server it is then related to the
clients to perform malicious
actions then we have peer-to-peer model
here controlling the infected Bots
involves a peer-to-peer Network that
relies on a decentralized approach that
is the Bots are tropological
interconnected and acts as both CNC
servers that is the server and the
client to the hackers adopt this
approach to avoid detection and single
point
failure in the end we will see some
points on some countermeasure against
bot net
attacks the first step is to have
updated drivers and system updates after
that we should avoid clicking random
popups or links that we often see on the
internet and lastly having certified
antivirus anti-spyware softwares and
firewall installed into a system will
protect against malware attack the
internet is an endless source of
information and data still in some cases
we come across some occurrences like
cyber attacks hacking force entry which
may affect a Time on the web hi everyone
and welcome to the simply La Channel
today we will discuss a topic that
secretly records our input data that is
known as key loggers but before we begin
if you like watching Tech videos
subscribe to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon to never miss an
update to understand the key logging
problem better let's take a look at an
example this is June she works in a
business firm where she manages the
company's data
regularly this is checkup from the
information Department who is here to
inform her about some of the security
protocols during the briefing she
informed him about some of the problems
a system was facing with which included
slow reaction speed and unusual internet
activity as Jacob heard about the
problems with the system he thinks of
the possibility what could be the reason
behind these problems a system was
facing
with the conclusion that he came across
was the key logging issue
unknown to the problem her system was
facing with she asked him about some of
the details regarding
it for today's topic we learn what
exactly key loggers are and how they
affect our system what are the harmful
effects that key loging can bring into
the system to begin with we learn what
exactly the key logging program
is as the name suggests key logger is a
malicious program or a tool that
designed to record key strokes that are
typed during data input and record them
into a lock file then the same program
secretly sends these lock files to its
origin where they can be used for
malicious acts by the
hacker now that we know what the key
logging program is let's take a look how
they enter into the
system searching for a suitable driver
for a system can often lead to the
installation of the key logging program
into the system if we often visit
suspicious sites and uncertified
software are installed into our system
then if we use unknown links or visiting
unknown websites which come through
unknown addresses can also be a reason
behind the key logging issue entering
into the system and lastly there are
often cases where different popups that
we often see on social sites or
different media sites can lead to the
installation of key loging program into
our
system
now that we know how the problem gets
into the system let's take a look how to
identify whether the system is infected
by the key logging
issue the key logging issue can be
identified if there are often cases when
a keyboard lags behind the system the
data that we enter sometimes is stuck in
between when we type through the
input then there are cases when the
system freeze occurs unknowingly to what
exactly could be the reason behind them
and also there are delayed reaction time
for different applications that run on
the system and lastly there are
different cases when we often see
suspicious internet activity on the
system that we don't know about this
could lead to the identification of a
problem into the
system now we'll take a look at
different types of key loggers that are
present on the net which can harm our
system
differently the first problem that key
loggers arouse is API based the most
common key logging case which uses apis
to keep a log of the type data and share
it to its origin for malicious purposes
each time we press a key the key logger
intercepts the signal and logs it then
we have form grabbing based key loggers
as the name suggests they are a based
key loggers that store
the form data that is if we often use
web forms or different kinds of forms to
enter different data they can be
recorded into the system by the program
and send it to its
origin then we have kernel based key
loggers these key loggers are installed
deeply into the operating system where
they can hide from different antivirus
if not checked properly and they record
the data that we type on the keyboard
and send it to its origin
and lastly we have Hardware Key loggers
these key loggers are present directly
into the hardware that is they are
embedded into system where they record
the data that we type on the
keyboard now let's take a look how
hackers differentiate different type of
recorded data and exploit
them when hackers receive information
about the target they might use it to
Blackmail the target which may affect
the the personal life of the Target and
also blackmail them for different money
related
issues then in case of company data that
is recorded by the key logging program
can also affect the economic value of
the company in the market which may lead
to the downfall of the
company also in some cases the key
logging program can also log data about
military Secrets which may include
nuclear codes or security protocols
which are necessary to maintain the
security of a
country now let's take a look whether
mobile devices get infected with the key
logging issue or
not in the case of hand devices
infection of key loggers are low in
comparison to the computer systems as
they use onscreen keyboard or virtual
keyboard but in some cases we often see
different kindes of malicious programs
getting installed into the hand device
if we often visit different uncertified
websites or illegal websites or torrent
sites and also the device that is
infected with the key logging issue or
different kind of malicious program can
often lead to the exploitation of data
that includes photos emails or important
files by the hacker or the Cyber
criminal that install the particular
malicious program into the
system now to prevent a system from
getting infected by the key locking
program let's take a look at different
points the first point includes using of
different antivirus softwares or tools
which can prevent the entering a
malicious program into the
system then keeping system security
protocols regularly updated is also a
good
habit and lastly using virtual keyboard
to input our sensitive data which may
include Bank details login details or
different passwords related to different
websites now that we have some
understanding about the topic of key
loggers let's take a look at the demo to
further increase the knowledge about the
topic for the first step we have to
download some of the important libraries
that are required into the
system which
is this library now we'll run
it the system says the library is
already installed into the
system now let's take a look what
exactly modules are required from the
particular
library from this Library we'll
import the keyboard module which will
help us to record the data that we type
on the
keyboard now from the same we'll also
import key
module and The Listener
module and
also the logging module which will help
us to record the data into a log
file for the next part we'll write a
piece of code that will allow us to save
the data that is recorded by the program
into a text file that will be named as
key log text file along with the date
and time stamp let's take a
look now we'll provide it with the file
name that will be given
as key log do txt
file and also so the part where the
format of the data is
recorded put the brackets over here to
contain the file name now we'll write
the format in which the data will be
recorded into the log file which will be
given
as the format would be the message and
the time stamp which would be given
as
along with the time
stamp as
percentage and ending it with the
bracket now for the next step we'll
design two of the functions that will be
used used into the program that will be
termed as while press function and while
release function let's take a
look while press
function would be a function that will
come into play when the keyboard key has
been
pressed
is
and this would go for the format that we
designed in the above
line
and
logging the Press
key
info a string file to be
recorded into the lock file
now now we'll design a function that is
while
release that will come into play
when
the Escape key has been pressed that is
the program will terminate itself and
the program will stop from
running and in the
end we require for the functioning of
the program to Loop these functions that
is while press and while release to
continue its
cycle
that will be going for while press
and
on release will contain while
release
function
as list
now and now this part would join the
different threads and store them into
the lock file now that we have completed
the code for the program let's run
it we have to wait for a moment so the
program runs it
now to ver ify the program let's open
notepad and on the notepad we'll
write hello
world which will be the basic whether
the program is working or not let's take
a
look and we'll go for the main page on
Jupiter notebook and refresh the page go
to the
botton over here we see that key log
text that is the text file that we
created let's open
it and over here we have the data that
is created as we started with Note then
this is the hello world part that we
created just
now which shows that the program we
created is working properly now that we
have reached the end of the module let's
take a look at the summary firstly we
learn what exactly key loggers are then
we understood what different modes are
present how the system get infected with
the key logging problem then we learned
how to detect the problem into our
system then we learned what different
types of key loggers are present on the
net we also understood how hackers use
the recorded data from the program and
we also learned whether mobile devices
get infected with the key logging
problem or not and lastly we understood
what different points can be to prevent
the entering of the key logging problem
into the system and before we begin if
you're someone who is interested in
building a career in cyber security or
to become an ethical hacker by
graduating from the best universities or
a professional who elicits to switch
career with cyber security or ethical
hacker by learning from the experts then
try giving a short to Simply Lars
postgraduate program in cyber security
with modules from MIT schi College of
computing the course link is mentioned
in the description box below that will
navigate you to the course page where
you can find a complete overview of the
program being offered before we learn
about the Pegasus platform let us
understand what spyware is and it's
working spyware is a category of malware
that can gather information regarding a
user or a device straight from the host
machine it is mostly spread by malicious
links via email or chat applications
when a link with the malware is received
clicking on this link will activate the
spyware which allows the hacker to spy
on all our user information with some
spyware systems even clicking on the
link isn't necessary to trigger the
malicious payload this can ultimately
cause security complications and further
loss of privacy one such spy system that
is making the rounds in the tech
industry today is Pegasus the Pegasus is
a spyer system developed by an Israeli
company known as the NSO group it runs
on mainly mobile devices spanning across
the major operating systems like the
Apple's IOS on iPhone and the standard
Android versions this is not a newly
developed platform form since Pegasus
has existed since as early as 2016 a
highly intricate spy program that can
track user location read text messages
scan through mobile files access device
camera and microphone to record voice
and video Pegasus has all the tools
necessary to enforce surveillance for
any client that wishes to buy its
services initially the NSO group had
designed the software to be used against
terrorist factions of the world with
more and more encrypted communication
channels coming to the Forefront Pegasus
was designed to maintain control over
the data transmission that can be a
threat to National Security
unfortunately the people who bought the
software had complete control over who
how and up to what level they can put
surveillance limits on eventually the
primary clients became Sovereign Nations
spying on Public Information that is
supposed to stay private became really
easy with this service multiple devices
can be affect With the same spy system
to create a network in information this
network keeps feeding data to the host
to understand how a network can be
created let's know how a mobile device
can be affected by Pegasus we all
communicate with friends and family over
instant messaging applications and email
in some instances if you check your
inbox on a regular basis you must have
noticed that we received some spam
emails that the mail providers like
Gmail and Yahoo can just filter into the
spam folder some of these messages
bypass this filter and make their way
into a person person's inbox they look
like generic emails which are supposed
to be safe the Pegasus pyware targets
such occurrences bypassing malicious
messages and links which install the
necessary Spy software on the user's
mobile device be it Android or an iPhone
this isn't unique to the email ecosystem
since it's equally likely to be targeted
by SMS text WhatsApp Instagram or even
the most secure messaging apps like
signal and threa once the malicious
links are clicked aspire PW package is
downloaded and installed on the device
after this spyware is successfully
installed the perpetrator who sent the
payload to the victim can monitor
everything the user does Pegasus can
collect private emails passwords images
videos and every other piece of
information that passes to the device
Network all this data is transmitted
back to the central server where the
primary spying organization can monitor
the activities at a granular level this
is not even surface level since comp Spy
software like Pegasus can access the
root files on our mobiles these root
files hold information that is crucial
to the working of the Android and iOS
operating systems leaking such private
information is a massive blow to the
security and the privacy of an
individual the information that may seem
trivial like the name of your Wi-Fi
connection or the last time you ordered
an item from Amazon are indeed all
valuable information this exploitation
is primarily possible due to the zero
day vulnerabilities known as bugs in the
software development process the zero
day bugs are the ones that have just
been discovered by some independent
security company or a researcher once
they are found reporting these
vulnerabilities to the developer of the
platform which would be either Google
for Android or Apple for iOS is the
right thing to do however many such
critical bugs make their way onto the
dark web where hackers can use them to
create exploits these exploits are then
sent to innocent users with a link or a
message like we had discussed before
Pegasus was able to affect the latest
devices with the all the security
patches installed but some bugs are not
reported to the developers or just
cannot be fixed without breaking some
core functionality these become the
Gateway for spyware to enter into the
system you can never be 100% safe but
you sure can give it all in protecting
yourself the one thing where Pegasus
stands out is a zero click action
feature usually in spam emails the
malicious code is act activated when the
user clicks the malware link a user
doesn't need to click the link in the
new version of the Pegasus and a few
other spyware programs once the message
arrives in the inbox of WhatsApp Gmail
or any other chat applications the
spyware gets activated and everything
can be recorded and sent back to the
central server the primary issue with
being affected by spyware as a victim is
detection unlike Crypt Miners and troan
spying Services usually do not demand
many system resources which which makes
them tough to detect after they have
been activated since many devices slow
down after a couple of years any kind of
Performance Set due to such spyware is
often attributed to poor software
longetivity by the users they do not
check meticulously for any other causes
that is causing the Slowdown when left
unchecked these devices can capture
voice and video from the mobile sensors
while keeping the owner in the dark
let's take a moment to check if you are
well aware of the causes of such attacks
how do users fall pre to such spyware
programs a by installing untested
software B by clicking on the third
party links from email and messages C by
not keeping the apps and phones updated
or D all of the above let us know your
answers in the comment section below and
we will R the correct answer next week
but what about the unaffected devices
the vulnerable ones while we cannot be
certain of our security there are a few
things we can do to boost our device be
it against Pegasus are the next big
spyer on the market let's say we are
safe now and we have the time to take
the necessary steps to prevent a spyer
attack what are the things we can go for
a primary goal must always be to keep
our apps and the operating system
updated the latest security patches the
vulnerabilities that the exploits Target
are often discovered by developers from
Google and apple which send the security
patches quickly this can be done for
individual apps as well so keeping them
updated is of utmost import importance
while the most secure devices have
fallen pre to Pegasus as well a security
patch from developers may help in
minimizing the damage at a later stage
or maybe negate the entire spyware
platform alog together another big
factor is the spread of malware is the
trend of sideloading Android
applications using do APK files
downloading such apps from a third party
website have no security checks involved
and are mostly responsible for adware
and spyware invasions on user devices
avoiding the side loading of apps would
be a major step in protecting yourself
we often receive spam emails or texts
from people we may not know on social
medias they are accompanied with links
that allow malware to creep into a
device we should try to follow the
trusted websites and not click on any
links that redirect us to unknown
domains spy is a controversial segment
in governance while the ramifications
are pretty extreme in theory it severely
impacts user privacy against
authoritarian regimes sufficient
resources and a contingent plan can
alter the false veale of democracy
altogether even if our daily life is
rather simplistic we must understand
that privacy is not about what we have
to hide instead it portrays the things
we have to protect it stands for
everything we have to share with the
outside world both theorically and
literally hey everyone today we look at
the hack which took the World by storm
and affected multiple governments and
corporations the solar winds attack the
global statistics indicate that upward
of 18,000 customers have been affected
potentially needing billions to recover
the losses incurred before we have a
look at this hack Make sure to subscribe
to our Channel and hit the notification
Bell to never miss an update from Simply
learn the date is December 8th 2020 fire
a global leader in company specializing
in cyber security released a blog post
that caught the attention of the entire
it Community a software known as Orion
which was developed by solar wind
Incorporated had become a victim of a
remote access Trojan or a rat the breach
was estimated to be running since the
spring of 2020 and went virtually
unnoticed for months the reveal sent the
developers of the Orion software into a
frenzy as they quickly released a couple
of hot fixes for their platform in order
to mitigate this threat and prevent
further damage but how did this come
into existence we first need to
understand the platform which was
responsible for this breach soloin a
software company based in Texas United
States had developed a management
platform known as Orion Hing to
corporations and governments worldwide
Orion was responsible for the monitoring
and management of it Administration this
included managing the client servers
virtualization components and even the
organization Network infrastructure that
bought the platform solar wind claims
they have more than 300,000 clients
including US government agencies and
several Fortune 500 companies this
entire chain can be classified as a
supply chain attack in this variant of
cyber crime crime the hackers Target
relatively weaker links in an
organization's chain of control and
delivery these are preferbly services
rendered by a third party since there is
no direct jurisdiction over it in this
case the Orion platform was the primary
target the culprit however was software
updates the update server for solar
Orion had a malicious version attached
with malware or a Trojan to be precise
this was made possible since the code
repository that handled the software
updates was breached once the update
server Repository was compromised the
source code of the applications became
open to modification and malicious code
found its way onto the software the
remote access trojen was attached to a
potential update nicknamed the Sunburst
update this update gave hackers back
door access to any client that uses the
correct version on its release many
clients believ the update to be
legitimate since it came from the right
source and they had no reason to believe
otherwise American government agencies
were supposedly hit the hardest as the
list of victims in included the US
Departments of Homeland Security
treasury and health several private
companies like Cisco Nvidia and Intel
were compromised according to a list
published by the cyber security firm
trusk most of the companies had issued
quick updates to fix this
vulnerabilities introduced by the
software while the actual perpetrators
have never been found it is believed
that this was an act of crossborder
corporate Espionage conducted by state
sponsored hackers either from Russia or
China before we move forward let's take
a recap of the things we learned what
category of malware was responsible for
the solar wind hack was it one virus a
remote access Trojan a spyware or a worm
let us know your answers in the comment
section right away and we will reveal
the correct answer in a week coming to
possible reparations the Biden
government has launched a full
investigation on the effects and the
repercussions of this breach there are a
couple of things that we as consumers
must always tend to when working our way
way through the worldwide web using a
password manager is highly recommended
which can generate secure alpha numeric
passwords you must also use different
passwords for different accounts thereby
reducing the chances of a single point
of failure should one of those accounts
get breached usage of two-factor
authentication applications is also
encouraged since it acts as a safety net
if hackers directly get a hold of our
credentials clicking on unknown links
transmitted via emails is also a strict
no as is installing applications from
unverified sources the solar winds hack
is estimated to cost the parent company
nearly $8 million as reparations making
it one if not the biggest hacks in
cyberspace history as recently as of
July 2021 the hackers access some us
attorneys Microsoft 365 email accounts
as part of the attack criminal
organizations like the FBI and CIA are
determined to figure out the culprits
responsible for this debacle however the
intricacy and the full extent of the
breach makes it a way more comp
complicated job than it looks on paper
the day is 26th February
2022 the world is hit with breaking news
that Russian State tv channels have been
hacked by Anonymous a activist
Collective and movement who have made a
name taking part in multiple Cyber Wars
in the past decade this was in response
to the Russian aggression on Ukrainian
territory in the hopes of annexation
Anonymous hacked the Russian State TV
networks to combat propaganda in Russia
and highlight the damage to life Meed
out by the Kremlin Ukraine they also
hacked 120,000 Russian troops personal
information and the Russian Central Bank
stealing 35,000 files this served as a
clear indicator of how cyber War can
change the momentum in battle something
which people had never seen so closely
so what is cyber War a digital assault
or series of strikes or hacks against a
country is sometimes referred to as a
cyber War it has the ability to cause
havoc on government and civilian
infrastru structure as well as disrupt
essential systems causing State harm and
even death in this day and age the
internet plays a bigger role than just
watching videos and learning content
it's where you have your personal data
and carry Financial transactions so
rather than resorting to physical
violence Cyber Wars become the new means
to cause Havoc considering the
vulnerability of the data passing
through the internet in most
circumstances cyber warfare involves a
nation state attacking another in
certain cases the assaults are carried
out by terrorist organizations or
non-state actors pursuing a hostile
nation's aim in June 2021 Chinese
hackers targeted organizations like
ryzon to secure remote access to their
networks stuck net was a computer worm
designed to attack Iran's nuclear
facilities but evolved and expanded to
many other industrial and energy
producing sites in
2010 since the definition of cyber war
is so vague applying rules and sanctions
based on digital assault is even tougher
making the field of cyber warfare a
lawless land not bound by any rules or
policies there are multiple ways in
which these attacks can be carried out a
major category of Cyber attack is
espionage Espionage entails monitoring
other countries to steal critical
Secrets this might include compromising
vulnerable computer systems with botn
Nets or spear fishing attempts before
extracting sensitive data in cyber
warfare the next weapon in cyber war is
sabotage government agencies must
identify sensitive data and its dangers
if it is exploited Insider threats such
as disgruntled or irresponsible
Personnel or government staff with ties
to the attacking country can be used by
hostile countries or terrorists to steal
or destroy
information by overwhelming a website
with bogus requests and forcing it to
handle them denial of service attacks
prohibit real users from accessing it
attacking parties may use this form of
assault to disrupt key operations and
systems and prevent citizens military
and security officials and research
organizations from accessing sensitive
websites but what benefits does Cyber
War offer in contrast to traditional
physical Warfare the most important
Advantage is the ability to conduct
attacks from anywhere globally without
having to travel thousands of miles as
long as the attacker and Target are
connected to the internet organizing and
launching Cyber Wars is relatively less
tedious Than Physical Warfare people
living in or battling for a country are
subjected to propaganda attacks in an
attempt to manipulate their emotions and
thoughts digital infrastructure is
highly crucial in today's modern world
starting from communication channels to
Secure Storage servers crippling a
country's footprint and control on the
Internet is very damaging but what are
some of the ways we as Citizens protect
ourselves in the case of a cyber war in
the unfortunate event that your country
is involved in Warfare be sure to fact
check every every piece of information
and follow only trusted sources in that
frame of time even conversations online
should be limited to a need to know
basis considering propaganda campaigns
have the power to influence the tide of
War drastically it is highly crucial to
follow basic security guidelines to
secure our devices like regularly
updating our operating systems
occasionally running full system
antivirus scans Etc if your country or
organization is being attacked having
devices segregated in Network goes a
long way in bolstering
security try to avoid sharing a lot of
personal data online in this era of
Instagram and Facebook divulging private
information can be detrimental to
keeping a secure firewall for your data
the more information an attacker has
access to the higher his chances of
being able to devise a plan to
infiltrate defenses and if you're
someone who is interested in building a
career in cyber security that is by
graduating from the best universities or
a professional while sits to switch
careers with cyber security by learning
from the experts then try giving a short
to Simply Lars postgraduate programming
cyber security with modules from the MIT
schwarzman College of Engineering and
the course link is mentioned in the
description box that will navigate you
to the course page where you can find a
complete overview of the program being
offered during data transmission there
are various external factors which can
affect the transmission of data over a
network channel to prevent such cases
from happening we use Internet Protocol
security which we'll be discussing in
the session on IPC explain hi guys and
welcome to year and testing video by
simply learn but before we begin if you
are watching Tech videos subscribe to
our Channel and hit the Bell icon to
miss an update from us now without
further Ado let's take a look at the
agenda for the
session to begin with we will look into
what is
IPC continuing with why do we use IPC in
a network
followed by components of Ip SEC modes
of Ip security as for the last topic we
will look into working steps involved in
IP security let's begin with the first
setting that is what is IP
SEC IPC Internet Protocol security is
defined as a set of framework and
protocol to ensure data transmission
over a network
channel this protocol was initially
defined on of two main protocols for
data security over a network channel
which were authentication header which
is responsible for data integrity and
anti-replay
services and the second protocol is
encapsulating security payload in short
ESP which includes data encryption and
data
authentication now let's move on to the
next setting that is why do we use IPC
in a
network IP SEC is used to secure
sensitive data and information such as
company data clinical data Bank data and
various sensitive information regarding
an institution which are used during
data transmission over a network
channel the use of VPN that are virtual
private networks and apply IPC protocols
to encrypt the data for into in
transmission let's continue with why do
we use IPC
Services IPC is also used to encrypt
data for application layer in the OSI
model and provide security for sharing
data over Network routers and data
authentication let's take a look at the
working of ipx
services to begin with we have two
different system system 1 and system 2
which will establish a network channel
and then the encryption of data will
takes place when one host will will
share the data to the second host during
this ipx services will secure the data
that is to be transferred over the
network channel by applying router
encryption and
authentication now let's move on to the
next topic that is components of
IPC the IPC Services comprises of
multiple protocols that ensure the data
transmission over the network channel
the first one is encapsulating security
payload protocol in short
ESP this protocol of Ip security
provides data encryption and
authentication
services and it also authenticates and
encrypt the data packet in the
transmission
Channel moving on we have authentication
header in short
ah similar to ESP the authentication
header also provides all the security
services but it does not encrypt the
data it also protects the IP packet and
adds additional headers to the packet
header the modified IP datagram looks
this way where the IP components are
included at the second position the
seventh position and the sixth position
along with the authentication of data
services over the network
channel moving on we have Internet key
exchange ik
ke this protocol provides protection for
Content data and also changes is the
attribute of the original data to be
shared by implementing sha and md5
algorithms they also check the message
for authentication and then only is
forwarded to the receiver side for
example this is the original data packet
we are used to with IP head upar TCP UDP
and data whereas this is the modified IP
site data packet where ESP header is
added between IP header and the TCP
protocol
now let's move on to the next heading
that is modes of Ip
SEC there are basically two types of Ip
modes available for data transmission
over the network channel where the first
one is tunnel mode this mode of
transmission is used to secure gateway
to Gateway data it is applied when the
final destination of the data is to be
connected to a sender site through a
connection Gateway over the internet for
example we have two host host a and host
B through the host a we are sending a
message to host B which will pass
through a Gateway at Host St point and
it passes through a gateway to ghost B
then this is a basic format for Gateway
to Gateway data
transmission and the given IP datagram
format is used for tunnel mode now let's
move on to the second mode of IPC that
is transport mode this mode of IPC is
used to protect protocols like TCP or
UDP and is used to ensure end to end
communication unlike tunnel mode the
transport mode data at authentication
header and encapsulating security
payload for security purpose in the IP
header this is the modified IP datagram
for transport mode
the point to be noted is the IPS header
is always added between IP header and
TCP
header now let's move on to the last
heading for the session on IP SEC that
is the working steps involved in IP
Security in general there are five steps
involved in the working of Ip sec to
ensure data transmission over a network
channel the first step is host
recognition in the first step the host
system will check if the pket is to be
transmitted or Not by automatically
triggering the security policy for the
data which is implemented by the sender
side for proper
encryption then the second step is known
as ik Phase 1 in this step the two host
devices the sender and the receiver side
will authenticate each other to
establish a secure network
channel it is comprised of two modes
the main mode this provides much better
security with a proper time
limit and the second mode known as
aggressive mode as the name suggests it
establishes the IPC protocol much faster
in comparison to main mode let's move on
to the third step which is ik Phase 2
after the second step the host decide
the type of cryptography algorithm to
apply over the session in the network
channel and the secret key for the
algorithm to be used to encrypt the data
for
transmission then we have IPC
transmission this step involves the
actual transfer of data over the network
channel using various protocols used in
IPC security which are implemented under
the tunnel
condition and the last step is IPC
termination after the completion of data
exchange or session timeout the IPC
tunnel is termin ated and the security
key established is discarded by both the
host system network security is a set of
technologies that protects the usability
and integrity of a company's
infrastructure by preventing the entry
or proliferation within a network it
architecture comprises of tools that
protect the network itself and the
applications that run over it effective
network security strategies employ
multiple lines of defense that are
scalable and automated each defensive
layer here enforces a set of security
policies which are determined by the
administrator beforehand this aims at
securing the confidentiality and
accessibility of the data and the
network the every company or
organization that handles a large amount
of data has a degree of solutions
against many cyber threats the most
basic example of network security is
password protection it has the network
the user chooses so recently network
security has become the central topic of
cyber security with many organizations
involved in applications from people
with skills in this area it is crucial
for both personal and professional
networks most houses with highspeed
internet have one or more wireless
routers which can be vulnerable to
attacks if they're not adequately
secured data loss theft and sabotage
risk may be decreased with the usage of
a strong network security system your
workstations are protected from
hazardous 5 thanks to network security
additionally it guarantees the security
of the data which is being being shared
over a network by dividing information
into various sections encrypting these
portions and transferring them over
separate Pathways network security
infrastructure offers multiple levels of
protection to th man in the midle
attacks preventing situations like
eavesdropping among other harmful
attacks it has become increasingly
difficult in today's hyperconnected
environment as more coroporate
applications migrate to both public and
private clocks additionally modern
applications are also frequently
virtualized and and dispersed across
several locations some outside the
physical control of the IT team Network
traffic and infrastructure must be
protected in these cases since assaults
on businesses are increasing every
single day we now understood the basics
of network security but we need to
understand how network security works in
the next section in slightly more detail
network security revolves around two
processes authentication and
authorization the first process which is
authentication is is similar to access
cards which ensure that only those have
the right to enter a building in other
words authentication checks and verifies
that it is indeed the user belonging to
the network is trying to access or enter
it thereby preventing unauthorized
intrusions next comes
authorization this process decides the
level of access provided to the recently
authenticated
user for example Network admin needs
access to the entire network whereas
those working within it probably need
access to only certain areas within the
network based on the network user role
the process of determining the level of
access or permission level is known as
authorization today's Network
architecture is complex and faces a
threat environment that is always
changing and attackers that are always
trying to find and exploit
vulnerabilities these vulnerabilities
can exist in many areas including
devices data applications users and
locations for this reason many Network
Security Management tools and
applications are in use today that
address individual
threats when it's just a few minutes of
down times can cause widespread
disruption and massive damage to an
organization's bottom line and
reputation it is essential that these
protection measures are in place
beforehand now that you know a little
about network security and its working
let's cover the different types of
network
security the fundamental tenant of
network security is the layering of
protection for massive networks and
store data that ensure the acceptance of
rules and regulations as a whole there
are three types the first of which is
physical security the next being
Technical and the third being
administrative let's look into physical
security first this is the most basic
level that includes protecting data and
network to unauthorized Personnel from
acquiring control over the
confidentiality of the network this
include external peripherals and routers
that might be used for cable connections
the same can be achieved by using
devices like biometric systems physical
security is critical especially for
small businesses that do not have many
resources to devote to security
personnel and the tools as opposed to
large
firms when it comes to technical network
security it focuses mostly on
safeguarding data either kept in the
network or engaged in network
transitions this kind fulfills two
functions one is defense against
unauthorized users the other is a
defense against m
actions the last category is
Administrative this level of network
security protects user Behavior like how
the permission has been granted and how
the authorization process takes place
this also ensures the level of
sophistication the network might need to
protected through all the attacks this
level also suggest necessary amendments
that have to be done to the
infrastructure I think there all the
basics that we need to cover on network
security in which our next topic we're
going to go through two mediums of
network security which are the transport
layer and the application
layer so transport layer is a way to
secure information as it is carried over
the Internet with users browsing
websites emails instant messaging Etc
TLS aims to provide a private and secure
connection between a web browser and a
website server it does this with a
cryptographic handshake between two
systems using public key cryptography
the two parties to the connection
exchange a secret token and once each
machine validates this token it is used
for all Communications the connection
employs lighter symmetric cryptography
to save bandwidth and processing power
since the application layer is the
closest layer to the end user it
provides hackers with the largest threat
surface poor app layer security can lead
to Performance and stability issues data
theft and in some cases the network
being taken down examples of application
layer attacks include distributed denal
of service attacks or DDOS attacks h GTP
floods hql injections cross-site
scripting Etc most organizations have an
arsenal of application layer security
protections to combat these and more
such as web application firewalls secure
web Gateway Services
Etc now that we have the theory behind
network security has been covered in
detail let us go through some of the
tools that can be used to enforce these
network security
policies the first two to be covered in
the section is a firewall
a fireball is a type of network security
device that keeps track of incoming and
outgoing Network traffic and it decides
which traffic to allow or deny in
accordance to a set of security rules
for more than 25 years firewalls have
served as Network Security's first line
of defense they provide a barrier
between trustworthy internal protected
and regulated networks from Shady
external networks like the internet at
some point the next tool which can be
used to bolster network security is a
virtual private Network or VPN for short
it's an encrypted connection between a
device and a network via the Internet
the ened connection AIDS the secure
transmission of sensitive data it makes
it impossible for unauthorized parties
to e drop on the traffic and enables
remote work for the user the usage of VN
technology is common in both corporate
and personal networks next we cover the
importance of intrusion prision systems
in network security or IPS Frameworks an
intrusion prevention system is a network
security tool that continually scans a
network for harmful activity and
responds to it when it does occur by
reporting blocking or discarding it it
can be either Hardware or software it's
more sophisticated that an intrusion
detection system or an IDs framework
which can just warn an administrator and
merely identify harmful activities while
in the case of an IPS it actually takes
against that activity the next tool in
this section and the final one are going
to be behavioral analytics behavioral
analytics focus more on the statistics
that are being carried over and stored
through months and years of usage on
some kind of similar pattern is noted
but the it administrator can detect some
kind of attack the similar attacks can
be stopped and the security can be
further
enhanced now that we have covered all
that we need to know about network
security the necessary tools it's
different types Etc let's go through the
benefits of network security as a
whole the first which which is
protection against external threats the
objective for cyber assaults can be as
varied as the Defenders themselves
although they're typically initiated for
financial gain whether they are
industrial spies activists or cyber
criminals these Bad actors all have one
thing in common which is how quick
clever and covert attacks are getting a
strong cyber security posture that
considers routine software updates May
assist firms in identifying and
responding to the abuse techniques tools
and the common entry
points the next benefit is protection
against internal threats the human
aspect continues to be the cyber
security systems weakest link Insider
risk can originate from current or
former workers third party vendors or
even trusted partners and they can be
unintentional careless or downright EV
aside from that the rapid expansion of
remote work and the personal devices
used for business purposes while even
iot devices in remote locations can make
it easier for these kind of to go
undetected until it's too late however
by proactively monitoring networks and
managing access these dangers may be
identified and dealt with before they
become expensive
disasters the third benefit is increased
productivity it is nearly impossible for
employees to function when networks and
personal devices are slowed to a crawl
by viruses and other cyber attacks
during the operation of website and for
the company to run you may significantly
minimize violations and the amount of
long time required to fix the breach by
implementing various cyber security
measures such as enhanced firewalls
virus scanning and automatic backups
employee identification of possible
email fishing schemes suspicious links
and other malicious criminal activities
can also be aided by Education and
Training another benefit is brand trust
and
reputation customer retention is one of
the most crucial elements in business
development customers today place a
premium on maintaining brand loyalty
through a strong cyber security stance
since this is the fastest way to get
other businesses back get referrals and
sell more tickets overall additionally
it helps manufacturers get on the vendor
list with bigger companies as a part of
the supply chain which is only as strong
as its weakest link this opens
possibilities for potential future
endeavors and development and if you
want to Kickstart your career as a cyber
security professional in 6 months then
try giving a short to Simply learn
skeletic cyber security boot camp the
course link is is mentioned in the
description box below that will navigate
you to the course page where you can
find a complete overview of the program
or the boot camp being offered with the
rise in censorship and general fear over
privacy loss consumer security is at an
all-time high risk technology has made
our life so much easier while putting up
a decent Target on a personal
information it is necessary to
understand how to simultaneously
Safeguard our data and be up to date
with the latest technological
developments maintaining this balance
has become easier with cryptography
taking its place in today's digital
world so hey everyone this is B from
Simply learn and welcome to this video
on cryptography but before we begin if
you love watching Tech videos subscribe
to our Channel and hit the Bell icon to
never miss an update from Simply learn
so here's a story to help you understand
cryptography meet an Anne wanted to look
for a decent discount on the latest
iPhone she started searching on the
internet and found a rather Shady
website site that offered a 50% discount
on the first purchase once an submitted
her payment details a huge chunk of
money was withdrawn from a bank account
just moments after devastated and
quickly realized she had failed to
notice that the website was a HTTP web
page instead of an https one the payment
information submitted was not encrypted
and it was visible to anyone keeping an
eye including the website owner and
hackers had she used a reputed website
which has encrypted transactions and
employees cryptography our iPhone
Enthusiast could have avoided this
particular incident this is why it's
never recommended to visit unknown
websites or share any personal
information on them now that we
understand why cryptography is so
important let's take a look at the
topics to be covered today we take a
look into what cryptography is and how
it works we learn where cryptography is
being used in our daily lives and how we
are benefiting from it
then we will understand the different
types of cryptography and their
respective uses moving on we will look
at the usage of cryptography in ancient
history and a live demonstration of
cryptography and encryption in action
let's Now understand what cryptography
is cryptography is the science of
encrypting or decrypting information to
prevent unauthorized access we transform
our data and personal information so
that only the correct recipient can
understand the message as an essential
aspect of modern data security using
cryptography allows the Secure Storage
and transmission of data between willing
parties encryption is a primary route
for employing cryptography by adding
certain algorithms to Jumble up the data
decryption is the process of reversing
the work done by encrypting information
so that the data becomes readable again
both of these methods form the basis of
cryptography for example when simply run
is jumbled up or changed in any format
not many people can guess the original
word by looking at the encrypted text
the only ones who can are the people who
know how to decrypt the coded word
thereby reversing the process of
encryption any data pre- encryption is
called plain text or clear text to
encrypt the message we use certain
algorithms that serve a single purpose
of scrambling the data to make them
unreadable without the necess tools
these algorithms are called ciphers they
are a set of detailed steps to be
carried out one after the other to make
sure the data becomes as unreadable as
possible until it reaches the receiver
we take the plain text pass it to the
cipher algorithm and get the encrypted
data this encrypted text is called the
cipher text and this is the message that
is transferred between the two parties
the key that is being used to scramble
the data is known as the encryption key
these steps that is the cipher and the
encryption key are made known to the
receiver who can then reverse the
encryption on receiving the message
unless any third party manages to find
out both the algorithm and the secret
key that is being used they cannot
decrypt the messages since both of them
are necessary to unlock the hidden
content wonder what else we would lose
if not for
cryptography any website where you have
an account can read your passwords
important emails can be intercepted and
their contents can be read without
encryption during the transit more than
65 billion messages are sent on WhatsApp
every day all of which are secured
thanks to endtoend
encryption there is a huge Market
opening up for cryptocurrency which is
possible due to blockchain technology
that uses encryption algorithms and
hashing functions to ensure that the
data is secure if this is of particular
interest to you you can watch our video
on blockchain the link of which will be
in the description
of course there is no single solution to
a problem as diverse as explained there
are three variants of how cryptography
works and is in practice they are
symmetric encryption asymmetric
encryption and hashing let's find out
how much we have understood until now do
you remember the difference between a
cipher and Cipher text leave your
answers in the comments and before we
proceed if you find this video
interesting make sure to give it a
thumbs before moving ahead let's look at
symmetric encryption
first symmetric encryption uses a single
key for both the encryption and
decryption of data it is comparatively
less secure than asymmetric encryption
but much faster it is a compromise that
has to be embraced in order to deliver
data as fast as possible without living
information completely vulnerable this
type of encryption is used when data
rests on servers and identifies personal
for payment applications and services
the potential drawback with symmetric
encryption is that both the sender and
receiver need to have the same secret
key and it should be kept hidden at all
times Caesar Cipher and igma machine are
both symmetric encryption examples that
we will look into further for example if
Alice wants to send a message to Bob she
can apply a substitution shifer or a
shift Cipher to encrypt the message but
Bob must be aware of the same key itself
so so he can decrypt it when he finds it
necessary to read the entire message
symmetric encryption uses one of the two
types of ciphers stream ciphers and
block ciphers block ciphers break the
plain text into blocks of fixed size and
use the key to convert it into Cipher
text stream ciphers convert the plain
text into Cipher text one bit at a time
instead of resorting to breaking them up
into bigger chunks in today's world the
most widely used symmetric encryption
algorithm is AES 256 that stands for
advanced encryption standard which has a
key size of 256bit with 128bit and 196
bit key sizes also being available other
primitive algorithms like the data
encryption standard that is the dees the
triple data encryption standard 3des and
Blowfish have all fallen out of favor
due to the rise of AES AES chops UPS the
data into blocks and performs 10 plus
rounds of obscuring and substituting the
message to make it
unreadable asymmetric encryption on the
other hand has a double whammy at its
disposal there are two different keys at
play here a public key and a private key
the public key is used to encrypt
information pre-transit and a private
key is used to decrypt the information
post Transit if Alice wants to
communicate with Bob using asymmetric
encryption she encrypts the message
using Bob's public key after receiving
the message message Bob uses his own
private key to decrypt the data this way
nobody can intercept the message in
between transmissions and there is no
need for any secure key exchange for
this to work since the encryption is
done with the public key and the
decryption is done with a private key
that no one except Bob has access to
both the keys are necessary to read the
full
message there is also a reverse scenario
where we can use the private key for
encryption and the public key for
decryption a server can sign
non-confidential information using its
private key and anyone who has its
public key can decrypt the message this
mechanism also proves that the sender is
authenticated and there is no problem
with the origin of the
information RSA encryption is the most
widely used asymmetric encryption
standard it is named after its Founders
reest Shamir and Adelman and it uses
block ciphers that separate the data
into blocks and obscure the information
widely considered the most secure form
of encryption albeit relatively slower
than EES it is widely used in web
browsing secure identification vpns
emails and chat
applications with so much hanging on the
key secrecy there must be a way to
transmit the keys without others reading
our private data many systems use a
combination of symmetric encryption and
asymmetric encryption to bolster
security and match speed at the same
time since asymmetric encryption takes
longer to decrypt large amounts of data
the full information is encrypted using
a single key that is symmetric
encryption that single key is then
transmitted to the receiver using
asymmetric encryption so you don't have
to compromise either way another route
is using the defy helpman key exchange
which relies on a one-way function and
is much tougher to break into the third
variant of cryptography is termed as
hashing hashing is the process of
scrambling a piece of data beyond
recognition it gives an output of fixed
size which is known as the hash value of
the original data or just hash in
general the calculations that do the job
of messing up the data collection form
the hash function they are generally not
reversible without resilient Brute Force
mechanisms and are very helpful when
storing data on website servers that
need not be stored in plain text for
example many websites store your account
passwords in a hashed format so that not
even the administrator can read your
credentials when a user tries to log in
they can compare the entered password's
hash value with the hash value that is
already stored on the servers for
authentication since the function will
always return the same value for the
same
input cryptography has been in practice
for centuries Julius Caesar used a
substitution shift to move alphabets a
certain number of spaces beyond their
place in the alphabet table a spy can't
decipher the original message at first
glance for example if he wanted to pass
confidential information to his armies
and decides to use a substitution shift
of plus two a becomes c b becomes D and
so on the word attack when passed
through a substitution shift of plus
three becomes dww dfn this Cipher has
been appropriately named the Caesar
Cipher which is one of the most widely
used
algorithms
the Enigma is probably the most famous
cryptographic Cipher device used in
ancient history it was used by the Nazi
German armies in the world wars they
were used to protect confidential
political military and administrative
information and it consisted of three or
more rotors that scrambled the original
message depending on the machine State
at that time the decryption is similar
but it needs both machines to stay in
the same state before passing the cipher
text so that we receive received the
same plane text message let's take a
look at how our data is protected while
we browse the internet thanks to
cryptography here we have a web based
tool that will help us understand the
process of RSA encryption we see the
entire workflow from selecting the key
size to be used until the decryption of
the cipher text in order to get the
plain text back as we already know RSA
encryption algorithm falls under the
umbrella of asymmetry key
cryptography that basically implies that
we have two keys at place here a public
key and a private
key typically the public key is used by
the sender to encp the message and the
private key is used by the receiver to
decrypt the message there are some
occasions when this allocation is
reversed and we will have a look at them
as well in RSA we have the choice of key
size we can select any key from a 512
bit to 1024-bit all the way up to a 496
bit key the longer the key length the
more complex the encryption process
becomes and thereby strengthening the
cipher text although with added security
more complex functions take longer to
perform the same operations on similar
size of data we have to keep a balance
between both speed and strength because
the strongest encryption algorithms are
of no use if they cannot be practically
deployed in systems around the world
let's take a 1024-bit key over here now
we need to generate the keys this
generation is done by functions that
operate on past freezes the tool we are
using right now generates the sudo
random keys to be used in this
explanation once we generate the keys
you can see the public key is rather
smaller than the private key which is
almost always the case these two keys
are mathematically linked with each
other they cannot be substituted with
any other key and in order to encrypt
the original message or decrypt the
cipher text this pair must be kept
together the public key is then sent to
the sender and the receiver keeps the
private key with himself in this
scenario let's try and encrypt a word
simply
learn we have to select if the key being
used for encryption is either private or
public since that affects the process of
scrambling the information since we are
using the public key over here let's
select the same and copy it and paste
over
here the cipher we are using right now
is plain RSA there are some modified
ciphers with their own pros and cons
that can also be used provided we use it
on a regular basis and depending on the
use case as well once we click on
encrypt we can see the cipher text being
generated over
here the suder random generating
functions are created in such a way that
a single character change in the plain
text will trigger a completely different
Cipher text this is a security feature
to strengthen the process from Brute
Force methods now that we are done with
the encryption process let's take a look
look at the decryption
part the receiver gets this Cipher text
from the sender with no other key or
supplement he or she must already
possess the private key generated from
the same pair no other private key can
be used to decrypt the message since
they are mathematically linked we paste
the private key here and select the same
the cipher must always be the same used
during the encryption
process one once we click decrypt you
can see the original plane text we had
decided to encrypt this sums up the
entire process of RSA encryption and
decryption now some people use it the
other way around we also have the option
of using the private key to encrypt
information and the public key to
decrypt it this is done mostly to
validate the origin of the message since
the keys only work in pairs if a
different private key is used to encrypt
the message the public key cannot
decrypt it conversely if the public key
is able to decrypt the message it must
have been encrypted with the right
private key and hence the rightful owner
here we just have to take the private
key and use that to encrypt the plain
text and select the same in this
checkbox as well you can see we have
generated a completely new Cipher text
this Cipher text will be sent to the
receiver and this time we will use the
public key for
decryption let's select the correct
checkbox and decrypt and we still get
the same
output now let's take a look at
practical example of encryption in the
real
world we all use the internet on a daily
basis and many are aware of the
implications of using unsafe websites
let's take a look at Wikipedia here
pretty standard https website where the
H stands for secured let's take a look
at how it secures the
data wi shock is the world's foremost
and most widely used Ed Network protocol
analyzer it lets you see what's
happening on your network at a
microscopic level and we are going to
use the software to see the traffic that
is living a machine and to understand
how vulnerable it
is since there are many applications
running in this machine let's apply a
filter that will only show us the
results related to
[Music]
Wikipedia
let's search for something that we can
navigate the website
with okay once we get into it a little
you can see some of the requests being
populated over
here let's take a look at the specific
request these are the data packets that
basically transport the data from our
machine to the internet and vice
versa as you can see there's a bunch of
J giberish data here that doesn't really
reveal anything that we searched or
watched similarly other secured websites
function the same way and it is very
difficult if at all possible to Snoop on
user data this way to put this in
perspective let's take a look at another
website which is a HTTP web
page this has no encryption enabled from
the server end which makes it vulnerable
to attacks there is a login form here
which needs legitimate user credentials
in order to Grant access let's enter a
random pair of
credentials these obviously won't work
but we can see the manner of data
transfer unsurprisingly we weren't able
to get into the platform instead we can
see the data packets
let's apply a similar filter that will
help us understand what request this
website is
sending these are the requests being
sent by the HTTP login form to the
internet if we check here see whatever
username and password that we are
entering we can easily see it with the
wire shark now we used a dummy pair of
credentials if we select the right data
packet we can find our correct
credentials if any website had asked for
a payment information or a legitimate
credentials it would have been really
easy to get a hold of these to reiterate
what we have already learned we must
always avoid HTTP websites and just
unknown or not trustworthy websites in
general because the problem we saw here
is just the tip of the iceberg even
though cryptography has has managed to
lessen the risk of cyber attacks it is
still prevalent and we should always be
alert to keep ourselves safe online and
if you want to Kickstart your career as
a cyber security professional in 6
months then try giving a short to Simply
learn skeletic cyber security boot camp
the course link is mentioned in the
description box below that will navigate
you to the course page where you can
find a complete overview of the program
or the boot camp being offered there are
two types of encryption in
cryptography symmetric key
cryptography and asymmetric key
cryptography
both of these categories have their pros
and cons and differ only by the
implementation today we are going to
focus exclusively on symmetry key
cryptography let us have a look at its
applications in order to understand its
importance
better this variant of cryptography is
primarily used in banking applications
where personally identifiable
information needs to be encrypted with
so many aspects of banking moving onto
the internet having a reliable safety
net is crucial
symmetric cryptography helps in
detecting bank fraud and boost the
security index of these payment gateways
in
general they are also helpful in
protecting data that is not in transit
and rests on servers and data centers
these centers house a massive amount of
data that needs to be encrypted with a
fast and efficient algorithm so that
when the data needs to be recalled by
the respective service there is the
Assurance of minor to no
delay while browsing the internet we
need symmetric encryption to browse
secure https websites so that we get an
allaround protection it plays a
significant role in verifying website
server authenticity exchanging the
necessary encryption Keys required and
generating a session using those keys to
ensure maximum security this helps us in
preventing the rather insecure HTTP
website
format so let us understand how
symmetric key cryptography works first
before moving on to the specific
algorithms
symmetric key cryptography relies on a
single key for the encryption and
decryption of information both the
sender and receiver of the message need
to have a pre-shared secret key that
they will use to convert the plain text
into Cipher text and vice versa as you
can see in the image the key used for
encryption is the same key needed for
decrypting the message at the other end
the secret key shouldn't be sent along
with the cipher text to the receiver
because that would defeat the entire
purpose of using cryptography key
exchange can be done beforehand using
other algorithms like the defy Helman
key exchange protocol for
example for example if Paul wants to
send a simple message to Jane they need
to have a single encryption key that
both of them must keep secret to prevent
snooping on by malicious
actors it can be generated by either one
of them but must belong to both of them
before the messages start flowing
suppose the message I am ready is
converted into Cipher text using a
specific substitution Cipher CER by Paul
in that case Jane must also be aware of
the substitution shift to decp the
cipher text once it reaches her
irrespective of the scenario where
someone manages to grab the cipher text
mid transit to try and read the message
not having the secret key renders
everyone helpless looking to snop in the
symmetric key algorithms like the data
encryption standard have been in use
since the 1970s while the popular ones
like the AES have become the industry
standard
today
with the entire architecture of
symmetric cryptography depending on the
single key being used you can understand
why it's of Paramount importance to keep
it secret on All
Occasions the side effect of having a
single key for the encryption and
decryption is it becomes a single point
of failure anyone who gets their hand on
it can read all the encrypted messages
and do so mainly without the knowledge
of the sender and the receiver so it is
the priority to keep the encryption and
decryption key private at all times
should it fall into the wrong hands the
third party can send messages to either
the sender or the receiver using the
same key to encrypt the message upon
receiving the message and decrypting it
with the key it is impossible to guess
its origin if the sender somehow
transmits the secret key along with the
cipher text anyone can intercept the
package and access the information
consequently this encryption category is
ter private key cryptography since a big
part of the data's Integrity is writing
on the promise that the users can keep
the key secret this terminology
contrasts with asymmetry key
cryptography which is called public key
cryptography because it has two
different keys at play one of which is
public provided we manage to keep the
keys secret we still have to choose what
kind of ciphers we want to use to
encrypt this information in symmetric
key cryptography there are broadly two
categories of ciphers that we can employ
let us have a
look stream ciphers are the algorithms
that en basic information one bit at a
time it can change depending on the
algorithm being used but usually it
relies on a single bit or bite to do the
encryption this is the relatively
quicker alternative considering the
algorithm doesn't have to deal with
blocks of data at a single time every
piece of data that goes into the
encryption can and needs to be converted
into binary format in stream cers each
binary digit is encrypted one after the
other the most popular ones are the rc4
4 salsa and Panama the binary data is
passed through an encryption key which
is a randomly generated bitstream upon
passing it through we receive the cipher
text that can be transferred to the
receiver without fear of man in the
middle attacks the binary data can be
passed through an algorithmic function
it can have either xor operations as it
is most of the time or any other
mathematical calculations that have the
singular purpose of scrambling the data
the